ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
FOR TUESDAY JULY SIX. WE DO NOT
YET HAVE A QUORUM. BUT WE CAN
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE SO WE
WILL DO THAT. SOME HOUSEKEEPING.
THAT WE ARE STILL. UNDER THE
PANDEMIC AND PANDEMIC COOL SO
WE ARE ASKING THAT FOLKS
MAINTAIN. PROPRIA DISTANCING AS
WELL AS WEAR MASKS THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITAL. THEN BE CAUTIOUS
ABOUT SORT OF INTERACTIONS WE
HAVE MULTIPLE WAYS OF
TESTIFYING EITHER HERE IN
PERSON. DURING A REMOTE
TESTIMONY SIDE OR ON THE PHONE
LINES SO IF YOU'RE ITEM COMES
UP JUST RAISE YOUR HAND ALLOWS
YOU TO COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE WE ASKED PEOPLE NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE SO WE CAN
KEEP IT AS CLEAN AS POSSIBLE
FOR OTHERS TO BE ABLE TO USE IT.
AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE
THOSE ARE CERTAINLY AVAILABLE
OUTSIDE THE NORTH SIDE OF THE
CAPITOL. AND THEN THE PHONE
LINES ARE ALSO AVAILABLE. THE
CALL IN NUMBER IS SHOWING
SHOULD BE SHOWING ON THE SCREEN
RIGHT NOW IT IS ALSO AVAILABLE
ON OUR WEBSITE. THE CALL IN
NUMBERS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
AGAIN THAT IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO.
OH TWO THAT'S. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO AND WHEN
YOU CALL IN. THE OPERATOR WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW.
TO GET INTO THE QUEUE ADD TO
WHICH QUEUE THAT YOU'RE IN SO
WE ASK THAT THAT FOLKS PAY
ATTENTION. TO THAT OKAY. GO. SO
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH OUR
ITEM NUMBER ONE ALTHOUGH BEFORE
THAT I WILL NOTE THAT TWO ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT AGENDA HAVE BEEN
PULLED OUT OF EIGHTEEN SB TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT N. ITEM NINETEEN
ACR NINETY FIVE SO THOSE WHO
WILL BE HEARD TODAY WE HAVE
NOTIFIED THE OFFICES
APPROPRIATELY SO WE WILL HAVE
THAT ADDITIONAL WORK TO DO ALL
RIGHT OUR ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
TWO FIFTY TWO. SENATOR WIENER
FULL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN- I WANT TO THANK YOU
AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US AND THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE VERY THOROUGH
ANALYSIS OF THE BILL I
COLLEAGUES SB TWO FIFTY TWO
WILL BE ON THE UNNECESSARY USE
OF DOGS AND CATS IN TOXICITY
TESTING. IN CALIFORNIA- THE
BILL MAY LOOK FAMILIAR YOU
HEARD THIS BILL LAST YEAR- WHEN
THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALLED
LONGER INTRODUCED TO
UNFORTUNATELY HAD TO ABANDON
THE BILL AFTER THE CODE ED-
BILL REDUCTION PROCESS WHEN IN
PLACE- SO WE REINTRODUCE IT
THIS YEAR. IN THE SENATE-
TOXICITY TESTING AS- DEFINED IN
THIS BILL- IT INCLUDES FORCE
FEEDING OR INJECTING ANIMALS
WITH HARMFUL CHEMICALS. TO
EVALUATE THE EFFECTS OF THESE
CHEMICALS AND WHAT THEY MIGHT
EFFECTIVE MIGHT HAVE ON HUMANS.
FOR EXAMPLE PUTTING A DOG IN A
CAGE FOR A YEAR. AND FORCE
FEEDING OF PESTICIDES EVERY DAY
FOR A YEAR JUST TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS. TO IT- IT IS SOME OF
THESE TESTS INVOLVE
INTENTIONALLY OVERDOSING- THESE
ANIMALS- LONG TERM- HORRIFIC
PAIN INTENTIONALLY BECAUSE-
JUST TO SEE WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN-
ANIMALS ARE OBSERVED. TO SEE IF
A BOMB AT TO SEE IF THEY
BELIEVE. MAY BE PLEASE ENTER
VIA DAY AFTER DAY AFTER DAY
AFTER DAY. SEE IF IT DEVELOP
TUMORS AND SEE IF DIE- THIS IS
THESE DOGS AND CATS SUFFER
GREATLY FROM THIS TOXICITY
TESTING. AND WE NOW KNOW FROM
INCREASING EVIDENCE THAT THESE
TESTS ARE REALLY NOT THAT
HELPFUL. IN TERMS OF PREDICTING
IMPACTS. ON THE HUMAN BODY. BUT
CONTINUED TO PERFORM THESE
TASKS AND CONTINUES TO USE
THESE ANIMALS- SOMETIMES IT
APPEARS BY FORCE OF HABIT.
WE'RE JUST BECAUSE THAT'S THE
WAY IT'S ALWAYS BEEN- DRUG
DEVELOPMENT RESEARCH IN
PARTICULAR BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU'VE ALL HEARD FROM- FROM THE
DRUG INDUSTRY- SHOWS THAT
ANIMAL MODELS ARE POOR
PREDICTORS FOR DRUG SAFETY IN
HUMANS. AND KEEP IN MIND THIS
IS TO ABOUT TOXICITY TESTING
ABOUT SAFETY THAT'S A POOR
PREDICTOR 90% OF DRUG DRUGS
THAT ARE FIRST TESTED ON
ANIMALS. ULTIMATELY FAIL WHEN
THEY ARE TESTED OR WARRANTY IN
HUMANS SUBSEQUENTLY-
RESEARCHERS HAVE EVEN EQUATED
PREDICTIONS OF TOXICITY- BASED
ON CANINE DATA. TO BE ONLY
SLIGHTLY BETTER THAN TOSSING A
COIN. IN ADDITION- THE TESTING
PROCESS LACKS TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. IT'S OFTEN
CONDUCTED BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
AND PRIVATE LIVES THAT ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO REPORT WHAT TESTS
THEY ARE CONDUCTING OR WHY. ARE
ONE YOUR PESTICIDE TESTS AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE SPEED FOR A
YEAR ALL THE DOGS ARE KILLED AT
THE END OF THE STUDY IF THEY DO
NOT DIE DURING THE STUDY. THE
EPA ELIMINATED THIS TEST
REQUIREMENT MORE THAN A DECADE
AGO IT'S NO LONGER REQUIRED
THERE COMPANIES CONTINUE TO
CARRY IT OUT. CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN A LEADER IN ALTERNATIVE
TESTING METHODS TO REPLACE
ANIMAL TESTING WITH NEW
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGY- AND
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF EXAMPLES
OF THIS- THE WORK OF COMPANIES
IN CALIFORNIA DEVELOPING
ALTERNATIVES. TO ANIMAL TESTING
IS IMPRESSIVE WE SHOULD BE
ENCOURAGING THE SHIFT. INSTEAD
OF EMPOWERING A VERY
INEFFECTIVE. I STATUS QUO. THE
BILL RINSE. TO PER CITY TESTING
CARRIED OUT ON DOGS AND CATS
THAT SERVE O REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS. IF THERE IS A
REGULATORY REQUIREMENT. FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR FROM
THE STATE THEN THAT'S EXEMPT
FROM THIS BILL WE'RE NOT
LOOKING TO OVERRIDE MANDATE SO
YOU HAVE TO WE DON'T PUT
COMPANIES AND NOT. OPPOSITION
AND THE BILL IS MORE LIMITED
THAN LAST YEAR'S THE LAST YOUR
BILL WENT THROUGH ONE COMMITTEE
AND THEN STOPPED WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH AN ENTIRE HOUSE WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
WE MADE A SERIES OF AMENDMENTS
IN RESPONSE TO FEEDBACK THAT WE
RECEIVED- FROM- INDUSTRY- AND I
THINK IT'S A WELL CRAFTED- BILL-
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THIS BILL
DOES NOT BAN ALL ANIMAL TESTING
IT'S ABOUT TOXICITY TESTING ONE
SPECIFIC FORM AND DOGS AND CATS
THIS BILL IS NOT GOING TO
OFFEND THE BIOTECH INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA THERE'S BEEN AN
INSINUATION OF THAT THAT IS
COMPLETELY BASELESS I HAVE A
LARGE BIOTECH INDUSTRY IN MY
DISTRICT IT'S AN INDUSTRY THAT
I. ADMIRE GREATLY IN TERMS OF
THE LIFESAVING INNOVATION- THIS
IS ABOUT WHETHER THEY CAN
ACTUALLY DO TOXICITY TESTS ON
DOGS AND CATS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- AND THAT'S NOT
GOING TO UP AND THE INDUSTRY BY
ANY STRETCH OF IMAGINATION
THOUGH CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO
INNOVATE HERE TO MANUFACTURE
HERE AND TO DO THEIR GREAT WORK
HERE I TELL YOU THIS IS A BILL
WORTHY OF YOUR SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
WITH ME TODAY TESTIFY ARE
KATHLEEN CONLEE THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF ANIMAL RESEARCH
ISSUES AT THE HUMANE SOCIETY
OUR SPONSOR AND OTHER BARBARA
HODGES A VETERINARIAN WITH A
HUMANE SOCIETY VETERINARY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR I DO HAVE
THOSE TWO WITNESSES LISTED WITH
US ON THE TELEPHONE. KATHLEEN
CONNELLY ARE YOU WITH US. I AM
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES GO AHEAD
PLEASE. RIGHT THANK YOU
CHARACTER ON AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL TWO FIFTY TO THE PET ACT
MY NAME IS KATHLEEN CONLEY AND
I AM VICE PRESIDENT OF ANIMAL
RESEARCH ISSUES FOR THE HUMANE
SOCIETY OF THE UNITED STATES. I
MYSELF WORKED FOR SEVERAL YEARS
AT A PRIMATE BREEDING AND
RESEARCH LABORATORY BECAUSE I
WAS CONCERNED ABOUT HUMAN
HEALTH AND WANT TO FIND CURES
FOR HUMAN BUT I WAS ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT ANIMAL WELFARE
I LEFT THE LAB FOR THE SAME
REASON. I WON FIRST DRESS AT
THIS BILL DOESN'T STOP ALL
ANIMAL TESTING AND RESEARCH
IMPACTS LESS THAN 1% OF ALL
ANIMALS USED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IS NOT A SALES
OR MANUFACTURING BANDS ALSO
DOGS AND CATS ARE USED FOR CODE
RESEARCHER. TESTING RELATED TO
HUMANS. NFL TO GET TWO HAS
SEVERAL. AS VERY NARROW IN
SCOPE SEVERAL. HAVE BEEN MADE
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS BUT SOME
REQUEST SIMPLY HAVEN'T BEEN
FEASIBLE. BUT THERE'S THOSE
THAT MAINTAIN THE STATUS QUO OF
THE MOST RECENT WHICH WOULD
AFFECT THE FEDERAL AGENCY TO BE
PROACTIVE. WHEN IT IS MORE
REASONABLE FOR THE STATE TO
EXPECT COMPANIES TO BE
PROACTIVE. PEOPLE ARE SHOCKED
WHEN THEY SEE IMAGES OF DOGS
SUFFERING IN TOXICITY TESTS AND
TELL ME THEY CAN'T BELIEVE IT
STILL LEGAL. A POLL RELEASED
EARLIER THIS YEAR FOUND THAT
75% OF CALIFORNIANS OPPOSE
TEXAS A TESTING ON DOGS. IN
ADDITION TO THEIR SUFFERING
THERE'S OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE
OF THE FAILURE OF TOXICITY
TESTING ON DOGS. INCLUDING N
SAMPLES OF FARM CHICKEN. AND
THE VALUE OF NON ANIMAL
ALTERNATIVES SUCH AS ORGAN ON A
CHIP TECHNOLOGIES ORGANIZED
SYSTEMS BIOLOGY AND MUCH MORE.
INCLUDING INCREDIBLE. WORK
HAPPENING RIGHT IN CALIFORNIA.
DR GARY FAMILY OF THE SAN FOR
CAN. FINE SUBMITTED A SUPPORT
LETTER THAT INCLUDED EXTENSIVE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE EVIDENCE.
OVERALL RESULTS FROM TECH TO
THE TEST ON DOGS AND CATS WILL
NEVER IMPROVE. WELL THE NON
ANIMAL TECHNOLOGIES WILL ONLY
CONTINUE TO GAIN GROUND SAVING
PRECIOUS TIME IN RESEARCH
DOLLARS. ACTIVITY TESTING ON
THE COMPLIANCE TESTING ANIMALS
AS AN EASY BACK TO CHECK FOR
PRODUCT APPROVAL THERE IS NO
REAL INCENTIVE TO STOP. BUT YOU
ALL CAN HELP WITH THAT IF YOU
FELL IN FAVOR OF SENATE BILL
TWO FIFTY TWO YOU WILL PROTECT
ON THING CANNOT. INCREASE IN A
DECADE- ANIMATION AND BE A PART
OF BY YOUR CONSTITUENTS. I HOPE
YOU. WILL CHOOSE TO DO SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND THEN DOCTOR
HOW. YES GOOD MORNING CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN. GREAT THE
MORNING CARE STONE AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE OTHER DOCTOR
BARBARA HODGES CALIFORNIA
VETERINARIAN PRACTICING SMALL
ANIMAL MEDICINE EXCLUSIVELY
WITH DOCTOR CAPS PATIENTS FOR
THE PAST TWENTY YEARS. I
REPRESENTS THE HUMANE SOCIETY
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WITH APPROXIMATELY NINE
THOUSAND MEMBERS NATIONWIDE
INCLUDING TWO THOUSAND MEMBERS
IN CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB TWO FIVE TWO WHICH
WOULD BAN CRUEL AND UNNECESSARY
TOXICITY TESTING ON DOCTOR CAPS
IN CALIFORNIA. DURING CHECKING
OUT SUCH ARE EXPOSED TO DRAW
PETRIFIED OTHER CHEMICALS AND
OTHER THAN A BIRD. FOR EFFECTS
SUCH AS VOMITING SEIZURES
DIFFICULTY BREATHING HEART
FAILURE OR EVEN DEATH AFTER THE
STUDIES THE ANIMAL SUBJECTS ARE
OFTEN KILLED SO THERE TO SHOOT
AN ORGAN CAN BE EXAMINED.
HOWEVER THERE IS IN FACT A POOR
CORRELATION BETWEEN THE RESULTS
OBTAINED FROM TESTING ON THESE
ANIMALS AND REAL WORLD OUTCOMES
IN HUMANS SB TWO FIVE Q.
ENCOURAGES HUMAN RELEVANT NON
ANIMAL TESTING METHODS WHILE
PROVIDING EXEMPTIONS FOR
MEDICAL RESEARCH DON'T HAVE
MANDATED TO USE ANIMAL. AND
TESTING OF MEDICATIONS AND
PRODUCTS MEANT. FOR DOGS AND
CATS WITHOUT. SB TWO FIVE TWO
ENCOURAGE IS THE DEBATE AND OF
NON. HEALTH TESTING. THAT WOULD
MORE IF INSURE HUMAN AND SAFETY
WELL IT'S KNOWLEDGE IN THE
STRONG EMPATHIC BOND THAT
CALIFORNIANS HAVE WITH
COMPANION DOGS AND CATS.
CALIFORNIA HAS A LONG AND
IMPRESSIVE HISTORY OF ANIMAL
WELFARE LEADERSHIP INCLUDING
PASSAGE OF THE FIRST STATEWIDE
LEGISLATION TO END THE TELECOM
MEDICS KEPT IT ON APPLE'S. WE
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT YES
PIONEERING BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. RIGHT THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB
TWO FIFTY TWO. RIGHT SEE NOT
ANYONE OF THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
SITE. SEE NON OPERATOR WOULD
YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO THE CASE
SUPPORT FOR SB TWO FIFTY TWO.
WE WILL NOT TAKE ANYMORE
TESTIMONY AT THIS POINT BUT
NAME AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT
FOR SB TWO FIFTY TWO. GIFT CARD
SUPPORT OF SB TWO FIVE QUEUE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT IS SUPPORT S. B. TWO
FIFTY TWO. THANK YOU AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE UP TO SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING CARE NUMBER OF
PROPOSALS ON BEHALF OF SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NEXT WE WILL GO TO.
OBSCURED MAINLINE SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO NARWAL
BONTA BOARD MEMBER- AT NINE
OAKLAND GOING INTO STRONG WORK
ETHIC THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS FRANK SHOWN WITH RIGHTS
FOR ANIMALS AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA AT THE TWO
FIFTY G. THANK YOU AND NEXT
WILL GO TO LINE OF FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
JENNIFER HAGUE WITH THE ANIMAL
LEGAL DEFENSE FUND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB TWO FIFTY TWO.
THANK YOU AN EXTRA LINE FORTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
ELIZABETH BAKER ON BEHALF OF
PHYSICIANS COMMITTEE FOR
RESPONSIBLE MEDICINE IN SUPPORT
IF THEY FAILED TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE WILL GO
TO LINE OF FORTY Q. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS MONICA
ANGER BURKE AND ON BEHALF OF
CRUELTY FREE INTERNATIONAL IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO FIFTY TWO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO FURTHER SUPPORT QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION WE-
SORRY GO AHEAD. HOW WE JUST GOT
ONE MORE IN QUEUE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE IT. ALL RIGHT GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU WHITE NINETY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SU WARY
PRESIDENT ALTERNATIVES RESEARCH
AND DEVELOPMENT FOUNDATION
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO
FIFTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE MISTER CHAIR RIGHT NOW
COMBINED NINETY TO NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
PLASTERED WITH THE NATIONAL
ANTI VIVISECTION SOCIETY AND
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF XP
TWO FIFTY KILL. THANK YOU. AND
THERE ARE NO FURTHER ARGUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU WILL BE
ULD LIKE TO STOP AND
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. YOU CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE. STONE HERE.
GALLAGHER THERE. CHAU CHIU
DAVIES GONZALEZ SAID THAT
HOLDEN KALRA KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
REYES ASSEMBLY. ALL RIGHT WE DO
HAVE A CORE SO I HAVE TO
WITNESSES. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WHO ARE
HERE WITH US IN THE ROOM WHERE
A TOP AND JEANS. GRUFFALO
COMING UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BURE'S
DINNER FEEL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ADDITION TO
COS HAD A NET C. N. TA THE BY
THE CALIFORNIA BIOMEDICAL
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION EMBARK ON
CALLER CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS. AMENDED POSITION
ON SB TWO FIVE TWO. THE FIRST
DAY WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
NUMEROUS CONVERSATIONS WE'VE
HAD WITH SENATOR WIENER AND HIS
STAFF ON HIS BILL. THE CENTER
HAS A KEEN KEENE PERSPECTIVE ON
OUR INDUSTRY AND WE'RE THANKFUL
FOR HIS TIME AND ENGAGEMENT
WITH US THANK YOU. THE BASIS
FOR OFFERED POSE LESS AMENDED
POSITION IS STRAIGHTFORWARD.
CURRENTLY BUILT THE BILL
REQUIRES OUR MEMBERS TO GET
PERMISSION FROM THE FDA TO TEST
ON DOGS OR CATS AS PART OF DRUG
DEVELOPMENT. THE FDA DOES NOT
PROVIDE SUCH WRITTEN PERMISSION
NOR IS THERE FEDERAL OUT TOWARD
THE CENTER. TO BE CLEAR THE FDA
HAS NOT DOES NOT. IN THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE WILL NOT
PROVIDE PERMISSION TO ALLOW FOR
SUCH TESTING. WE ABSOLUTELY
AGREE WITH A LOT OF GOALS OF SB
TWO FIVE TO LIMIT SUCH TESTING.
OUR MEMBERS OF STAFF CORPORATE
GOALS TOWARD THAT END. AS AN
ACT OF LAST RESORT NOT
CONVENIENCE OUR MEMBERS TEST ON
DOGS OR CATS IN ONLY ONE HALF
OF 1% FOR MEDICAL RESEARCH AND
TEACHING IN OUR STATE. AND THIS
PERCENTAGE CONTINUES TO
DECLINE. NONETHELESS THE FTA
ANOTHER GLOBAL REGULAR
REGULATORS. RECOGNIZE SIGNS
SHOULD DRIVE WHICH NON RODENT
SPECIES ARE BEST FOR DRUG
ACTUALLY THE NUMBER FOR DOGS
AND CATS CONTINUE TO DECLINE.
OUR MEMBERS ARE ENGAGED
IDENTIFYING REAL RESEARCH
ALTERNATIVES BUT THE SCIENCE
JUST ISN'T THERE YET. ALL CLOSE
BY UNDERSCORING RATHER SHARED
COMMON GROUND. THE BILL WAS
AMENDED TO ALLOW FOR TESTING
SPECIFIC TO ANASTASIA CANCER
TREATMENT ANIMAL VACCINES AND
OTHER ANIMAL MEDICINES. WE
APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT SUCH
EXEMPTIONS OBVIOUSLY THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSORS RECOGNIZE SUCH ANY
SIMPLY WE ASK THAT THIS
RECOGNITION IS APPLIED BROADLY
IN ORDER TO AVOID HAVING TO
PICK WHICH DISEASE FALLS INTO
THE CATEGORY OF BAD ENOUGH. HAS
WRITTEN SB TWO FIVE TWO WILL
HINDER OUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE
THE NEXT POTENTIAL DRUG TO COME
TO MARKET THAT IN THE VERY
LEAST WOULD PROVIDE RELIEF BUT
HOPEFULLY EVEN BETTER SAVE
LIVES THANK YOU AND AVAIL AND
AVAILABLE TELEPHONICALLY CHANCE
FOR MORE TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AS
MARK COLEMAN CEO OF EXPANDED
FEDEX. THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN
THE NEXT WE HAVE MORE A TOP. I
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TIME WHERE A TOP ARE HERE ON
BEHALF OF BIO CALM CALIFORNIA
AND WE TOO ARE HERE REGRETTABLY
IN A POSITION OF OPPOSING LAST
AMENDED. AND JUSTIN MENTIONED-
PHARMACOLOGICAL TESTING ON CATS
AND DOGS IS NOT SOMETHING OUR
COMPANIES DO CAPRICIOUSLY OR
OUT OF CONVENIENCE. IN FACT
QUITE THE OPPOSITE. HOWEVER
THERE IS A MISCONCEPTION THAT
THERE ARE MULTITUDES OF NON
ANIMAL BASED TASKS THAT CAN BE
SUBSTITUTED IN ALL CASES. THIS
IS SIMPLY NOT THE CASE. THE FDA
EXPECTS ANIMAL MODELS SINCE.
MANY TIMES NOTHING CAN REPLACE
THE WHOLE LIVING SYSTEM WHEN
DEVELOPING DRUGS ENGAGING DRUG
EFFICACY AND SAFETY. OUR
COMPANIES USE CATS AND DOGS
SPARINGLY AND ONLY WHEN
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY. 95% OF
ESSENTIAL ANIMAL WORK IS
CONDUCTED ON RODENTS AND ONLY
ONE HALF OF 1% OF SUCH WORKS
WORK TAKES PLACE ON CATS AND
DOGS. BUT WHEN SCIENCE DICTATES
THE NEED FOR USE OF NON RODENT
SPECIES ARE COMPANIES ARE BOUND
TO FOLLOW THOSE SCIENTIFIC
PRINCIPLES. WE TWO ARE MOST
APPRECIATIVE OF THE TIME THE
AUTHOR HAS SPENT IN DISCUSSIONS
WITH US ON THE BILL. RECENT
AMENDMENTS ARE A GOOD START.
WELL THEY PURPORT TO EXEMPT
MEDICAL RESEARCH THE LANGUAGE
REQUIRES A WRITTEN MANDATE FROM
THE FTA. THAT IS NOT HOW THE
FDA OPERATES. THE FDA. ONLY
ONCE THE COMPLETED STUDIES ARE
PRESENTED TO THEM. THIS BILL
THE BILL- RECOGNIZES THIS
INCONSISTENCY BECAUSE IT
PROVIDES A FULL EXEMPTION FOR
VACCINE DEVELOPMENT. WELL WE
CERTAINLY AGREE THAT VACCINE
DEVELOPMENT IS CRITICAL
ESPECIALLY THIS YEAR WE MUST
ENSURE THAT THERAPIES FOR
CANCER AND ALZHEIMER'S FOR NON
OPIOID PAIN RELIEF OPTIONS AND
FOR ALL OTHER CRITICAL HUMAN
HEALTH CONDITIONS RECEIVE THAT
SAME EXCLUSION. THE AMENDMENT
WE SEE COULD NOT PROVIDE A
LOOPHOLE FOR INAPPROPRIATE
ANIMAL TESTING. BUT IS INSTEAD
A RESPONSIBLE AND SCIENCE BASED
SOLUTIONS. AND LASTLY I WOULD
KNOW THE CALIFORNIA ENJOY SOME
OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
PROTECTIONS IN THE NATION FOR
ANIMALS USED IN SCIENTIFIC
RESEARCH. OUR COMPANIES ARE
PROUD OF THE FACT THAT THE
MAJORITY OF AVAILABLE DOGS ARE
ADOPTED TO FOREVER HOMES IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN RESEARCHERS
CONCLUDED. ANIMAL PROTECTION
AND SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH IN
CALIFORNIA ARE NOT MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE OFFER TO FIND AMENDMENTS
THAT CONTINUE TO UP HOLD
CALIFORNIA STRONG ROLE AS THE
WORLD'S LIFESCIENCES LEADER
HOWEVER WITH THE BILL AS IT'S
PRESENTED TODAY WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE. OKAY I UNDERSTAND WE ALSO
HAVE A MARK COLEMAN ON- AS
STAND BY FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS- IS THERE ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION. IN THE ROOM TODAY
AND AGAIN IT WOULD JUST BE.
NAME TITLE IN OPPOSITION. OKAY
SEE NUMBER GO TO THE PHONES DO
WE HAVE ANY. ANYONE CALLING IN
OPERATOR- IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE TWO FIVE TWO. IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO FIFTY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AND THAT'S ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF
S. B. TWO FIFTY TWO. AND MISTER
CHAIR NO ONE HAS QUEUED UP
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION IN Q.
AND DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN THE
CONFERENCE IN ROOM. SEEN NONE
OKAY WE- BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE- ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
NUMBER GONZALEZ. I APPLAUD WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO I AM
CONCERNED THOUGH WITH THE
ISSUES THAT ARE BROUGHT UP- BY
THE COMPANIES AND THE FDA
APPROACH TO HOW APPROVAL WOULD
BE GRANTED- WHAT WHAT ARE YOU.
TRANSYLVANIA I GUESS IN THIS
THANK YOU KNOW AND WE'RE SENSE
OF THE DATA THE BILL THAT THIS
COMMITTEE PASSED LAST YEAR IN
THAT WE STARTED OUT WITH. SAID
FTA HAS TO REQUIRE IT- BASED ON
WHAT WE EARLY ON HEARD FROM THE
INDUSTRY WE CHANGE THAT TO
RECOMMENDS TO MAKE IT LESS-
IRON CLAD BECAUSE WE HEARD WHAT
THEY WERE SAYING- THERE AND NOW
THEY'RE SAYING THAT THEY NEVER
HEAR ANYTHING FROM THE FTA AND
IT'S LIKE A MYSTICAL. BLACK BOX
AND THEY HAVE TO SORT OF THE
DIVINER INTO IT I THINK THE
ANALYSIS ACTUALLY DID THE BEST
JOB THAT I'VE SEEN WITH A VERY
LENGTHY EXPLANATION ABOUT- WHAT
HOW THE FDA HAS ACTUALLY BEEN.
ENCOURAGING COMPANIES- DRUG
COMPANIES TO ENGAGE WITH THE
AGENCY MUCH EARLIER ON THESE
KINDS OF ISSUES SO WHAT THE
VERY THOROUGH DESCRIPTION AND
ANALYSIS IS PRETTY INCONSISTENT
WITH WHAT THE INDUSTRY TO SIGN.
ON WITH THAT THEY THEY PROPOSED
IN THEIR LETTER AN AMENDMENT
THAT WOULD HAVE OBLITERATED. I
MEAN WHAT IF YOU COULD DRIVE A
MACK TRUCK THROUGH A LOOPHOLE
THEY HAVE NOW I SPOKE DIRECTLY
WITH THEM YESTERDAY THEY'RE
GONNA COME BACK WITH SOME
ADDITIONAL IDEAS I WOULD LOVE
TO WORK IT OUT WITH THEM- HI I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN
OPERATIONALIZE. WHAT WE'RE
REQUIRING I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THIS DOESN'T BECOME
SORT OF A DEAD LETTER- AND SO
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK-
WITH WITH THE INDUSTRY TO I
CAN'T GUARANTEE WE'RE GONNA
WORK IT UP A REALLY GOING TO. I
TRY TO ACCOMPLISH WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH THAT
THERE'S SOME SORT OF INDICATION
THAT THE F. THAT THIS IS NEEDED
OR RECOMMENDED- AND SOMETHING
THAT THEY CAN OPERATIONALIZE
THANK YOU I'M- AND I SHOULD
KNOW THIS DOES THIS GO TO
PREPARATION. IT SHOULD BE OUT I
AM I APPRECIATE THAT I'M NOT
VOTE FOR TODAY BUT I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE SOME PROGRESS MADE TO
FEEL THAT YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY-
THIS YEAR SHOWS US MORE THAN
ANY HOW IMPORTANT OF THE
INDUSTRY IS TO AND. ENSURING
THAT GOD KNOWS WHAT CAN COME
NEXT- WOULD JUST WANNA MAKE IT
WORKABLE. ABSOLUTELY WE I
COMMITTEE IT WILL WE WILL DO
THAT I DO JUST WANT ALSO
REITERATE- DIED THIS AND THE IN
THIS WHEN I SPOKE WITH HIM JUST.
ACKNOWLEDGED THE- BECAUSE AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER THERE THERE
WAS AN INSINUATION I THINK THAT
THIS IS SOMEHOW GOING TO UPEND
THE INDUSTRY THIS IS JUST.
ABOUT TOXICITY TESTING
CALIFORNIA IT'S NOT GONNA UP IN
THE INDUSTRY BUT THANK YOU AND
YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT ON THAT.
THANK YOU. NUMBER DAVIS THANK
YOU. SENATOR A QUESTION FOR YOU
WHAT TO WHAT EXTENT WITH THIS
BILL FINANCIALLY IMPACT
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES. NOBILITY
TO MANUFACTURE AND SELL DRUGS
AND OTHER PRODUCTS IN THE
STATE. I THINK NOT AT ALL- THIS
BILL HAS NO IMPACT ON.
MANUFACTURING DEVELOPMENT IT'S
SIMPLY ABOUT THIS VERY DISCREET
AREA. OF TOXICITY TESTING-
THERE YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE OTHER MEANS OF DOING
TOXICITY TESTING. OBVIOUSLY WE
CAN'T DICTATE WHAT HAPPENS IN
THE OTHER FORTY NINE. STATES OR
OTHER COUNTRIES IN TERMS OF
TOXICITY TESTING. SO IT'S NOT
LIKE WE'RE NOT THERE GLOBAL-
BANDAN THIS IS A VERY. LIMITED
PART OF THE PROCESS I DON'T
THINK IT'S GONNA. REALLY
IMPACTS. JOBS OF THE INDUSTRY.
AT ALL OTHER THAN THAT VERY
VERY LIMITED AREA. I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AND IF YOU HAVE THEM IN THE
FUTURE ANY OTHER RELATED ANIMAL
BILLS- WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH
YOU GOOD LUCK TO FIND THE OTHER
ANIMAL. ANIMAL PEOPLE IN THE
LEGISLATURE EFFECT THANK YOU
SOME REMEMBER CRESCENTA. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. OKAY THE SENATOR A I
TO SHARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
AND THAT I HOPE YOU WILL WORK
WITH INDUSTRY ON MAKING SURE
THAT THIS ISN'T GOING TO BE AN
IMPEDIMENT BUT I THINK WE'RE
ALL AGREEABLE ON ON ON THE
HEART OF THIS POLICY- WHICH IS
YOU KNOW ENDING THIS. RICK
STREAM WE LIMIT IN THIS-
TOXICOLOGY TESTING ON YOUR PETS
YOU KNOW OR OR OR OR CATS AND
DOG SO- I WILL BE SUPPORTED
TODAY AS WELL AND I'LL- GO
AHEAD AND- MADAM CLERK PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MYSTICALLY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SAY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NUMBER
OF. THE MOTION IS THE PAST TWO
APPROPRIATIONS STONE. GALLAGHER
HI GALLAGHER I CHAO CHAO HI
CHIU. DAVIES DAVIES I GONZALEZ
AS ALWAYS I HOLDEN. HOLDEN I
KALRA KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I YES FIVE REYES
AYE. OKAY THE BILL IS OUT-
THANK YOU SENATOR PRESHEAF THE
PRESENTATIONS MORE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BECAUSE CRESCENTA.
NEXT WE HAVE MISTER WILL CUT
SENATOR WHAT KASKY PLEASE. YOU
HAVE SB FIVE THIRTY ONE. GOOD
MORNING ARE MISTER VICE CHAIR
OF NUMBERS I'M AT ITS CORE FIVE
THREE ONE IS ABOUT BASIC RECORD
KEEPING AND TRANSPARENCY
PROTECTION FOR CONSUMERS AT
THAT HAVE DEBT IS THAT STUFF
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN WE PASSED THE FAIR
DEBT BUYING PRACTICES ACT WHICH
BROUGHT MUCH NEEDED REFORM TO A
LARGELY UNREGULATED BROKEN
SYSTEM OF DEBT BUYING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THERE WERE
WIDESPREAD COMPLAINTS AT THE
TIME OF COLLECTIONS GOING ON
AGAINST THE WRONG PERSON OR
TARGETING DEBT THAT WAS ALREADY
PAID OFF FOR PAPER EFFORTS TO
CORRECT. WRONG AMOUNT OF DEBT
SO THE THAT ACT HELP ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES BY REQUIRING TECH
BUYERS WHO HAVE DEBT SOLD TO
THEM OPERATIVE VERB IS SOLD AT
TO HAVE PROOF THAT THEIR OF
THEIR OWNERSHIP THAT ALLOW THE
CONSUMER TO- REQUEST THAT PROOF
ALSO THE LOG REQUIRED
DISCLOSURE WITH THE BASIC
INFORMATION ABOUT THE DEBT HOW
MUCH WAS OWED WHAT WERE THE
FEES AND INTEREST. AND THE DATE
OF THE LAST PAYMENT
UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE RECEIVED
REPORTS FROM A LEGAL SERVICE OF
DEBT COLLECTORS WHO ARE GOING
OUT OF THEIR WAY TO ASSERT- THE
ACT BY COLLECTING ON DEBT THAT
IS A SIGN NOT SOLD BECAUSE THE
DEBT IS NOT SOLD ALL THE
CONSUMER RIGHTS AND ALL
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE GIVEN THEM
UNDER THE FAIR DEBT BUYING.
PRACTICES ACT ARE BEING
CIRCUMVENT. DEBT COLLECTORS
SERVE ONCE AGAIN THE SAME- OLD
THERE TARA THE WRONG DEBTORS
COLLECT A INCORRECT AMOUNTS AND
THE CONSUMERS NO WAY TURN THE
TRUTH OF THE- SO THE HIGHLIGHT
THAT INTO SIXTEEN SO THE BUREAU
OF CAN FINANCIAL. FOUND THAT
THE NUMBER ONE CAN ON AGAIN
FINANCIAL IS IN CAL WAS PEOPLE
COLLECTING ON THE WRONG THE
RIGHT FROM THE WRONG PERSON
THERE WERE THREE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED COMPLAINTS AND THAT
ONLY INCLUDED DE- REPORTED
COMPLAINTS TO THE BILL. WOULD
REQUIRED COLLECTOR WHO HAVE
YOU'RE DEALING DEBT SIGN TO
THEM TO HAVE PROOF THAT THEY
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO COLLECT
ON THE DEBT. THE BILL WOULD GET
CONSUMERS THE RIGHT TO REQUEST
PROOF ALONG WITH SOME OTHER
BASIC INFORMATION. REGARDING
THE DEBT AND WITH ME THOSE ARE
THE SAME RIGHT TO BUY THE
WAITER WITH THE FAIR DEBT
BUYING- PRACTICES ACT. LATE
LEAVE FERRON WITH THE PUBLIC
LAWCENTER HI INSTEAD IS HERE TO
TESTIFY I AM TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARTICULATED THE
STAFF REPORT THAT WERE.
NEGOTIATED WITH THE BANKING
COMMITTEE ENTIRE CHINA VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND- WE DO
HAVE- LEE FERRAN FROM THE
PUBLIC LAWCENTER OF. PLEASE I
THINK SHE'S ON THE PHONE. IN
SUPPORT OF. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS LI PARENTS
I'M THE DIRECTOR.
OF LITIGATION
AND PRO BONO AT THE PUMP. I'M
GOING TO REPEAT COLLECTION
LETTERS FROM OUR HAVE BEEN
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN SUED BY
DEBT COLLECTORS. IN SOME
INSTANCES THE DEBT COLLECTORS
HAVE BEEN ASSIGNED THE DEATH
THIS IS COMMON WITH HOSPITAL
AND MEDICAL THAT- WHERE THE
PROVIDER COULD NOT SELL THE
DATA BUT I CAN'T FIND THE RIGHT
TO COLLECT TO A THIRD PARTY
DEBT COLLECTOR. WILL NEED THAT
VERIFYING THE PROTECTION AND
THE REQUIREMENTS AS AN AS THE
SENATOR MENTIONED IN THE FAIR
DEBT BUYING PRACTICES ACT DO
NOT APPLY. TO A DEBT COLLECTOR
THAT DEFINED IT THAT DOESN'T
HAVE TO PROVIDE THE SAME BASIC
INFORMATION. NOTED THAT BY HER
DAD. ONE OF THE FIRST QUESTION
WE ASK OF OUR- AS WELL OR NOT
THE CLIENT IN MILLION THE
TACKLE. MOST IF NOT ALL THE
TIME OUR CLIENTS THEY KNOW
THEY'VE NEVER HEARD OF THEM.
DEPENDING ON THE INFORMATION
PROVIDED IN THE COLLECTION
LETTER OR IN THE LAWSUIT. AFTER
SENATE INVESTIGATION FOR
DISCOVERY- TLT STAFF AND
ATTORNEYS CAN USUALLY FIGURE IT
OUT- WE CAN DETERMINE WHO THE
ORIGINAL CREDITOR IS AND
IDENTIFY THE ACCOUNT OPEN THAT
COLLECTOR IS COLLECTING. HOW SO
MANY DEBTORS ARE UNHAPPY. IN
CALIFORNIA COURT AND MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE STUCK
NAVIGATING THE COMPLEX NETWORK
OF DEBT COLLECTORS AND IF I
NEEDS ON THEIR OWN. AND MAY
NEVER BE ABLE TO GET THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED FROM THE
DEBT COLLECTOR TO VERIFY THAT
THAT. WE THE DEBTORS WONDER THE
DECAL. COLLECTING AND THAT THE
BIG. I HOPE. SB FIVE THIRTY ONE
WOULD LOOK THAT YOU. I THAT ARE
AT. THAT WOULD HAVE TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION. SUCH AS THE NATURE
OF THE UNDERLYING THAT THE DATA
DEFAULT AND THE DATE OF THE
LAST PAYMENT. THE NAME AND
ADDRESS OF THE ORIGINAL
CREDITOR. BASIC INFORMATION
WILL GET BETTER WHAT THEY NEED
TO EVALUATE THAT THAT IT REALLY
THERE'S JUST A DOLLAR AMOUNT
BEING CORRECT. AND HOPEFULLY
ALLOW THEM TO RESOLVE THEIR
DEBT EARLIER ON WITH CONFIDENCE
THAT THAT THAT REALLY IS
SOMETHING THEY ARE. AT THE FIVE
THIRTY ONE WILL ALSO PROVIDE A
DEFAULT JUDGMENT FROM BEING
ENTERED IF THIS INFORMATION IS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE LAWSUIT.
CALIFORNIA BETTER SHOULD NOT
END UP WITH A DEFAULT JUDGMENT
FOR A DEBT COLLECTOR THAT CAN.
EVEN TELL THEM THAT THE
ORIGINAL CREDITOR THAT. I DO
SUPPORT SB FIVE THIRTY ONE IN
THE BETTER AND LYFT. THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU MISS VERNE AND-
DO YOU HAVE- ANY OTHER. PERSONS
IN THE ROOM WANTED TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. C. NINE- ANY FOLKS
IN THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
NONE AND THEN ON THE PHONES
OPERATOR WE HAVE ANY OTHER WE
HAVE ANYONE CALLING IN TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
IF YOU ARE CAUGHT IN AN
UNSUPPORTIVE SB FIVE THIRTY ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
THIRTY ONE. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR
BURKE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COLLECTORS WE
ARE WITH HER DRAWN OUR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL OR NO
LONGER OPPOSE WHEN I THINK THE
OFFERING HIS STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH THIS ON AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU MEXICO CAROLINA ONE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING SURE MEMBERS TYLER
CROWDEN ON BEHALF WITH
INTERPRET BONTA LENDING IN FORT.
THANK YOU NEXT TOOK A LINE OF
ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING BY DAVID
READ ON BEHALF OF THE
RECEIVABLES MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION INTERNATIONAL ARMY
I DO SUPPORT OF THIS. THANK YOU
AND AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE THIRTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
OKAY NO MOVED TO OPPOSITION. I
DON'T HAVE ANY REGISTERED
OPPOSITION TESTIFYING TODAY BUT
IS THERE ANYONE IN IN THE ROOM
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION. TO
THE BILL. C. NONE REMOTE.
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEN NONE-
AND THEN ON THE PHONE DO WE
HAVE ANY PERSONS CALLING IN TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU FOR
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE THIRTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT ONE THEN ZERO
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE THIRTY ONE. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE OF ONE THIRTY YOUR
LINES OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MELANIE CUEVAS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
WE HAVE REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION
FROM THE BILL AND I THINK THE
AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK. THANK YOU NEXT TO
GO TO A LINE OF ONE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS LARRY HOFFMAN I'M
WITH CONSTRUCTION DEVELOPMENT
CONSULTING SERVICES- AND I AM
OPPOSED. THANK YOU AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINES OPEN. HI DON ARE
NOT PERFECT BECAUSE COMMUNITIES
AND I AM OPPOSED TO. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME IT'S CHAIR. OKAY WILL
CLOSE THE PHONE LINES ON THAT
AND BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS YES. MEMBER REYES
SECOND. THERE'S A MOTION BY
MISTER. CHAU AND SECOND BUT
MISS REYES AT SOME CHARGES I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EXPERTISE IN THIS SPACE IT'S
BEEN REALLY IMPORTANT TO HAVE
SOMEBODY WHO UNDERSTANDS THE
SYRIA WHO WHO WAS ABLE TO WORK
WITH OPPOSITION TO COME TO IT
TO CREATE TO BE ABLE TO PRESENT
TO BILLS THAT PROTECT. THE
PUBLIC AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THAT YOU'RE WELCOME THANK
YOU. YOU THE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. FIRST
AS WELL SENATE- LOOKS LIKE YOU
REMOVED OPPOSITION AND WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE NITROGEN I
FELT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THIS MORNING. THANK YOU
SENATOR- MYSTICALLY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
STONE GALLAGHER HI GALLAGHER I
CHILD CHILD BY JUNE. DAVIES
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HOLDEN
HOLDEN I KALRA KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN HI MAIENSCHEIN
REYES RESIDE. THANK YOU MR VICE
CHAIR THANK YOU COMMITTEE THE
BILL IS OUT. THANK YOU CENTER.
ALL RIGHT I THINK WE TO SEE
ANOTHER SENATOR NOW- WE HAVE
SENATORS SKINNER YET. OUR
SERVER LEYVA. FOR CALLING ALL
SENATORS WILL WAIT HERE. THE
LITTLE IN THIS ROOM SHOULD-
SENATE DOWN.
ARE YOU READY.
SENATOR EGGMAN. EUROPE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND HAVE A- HE
WOULD RESIGN THREE BILLS TODAY-
YOU WANT TO START WITH SB THREE
TWENTY YEARS SURE SURE WELL TO
START WITH GREETINGS HELLO
EVERYBODY FRIENDS NICE TO SEE
YOU. I WAS WATCHING FROM MY
OFFICE AND I SO YOU MIGHT NEED
AN AUTHOR SO BEING EVER. EVER
READY. OKAY SO YOU WILL START
WITH. THREE TWENTY CORRECT. YES
THAT IS A PERSON OR OKAY- CAN I
HAVE SERVED WITH A LOT OF YOU
FOR VERY LONG TIME IN THIS YEAR
A LOT OF MY LEGISLATION HAS TO
DO WITH CLEANING UP-
LEGISLATION OF DONE PREVIOUSLY
AND FIXING LAWS THAT I THINK
NEED A LITTLE BIT OF
ADJUSTMENT. SO TODAY I AM
PRESENTING THIS ONE IS- BIBLE
SEVEN I'M DOING THREE TWENTY.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU JUMP IN
LINE THEN YOU CAN'T FIND YOUR
SPOT.
AND WE CAN MOVE TO FIVE
OH SEVEN IF YOU'D LIKE CENTER.
MY BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
IS DIFFERENT IN THE SENATE AND
THE ASSEMBLY AS WE DON'T HAVE A
PORTFOLIO TO MY STAFF IS
CONTINUE TO FIND DIFFERENT WAYS
TO GIVE ME MY MATERIAL IN THIS
WAS A PDF THAT WE TRIED IN THE
NUMBERS DIDN'T WORK ANYWAY HI
GOOD MORNING SB THREE TWENTY
SIX TO BETTER PROTECT SURVIVORS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WELL AS
YOU KNOW CURRENTLY IF SOMEONE
IS A CONVICTED OR THERE'S A
RESTRAINING ORDER DUE TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SOMEBODY MUST
RELINQUISH THEIR GUNS- BUT
THERE IS NO PROCESS FOR THAT TO
OCCUR. SO THIS CREATES A TIP-
DID TO FIX SENATE RULE FIVE
POINT FOUR NINE FOR WHICH
CREATED YOU JUST OVERSIGHT
PROCESS TO ACTUALLY INSURE THE
FIRE ARMS ARE REMOVED- THIS
BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE
COURT COMMUNICATE WITH LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT ABOUT FAILURES
TO RELINQUISH THESE WEAPONS WE
KNOW IN MY WITH MY COMMUNITY
RECENTLY A POLICE OFFICER WAS
SHOT AND KILLED RESPONDING TO A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WHERE GUNS
WERE ON SITE- WE KNOW THAT THE
PRESENCE OF A FIREARM INTO.
HOME INCREASES THE RISK OF
HOMICIDE BY 5100% AND WE KNOW
THAT WOMEN AND SPECIALLY WOMEN
OF COLOR ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY FIRE ARM RELATED
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. EVEN WITH
THE STATE. LAWS WE STILL KNOW
THAT THERE ARE OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
WHO SHOULD NOT HAVE A WEAPON
WHO HAVE A WEAPON. AND THAT ARE
THOSE THAT ARE ONLY. REGISTERED
WITH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO THIS WILL SAY THAT BUT THAT
THAT THEN THERE'S A PROCESS TO
ACTUALLY RETURN THE WEAPONS TO
LET LAW ENFORCEMENT KNOW IF THE
WEAPONS ARE NOT. RETURNED AND
WE THINK THIS WILL GO A LONG
WAY TOWARDS ACTUALLY MAKING OUR
LAWS WORK. AND KEEPING WOMEN
AND CHILDREN AND VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SAFE. WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE A CAT THE SWARM
BURGER. WITH THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION AND THEN ALSO JULIA
WEBB- THE IMPLEMENTATION
DIRECTOR AT GIFFORDS LAW CENTER
TO PRESENT TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE. OKAY THANK YOU
SENATORAND WILL GO TO THE
FIRST WITNESS IN SUPPORT KATHY
HORNBERGER- MOTION BY MEMBER
REYES SECOND BY MEMBER GONZALEZ.
GOING TO PROCEED- WITNESS. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WE HAVE KATHY
HORNBERGER ON THE PHONE. OKAY
HOW ABOUT- JULIA WEBER DO WE
HAVE HER ON THE PHONE. HI YES
I'M HERE THIS IS JULIA WEBER
YOU HEAR ME ALRIGHT YES WE HEAR
YOU GO HEAD. OKAY WELL I
SERVICE IMPLEMENTATION DIRECTOR
AT DIFFERENT LAW CENTER TO
PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE MY NAME IS
JULIA WEBER- WE ARE A CO
SPONSOR OF THE SB THREE TWENTY.
I'M AN ATTORNEY IN SAN
FRANCISCO TEACH DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE LAW GOLDEN GATE
UNIVERSITY AND SERVED AS AN
EXPERT WITNESS IN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CASES- AN APPEARING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF DEFERRED.
I'VE WORKED IN- DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE FIELD FOR OVER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS INCLUDING SEVENTEEN
YEARS THAT THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
WHERE I WORKED ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND CHILD CUSTODY
INCLUDING DEVELOPING RULES OF
COURT. SUCH AS THE ONE THAT SB
THREE TWENTY IS BASED ON- WE
KNOW THAT SB THREE TWENTY WILL
ELEVATE THE IMPORTANT ROLE OF
OUR COURTS LAW ENFORCEMENT AND-
THE ROLE THE COMMUNITY PLAY IN
ENHANCING PUBLIC SAFETY THE
NOTHING BROWN SITUATION. AND WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THE COURTS- HAVE
BEEN CAPABLE OF- FOLLOWING THE
EXISTING RULE COURT FIGHT TO-
COULD USE SOME SUPPORT AND OUR-
LITIGANTS AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC COULD USE SOME SUPPORT
AROUND AS SENATOR EGGMAN NOTED.
THE ACTUAL LOCAL RELINQUISHMENT
PROCEDURES I IN THE MASTIC
FINALS RESTRAINING ORDER CASES
I MOST RECENTLY THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION FOCUSED ON
THE INTERSECTION OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND FIREARMS IN THIS
AREA AND THE NEED FOR
IMPROVEMENT STATEWIDE. SB THREE
TWENTY WILL SUPPORT THAT- ATTY
IT SAID COMMISSIONER- WHO WAS
SLATED TO TESTIFY- I'M SURE
WOULD SAY MORE ON THAT IF SHE
IS ABLE TO JOIN US. AND I AM
HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT-
THIS BILL AND AFFECT THE
FIREARMS RELINQUISHMENT THAT
ANY OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MIGHT HAVE TO THANK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
CENTER ADMIN FOR. YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS. OKAY AND-
JUST ALL TRAFFIC DO WE HAVE
KATHY WARBURG ON THE PHONE. WE
DO NOT HAVE HER AT THIS TIME
OKAY- HOW ABOUT WE GO TO OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN IN THE
ROOM- YES GO AHEAD. ATTACHMENTS
FROM BEHALF OF THE PROSECUTORS
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- DOESN'T LOOK LIKE WE HAVE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES SUPPORT HOW
ABOUT- IN THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION ANYONE. C. NINE HOW
ABOUT ON THE PHONES OPERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANYONE CALLING ON THE
PHONES IN SUPPORT. OF SB THREE
TWENTY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE TWENTY YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE TWENTY.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF-
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND NEXT THREE WILL
GO TO LINE OF ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS A
MONTHLY BASKET WITH THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. SIXTEEN.
OKAY AND AGAIN WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE TWENTY. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE OF TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
OKAY AND NOW WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION WE DID NOT RECEIVE
OFFICIAL OPPOSITION. WITH THIS
INFORMATION- BUT IS THERE ANY
I'M SORRY TO INTERRUPT- WE DID
GET JOINED BY KATHY. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE IT IN THE
PORT. I WILL WITNESS FARGO THAT
YEAH- WE HAVE KATHY HORNBERGER
ON. I WOULD JUST ASK THEM WE'VE
GONE THROUGH A LOT OF-
TESTIMONY SO JUST AS IF YOU
COULD KEEP IT AS- CONCISE AS
YOU CAN. PLEASE PROCEED OKAY
ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
CATHY SCHLUMBERGER AND A MEMBER
OF THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION. HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF ATHLETES THREE
TWENTY I THINK YOU ALL KNOW-
AFSHIN EXISTS TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE THE
EFFICIENCY AND EFFECTIVENESS OF
STATE GOVERNMENT. AND LAST YEAR
WE STUDIED CALIFORNIA'S
RESPONSE IS INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE AS YOU ALL KNOW THIS
AFFECTS ALL CALIFORNIANS OF ALL
BACKGROUNDS AGES AND GENDER
IDENTITY. AND OFTENTIMES IT
ENDS UP WITH DEADLY
CONSEQUENCES. ONE OF OUR STUDY
FOUND THAT 20% OF THE VICTIMS
WERE MURDERED WITHIN TWO DAYS
OF THE ORDER BEING ISSUED A
THIRD WERE KILLED WITHIN A
MONTH. AND SO THAT LED US TO
THE STATE IT'S JUST IMPERATIVE
THAT CALIFORNIA REMOVED
FIREARMS FROM. ECCLES PROFIT.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE GET THREE
TWENTY COUNT CURRENTLY DOES
REQUIRE IN THE FUTURE THE
PICTURE REQUIRED. ORDER TO
RELINQUISH THEIR FIREARMS YES
IN OUR REPORT WE FOUND THAT
THIS JUST WASN'T HAPPENING ALL
THE TIME FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS. SO TO HELP PROTECT
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
THE COMMISSION URGED CALIFORNIA
TO BETTER ENFORCE FIREARMS LAWS
AND ENSURE THAT THESE WEAPONS.
ARE REMOVED IMMEDIATELY FROM
DOLLARS PROHIBITED FROM OWNING
THEM. AND THAT'S THE TWENTY
WOULD CARRY OUT THAT
RECOMMENDATION I ENSURING THAT
THOSE SUBJECT TO A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PROTECTIVE ORDER YOU
RELINQUISH THEIR FIREARMS. SO
IN BEHALF OF THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR IPHONE AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU AND-
WE WILL I DO WE DON'T HAVE
OFFICIAL OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
BUT IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE. WAS ANYONE IN THE ROOM
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
THREE TWENTY. I THINK WE JUST
HAD A LETTER FROM SCO YOU
UNLESS AMENDED- AND THEN- ON
THE PHONES DO WE HAVE ANYONE.
IN OPPOSITION TO SB THREE
TWENTY. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE TWENTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF SB.
THREE TWENTY. MR WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. OKAY GET BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS. MEMBER
GONZALEZ I JUST HAVE A QUESTION
I SUPPOSE IF THEY WERE SERIOUS
ABOUT IT MAYBE THEY WOULD HAVE
BEEN HERE BUT- SEATO POINTS OUT
THAT SOMETIMES THIS IS HELD IN
CONJUNCTION WITH. OTHER
PROCEEDINGS AND IF IT WAS A
FELONY PRECEDING. THAT
OBVIOUSLY I THINK SHIPS MY
OPINION ON REMOTE ACCESS TO A
CERTAIN EXTENT BECAUSE WE DO
NEED THE RECORD BUT DO YOU KNOW
HOW OFTEN THAT'S PAIRED
TOGETHER OR IF THERE'S AN THAT
WOULD CREATE AN EXEMPTION TO
ALLOWING- REMOTE ACCESS. WE
DON'T BELIEVE SO I AND I THINK
A ISSUE IS THERE SOME ISSUE
WITH THE COURT REPORTERS AND SO
ANYBODY WHO'S DOING ANYTHING
REMOTE NOW THEY'RE THEY'RE
COMING TO VOICE WHICH WE
UNDERSTAND WE DON'T WANT TO
LOSE ANYTHING BUT WE ASO KNOW
IN THIS DAY AND AGE THAT WE
NEED TO USE REMOTE WHENEVER WE
CAN. AS EVIDENCED BY OUR
WITNESSES TODAY SO YEAH I AM
CONCERNED- WITH THE SANCTITY OF
THE RECORD IN CERTAIN CASES AND
SO WILL I ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT OF
WE'RE GOING TO SUPPORT THIS I
JUST WAS WONDERING UNDER YEAH.
IF THEY COULD EXPLAIN TO ME OR
I GUESS YOU COULD EXPLAIN TO ME
WHEN THAT MIGHT BE A SITUATION-
BY WHICH WE WOULD. MANDATE AT A
VERBATIM RECORD AND SO IT
WOULDN'T MATTER OKAY I WOULD I.
WOULD ASK MY- MY ATTORNEY ON
THE LINE. ALL RIGHT IS JULIE
WEBER- IF THAT IF. THE SENDER
YOU ASKING FOR MY INPUT YES. R.
YES SO IN THIS BILL THE COVERED
STIVELL RESTRAINING ORDER
MATTER NOT A CRIMINAL MATTERS
AT ALL AND- THE CURRENT WILL
COURT ALLOWS FOR TELEPHONIC
HEARINGS AS WELL SO IT HAS BEEN
THE PRACTICE FOR INSTANCE
TWENTY FOURTEEN OR SO. THAT
HE'S TYPE OF HEARING ASK YOU
DID WAS THE JUDGE'S DISCRETION
CAN INCLUDE THE OPTION OF A
TELEPHONIC APPEARANCE WHICH IS
HELPFUL. ESPECIALLY WHERE
SAFETY IS OF CONCERN FOR FOLKS
APPEARING IN COURT SO THERE ARE
WAYS DURING THE PANDEMIC COURTS
HAVE BEEN HOLDING REMOTE
HEARINGS THERE ARE WAYS TO
ENSURE THAT SOME TYPE OF
RECORD. FINDING STATEMENT OF
DECISIONS AND SO FORTH ARE
DOCUMENTED- BUT IT WOULD BE A
VERY STRANGE TO REMOVE THE SAID
DISCRETION FOR REMOTE
APPEARANCES IN THE CIVIL
MATTERS WHEN THAT HAS BEEN IN
PLACE. PRIOR TO THE
INTRODUCTION OF THE STILL. I
THINK MICHAEL WAS A LITTLE MORE
PEOPLE. I THIS. BY WHICH- I AND
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS TRUE
I'M JUST TAKING THAT LETTER. IS
THIS PAIRED EVER WITH- A FELONY
MATTER. WHAT A HEARING LIKE NO
THESE WOULD BE ENTIRELY STEP
I'M SORRY YEAH THEY BE TWO
ENTIRELY SEPARATE MATTERS
CRIMINAL AND CIVIL PROCEEDINGS
THEY MIGHT BE RELATED IN THE
SENSE THAT THE SAME INCIDENT
RESULTS IN A FELONY CHARGE. AND
THE VICTIMS DECIDE TO GET A
RESTRAINING ORDER BUT THOSE
PROCEDURES WOULD BE HANDLED BY
TWO SEPARATE JUDGES WE DON'T
HAVE JUDGES WHO HEAR BOTH THE
CRIMINAL AND CIVIL MATTERS OF
STATE- AND SO THE FELONY
PROCEEDING WITH- OCCUR
ACCORDING TO CRIMINAL
PROCEDURAL. LAWS RULES
REGULATIONS AND THE CIVIL
MATTER WOULD BE HANDLED
SEPARATELY THANK YOU I WAS JUST
I WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT
BECAUSE IT'S SAID THAT THIS
COULD BE HELD IN CONJUNCTION
WITH IN THE LETTER AND I JUST
WANT TO. BE CLEAR ON MY
POSITION ON- THESE ARE NOT
HEARINGS BUT- I THINK IT'S
BEEN. THINKING. THANK YOU OTHER
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. RIGHT SEEING
NONE SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AB I
THANK YOU DO WE- DO WE HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND ON THIS
ALREADY. DO YOU IT WAS. NUMBER
REYES AND SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ OKAY. THANK YOU
YEAH THIS IS SB THREE TWENTY TO
PASS AS AMENDED. TO
APPROPRIATIONS WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. STONE HI STONE HI
GALLAGHER- GALLAGHER I SHALL.
CHIU DAVIES. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
I HOLDEN. KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN I MAIENSCHEIN II
RES RES I. THE BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU. RIGHT SENATOR ADAM
NINE SB THREE EIGHTY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THIS IS ALSO A BILL
THAT YOU MIGHT RECALL THAT I'VE
WORKED ON SOME BEFORE- I'M
TODAY I'M PRESENTING SP EIGHTY
WHICH MAKES REVISIONS TO THE
END OF LIFE OPTIONS ACT THAT I
INITIALLY AUTHORED IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND WANTED TO AFFECT IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN. SINCE THE BILL
ORIGINALLY PASSED IN AS I
COMMITTED AT THE TIME OF ITS
PASSAGE I HAVE HELD A MULTIPLE
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS AND WE HAVE
REVIEWED THE DATA COLLECTED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
EVERY YEAR- WE UNDERSTAND THAT
WHEN THE BILL WAS FIRST PASSED
WE PUT IN A LOT OF SAFEGUARDS
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE. THAT THE
BILL WAS NOT ABUSED IT WAS A
LOT OF FEAR THAT- PEOPLE WOULD
BE TAKING IT HAPHAZARDLY OR
THAT OLDER PEOPLE WOULD BE THE
FIRST TO USE IT OR THAT THAT WE
WOULD WE WOULD THAT GET RID OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND POOR
PEOPLE- AND WE HAVE FOUND THAT
NOT TO BE TRUE- THE DATA HAS
BEEN CONSISTENT OVER THE FIVE
YEARS THAT WE'VE COLLECTED IT
WHICH HAS BEEN CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT'S BEEN WHAT HAS BEEN
COLLECTED AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THERE HAS NOT BEEN ONE EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION FOR- OR ANY KIND
OF PROBLEMS BUT WHAT WE HAVE
FOUND IS THAT WHILE THE
SAFEGUARDS ARE PUT IN PLACE TO
MAKE SURE HAT EVERYTHING WENT
AS PLANNED- THE SAFEGUARDS HAVE
NOW BECOME BARRIERS TO BE ABLE
TO ACCESS THE BILL. AND I KNOW
THAT'S WHAT NOT NOBODY NOBODY
WANTS THAT- ONCE A FROM KAISER
SHOW THAT ABOUT ONE THIRD OF
TERMINALLY ILL ADULTS WHO
REQUEST TO USE THE ACT ACTUALLY
DIE BEFORE THEY ARE ABLE TO USE
IT- OFTENTIMES DYING IN THE
VERY WAY THAT THEY MOST FEARED
THAT THEY WOULD DIE- IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. OREGON AUTHORIZED A
WAIVER OF THE FIFTEEN DAY
WAITING PERIOD BETWEEN REQUESTS
AND NEW MEXICO RECENTLY PASSED
IT WITH A FORTY EIGHT HOUR
WAITING PERIOD SO AS YOU RECALL
WHEN SOMEONE HAS A TERMINAL
ILLNESS FROM WHICH NO CURE IT'S
EXPECTED WHICH MEETS THE
HOSPICE CRITERIA AND ALMOST 90%
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE USED THIS
OUR HOSPICE PATIENTS AND ARE IN
HOSPICE. OFTENTIMES HAVING
FOUGHTTHEIR DISEASE FOR YEARS.
AND NOW AT THE END OF THEIR
LIFE- WE PUT IN FOR. DAYS THAT
INITIAL. AND THEN A FOLLOW UP
IN WRITING. WITH WITNESSES AND
THEN A SECOND REQUEST FIFTEEN
DAYS LATER. AND THEN THERE WAS
A FOURTH AND FINAL ATTESTATION
AT THE VERY END. SO WHAT WE ARE
ASKING NOW IS THAT WE WOULD
PREDICT TAKE THAT FIFTEEN DAYS
TO A TWO DAY A FORTY EIGHT HOUR
WAITING PERIOD. WE HAVE WORK
WITH THE CALIFORNIA. MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION. EVERYBODY
IS OKAY WITH THIS- WE'VE ALSO
COME TO REALIZE THAT THAT FINAL
AND FOURTH ATTESTATION FEELS
REDUNDANT AND SOMETIMES
INSULTING TO PEOPLE IF THEY
HAVE TO FILL IT OUT WITHIN
FORTY EIGHT HOURS AT THE TIME.
THAT THE INGEST THE MEDICATION
THAT YES THEY KNOW AND YES THEY
ARE NOT BE COATED PERSON YES
THEY ARE STILL SURE. US WERE
ASKING TO GET RID OF THAT. AND
WE'RE ALSO ASKING TO GET RID OF
THE SUNSET THIS IS MY FINAL
TERM- THERE HAS BEEN NO
EVIDENCE OF ABUSE OF THIS BILL-
AND TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
SOMETHING IN PLACE. FOR PEOPLE
AND THEN TAKE IT AWAY FROM
THEM- DOESN'T SEEM DOESN'T SEEM
RIGHT AND SO WE'RE ASKING TO
GET RID OF THE SUNSET. THE DATA
WILL STILL BE COLLECTED EVERY
SINGLE YEAR THE DEPARTMENT OF.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH WILL STILL MAINTAIN ALL
OF THE DATA. THAT HAS BEEN- A
PART OF THAT ONE OTHER PART
THAT WE'RE GOING TO ADJUST ON
THE BILL IS ALSO- TO MAKE
DOCUMENTATION MORE CLEAR-
OFTENTIMES WHAT HAPPENS IS
SOMEBODY HAS TALK TO THEIR
PHYSICIAN THEY'RE ATTENDING
ABOUT THIS AND- THE PERSON
MIGHT SAY OKAY. BUT THEN WHEN
pIT'S ACTUALLY TIME THEY'RE LIKE
WELL I DON'T WANT TO
PARTICIPATE WE'RE ASKING THAT
THAT BE DOCUMENTED RIGHT AWAY.
AND AS SOON AS I REQUEST IS
MADE. AT THE TRANSFER THAT THAT
PATIENTS MEDICAL RECORDS TO A
SECOND POSITION. THAT THAT
REQUEST THAT BE HONORED AND
DOCUMENTED RIGHT AWAY- SO THOSE
ARE THE AREAS THAT WE ARE
WORKING IN AND ALSO TO BE ABLE
TO SAY- BECAUSE OFTEN TIMES
WHEN IT WHEN A POSITION IS
GOING TO PRESCRIBE THEY SEE
CAN'T TAKE THIS IN A PUBLIC
PLACE. WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT DOES NOT
MEAN A HOSPITAL YOU ARE ALLOWED
TO USE IT IN HOSPITAL IF A-
HOSPITAL IS A- IS PARTICIPATING
OR- DOESN'T HAVE LAWS. THAT
BEARD THAT BAR PEOPLE FROM
BEING ABLE TO UTILIZE. A LOT
LIKE THIS. SO. THAT IS THAT
WHAT WE'RE ASKING IN THIS BILL
TO TAKE IT FROM FIFTH. DAY TO
FORTY EIGHT AS PROVED BE A BEAR-
WE ARE ASKING. THAT WE REMOVE
THE SUNSET. WE'RE ASKING THAT
THE DOCUMENTATION BE MORE CLEAR
AND WE'RE ASKING THE FINAL
ATTESTATION BE REMOVED AND WE
ARE ASKING. THAT THE- THAT IT
BE CLEARLY DOCUMENTED THAT THIS
CAN BE DONE IN IN A- IN A
HOSPITAL SETTING AT THAT WASN'T
MEANT TO BE LIKE A PARK. OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT- SO WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE. A DOCTOR
KATHERINE. FORREST AND DIE IN
DR RYAN SPIELVOGEL- TO SPEAK
WITH ME. IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
TO HAVE THOSE TWO WITNESSES
LISTED DR FORCED AND DOCTOR
SPIELVOGEL BOTH ON THE
TELEPHONE. DR FOR STORY WITH US.
HERE CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN.
HI MY NAME IS DR CAPITOL QUITS
WORK IN A CLINICAL ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR OF FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY MEDICINE AND PUBLIC
HEALTH SPECIALIST. THE
CALIFORNIA END OF LIFE OPTION
TICKET BACK I PRESCRIBE MEDICAL
AID IN DYING FOR NUMEROUS
CURRENTLY L. CALIFORNIANS IN
NINETEEN HUNDREDS OF
SUGGESTIONS AND BEST PRACTICES
CORRECT THAT RIGHT. RIGHT NOW
I'M BEFORE YOU SPEAKING AS A
LIFE PARTNER SOMEONE WHO JUST
LAST WEEK. NEW MEDICAL A IN
DYING PEOPLE AND HIS TERMINAL
FACTORING. IN APRIL WEALTHY
THANK THIRTY SEVEN YEAR WITH
DIAGNOSED WITH THE DISEASE AND
THOUGHT TO BE A LS AFTERNOON
LOU GEHRIG'S. BUT WITH MATH
MORE INTENDED AND DEADLY AN
UNDERWEIGHT FROM THE VISIT WITH
A TERM POSITION WITH HER DIED
IS CONFIRMED TURNED TO ME THAT.
HAPPENED IF YOU WOULD NOT BY
THE LEGAL RIGHT FOR ME TO USE
MEDICAL AID IN DYING HEY FROM
NEVER THAT FROM SUFFERING I
WOULD BE TERRIFIED EVERY
REMAINING MOMENT OF MY LIFE I
WOULD BE. ABSOLUTELY TERRIFIED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. BUT THE
ACTUAL STEPS ACCESS THE OP OR
NOT YOU EVEN FOR. THANK WE NEED
TO START THE PROCESS EARLY BUT
MOST PEOPLE DON'T WORK PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIAN COULDN'T SUPPORT
HIM BECAUSE HIS OFFICE HAD BEEN
TAKEN OVER BY THE CATHOLIC
SYSTEM WHICH PROHIBITS DOCTORS
FROM EVEN PARTICIPATING IN
THEIR CLOTHES. AND WE
PARTICIPATING LUCKILY WILL WAS
ABLE TO ACCESS A LOT AT
STANFORD AND I ACTUALLY SET UP
THEIR SYSTEM WHEN I WOULD
CONTACT THE PEE CARE. MIGHT
NEVER IMAGINE MY HUSBAND GO
THROUGH. THE PROCESS AND NOT A
FIVE. WELL SEPARATE MEN AIMS
ABOUT WHETHER HE BE ABLE TO
SURVIVE THE FIFTEEN WAITING
PERIOD THAT'S BECAUSE
CONDITION. RAPIDLY TO HEAR. IT
IN FACT THE PROCESS TOOK
UPWARDS OF A MONTH FOR. BUT
DESPITE THE BARRIERS HE FACED
MY WELL WOULD BE ABLE TO
PEACEFULLY AND THAT BRING THANK
OWN. AND I REPEAT YEAR YEAH ON
SB. NOT ONLY FOR THE DOESN'T OF
PATIENTS. THREE FIVE. OUR
PURPOSE FIVE MATH BUT ALL FOR
THE TWO OF THEM MINE BY. WELL
FOR IT. THANK YOU DOCTOR FORCED
TO. AS A PER SIDE I'VE NO
DOCTOR A WILL FOR A NUMBER OF
YOU AND FORCE. I I'M SO SORRY
FOR YOUR LOSS WHO'S- AN AMAZING
MAN AND YOU ARE VERY BRAVE TO
BE HERE TESTIFYING TODAY. SO
SOON AFTER THANK YOU WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOU. OKAY. SO
DOCTORS SILVA WILL. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN'T. EIGHT
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE IT
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
FOR ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY
TODAY AND ALSO THANK YOU
CATHERINE FOR THAT FOR THAT
TESTIMONY- MY NAME IS DR RYAN
SPIELVOGEL AND I AM A FAMILY
DOCTOR HERE IN SACRAMENTO. I
HAVE SUPPORTED MY PATIENTS
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA END OF
LIFE OPTION IT SINCE TWENTY
SIXTEEN. BECAUSE IT'S A VERY
POWERFUL TOOL FOR THEM AT THE
END OF THEIR LIVES TO BE ABLE
TO GET A LITTLE BIT OF THAT
POWER BACK. UNFORTUNATELY MANY
PATIENTS ENCOUNTER OBSTACLES
TRYING ACCESS MEDICAL AID IN
DYING. IN ONE OF THOSE BIGGEST
OBSTACLES WHICH YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD ABOUT TODAY'S THE FIFTEEN
DAY WAITING PERIOD. I HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY KNOWN TOO MANY
PATIENTS WHO HAVE DIED DURING
IT. HOW ONE THAT COMES TO MIND
OFTEN IS A PATIENT OF MINE HIS
NAME WAS TIM. HE WAS A DENTIST
WHO WORKED WITH DOCTORS WITHOUT
BORDERS FOR MANY YEARS BEFORE
HE DEVELOPED PAYLESS. AND I
RECALL QUITE VIVIDLY AND WITH
NOT A SMALL AMOUNT OF PAIN HOW
HE BEGGED ME TO BEND THE RULES
IN PRESCRIBED AID IN DYING
MEDICATION BEFORE THE FIFTEEN
DAY WAITING PERIOD WAS OVER.
BECAUSE HE HAD PROGRESSED SO
RAPIDLY THAT WE BOTH. KNEW THAT
HE MIGHT NOT MAKE IT THROUGH.
HAVE COURSE I KNEW THAT I
COULDN'T BUT HIS SUFFERING WAS
WAS REALLY PALPABLE IN IT
PULLED AT ME. AND HE DIED ON
THE LAST DAY OF THE WAITING
PERIOD. TO AN OUTSIDE OBSERVER
MANY SUCH DEATHS MIGHT SEEM
SERENE AS A PATIENT IS PUMPED
FULL OF MEDICATIONS TO HELP
THEM NOT FEEL DISCOMFORT. BUT
TO MANY OF THESE PATIENTS EVERY
WAKING MOMENT BECOMES A SPECIAL
TYPE OF TORTURE. AS A PHYSICIAN
WHO SEES HOW IMPORTANT THIS LAW
WORKS AND HOW IT WORKS ON THE
GROUND I URGE YOU TO VOTE YES
ON SB THREE EIGHTY. IT STILL
MAINTAINS THE DOZEN COURSE
SAFEGUARDS THAT PROTECT
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND
REMOVE UNNECESSARY BARRIERS
THAT PREVENT DYING CALIFORNIA'S
FROM ACCESSING THE LOG. IS A
POWERFUL TOOL FOR RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE FOR THE TERMINALLY ILL
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE NO
CONTROL OVER WHAT'S HAPPENING
TO THEM. AND THEIR BODIES
DURING A PIVOTAL POINT IN THEIR
LIVES PLEASE VOTE YES ON SB
THREE EIGHTY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OTHERS
WHO WANT TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR SB THREE EIGHTY IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
RIGHT SEEN THAT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB
THREE EIGHTY WE'RE TAKING AGAIN
NAME AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL. DO YOU HAVE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE EIGHTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF S. B.
THREE EIGHTY. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RECTANGLE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
NURSES ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF FIFTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THREE R.
SB THREE EIGHTY. THANK YOU NEXT
WE WILL GO TO A LINE OF ONE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS CATHERINE DODD
REGISTERED NURSE AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
JOHN STANLEY FROM CONSTANT USE
MEDICAL AID IN DYING TO AND
HE'S SUFFERING I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB THREE EIGHTY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE OF FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS JULIE STROUD I'M THE
DAUGHTER OF A LONG TIME UC
BERKELEY PROFESSOR WHO ACCESS
BUT DID NOT ULTIMATELY UTILIZED
MEDICAL AID IN DYING. IN
EMPHATIC SUPPORT OF SB THREE
EIGHTY. THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE OH TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS SHARON
CELLS AND I HAVE BEEN MARRIED
SO USE THE END OF LIFE OPTION
ACT IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE
EIGHTY AND URGE YOU TO DO THE
SAME THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
ALLEN HAMMER I LIVE WITH
INCURABLE CANCER AND A BRAIN
TUMOR. PLEASE SUPPORT SB THREE
EIGHTY FOUR YES. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE IS SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES HI
I'M MICHAEL WITTY W. I. T. T.
E. I'M THE CHIEF MEDICAL
OFFICER OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY CARE ASSOCIATION THE
FAMILY POSITION. IN- A STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE END OF LIFE
OPTIONS ACT SP THREE EIGHTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE
WILL GO TO LINE OUT ONE OH
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS KATIE HOGAN I'M
FIFTY TWO YEARS OLD AND LIVING
WITH A TERMINAL CANCER IN
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND I'M
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF SB.
THREE EIGHTY. DO YOU NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE A ONE ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
AMANDA BE A GUEST ON THE WINDOW
OF CRAIG DAVID IT WASN'T
FORTUNATELY UNABLE TO ACCESS
THE LOCK AT THE THREE EIGHTY
WOULD HAVE PREVENTED HIS
IMMENSE SUFFERING SO I URGE YOU
TO PLEASE VOTE YES. ON SB THREE
EIGHTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS MARGARET URBAN AND I'M
A HOSPICE SOCIAL WORKER AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
PLEASE VOTE YES. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE SIXTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
ONE SIX THREE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE A
ONE OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS MARK BLOOMBERG SAN
FRANCISCO TAXI DRIVER IN MEMORY
OF CREW OF GRAPHIS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE. ONE
FORTY SIX. HELLO MY NAME IS DAN
DEALS I AM BRITNEY MINARD
HUSBAND AS A LOT YOU KNOW ONE
OF THE CATHOLIC I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB THREE EIGHTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TO
LINE ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
BONNIE MCKEE AGAIN I AM A
SOCIAL WORKER AND MY MOTHER
USED MEDICAL AID IN DYING IN
GRASS VALLEY. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB THREE EIGHTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF ONE SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE ONE SIXTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IT MAY MY NAME IS
GEARING AND- NOT MY BEST FRIEND
USED THE IN FLIGHT OPTION ACT
AND I WAS WITH HER AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE
EIGHTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS SAM TRAD I'M THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR CAMPAIGN
DIRECTOR FOR COMPASSION AND
CHOICES ACTION NETWORK WE ARE
THE BILL SPONSOR AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE
EIGHTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO BORDERLINE OF ONE SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM
DOCTOR PAUL CHANDRA A LATE
STAGE FOUR CANCER PATIENT ALSO
A RETIRED EYES CHIU DIRECTOR
AND ASSISTANT CLINICAL
PROFESSOR OF NEUROSURGERY AT
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO. PLEASE SUPPORT SB
THREE EIGHTY. THANK YOU AND
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE A ONE
FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO TOMITA FAMILY PHYSICIANS
SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT OF. THREE
EIGHTY. THANK YOU MEXICO TO
LINE OF ONE SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DR MYRON TURBO
I'M RETIRED OPPOSITION AND
MEDICAL ONCOLOGIST AND I URGE
THE COURT TO AND PASSAGE OF THE
SB THREE EIGHTY. THANK YOU AND
NEXT OVER TO LINE ONE L. THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE CAMPBELL- MY HUSBAND
USED THE END OF LIFE OPTION
AFTER A YEAR AND A HALF AGO AND
I AM A STRONG SUPPORTER OF S.
B. CREATING. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF WHAT ONE
SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JOHN COMING LOOSE HOSPICE
MEDICAL DIRECTOR. ACTIVE
PRESCRIBER AT THE END OF LIFE
OPTION ACT MEDICATIONS PLEASE
VOTE YES ON SB THREE EIGHTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
RIGHT THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
MOVE INTO OPPOSITION WE HAVE
DOWN- ANSWERING ALVAREZ BOTH
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS.
THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DOWN OPEN
PLUS AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
THREE EIGHT ZERO- SEE IF I'LL
SEE WHERE STATEWIDE MEMBERSHIP
ASSOCIATION OF ABOUT TWENTY
FOUR OUT OF CALIFORNIA'S.
TWENTY EIGHT INDEPENDENCE
ENTERS AND WE REPRESENT ABOUT
THIRTY SIX OF THE EIGHT
COUNTIES IN THE STATE-
PROVIDING PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
FOR THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES ACROSS THE
STATE- WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
END OF LIFE ACT BACK IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN. AND TODAY AS VERY
EXAMINE THIS TO- WE POSE THE
CHANGES DETAILED IN THIS BILL
SB THREE EIGHTY. WE BELIEVE
IT'S HIGHLY PREMATURE TO REMOVE
THE TWENTY TWENTY SIX SUNSET
CLAUSE FROM CURRENT LAW. AND AS
A MATTER OF A PRACTICE. IN THE
IN THE IN THIS BUILDING- SUNSET
PROVISIONS ARE KEY TOOL USED BY
THE LEGISLATURE TO FORCE THE
LEAD TO. REVIEW HOW LAWS
FUNCTIONING EXAMINE EVERYTHING
FROM THE PLANTATION TO
ENFORCEMENT. TO IF THE LAWS
EVEN BEING UTILIZED INTENDED.
IN SB THREE EIGHTY BY REMOVING
THE CLAUSE FIVE YEARS EARLY WE
FEEL IT'S MUCH TOO SOON.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE LACK OF-
REAL DATA AVAILABLE TO
DETERMINE THE VERY REAL AND FAR
REACHING IMPACTS OF THIS LAW.
INCLUDING BRING INTO LIKE ANY
ABUSES OR MISCONDUCT- THE
PROBLEM WE'RE FACING DAY THAT
THAT THERE IS A VERY SERIOUS
ABSENCE OF THE DATA WE MAYBE
MANY WHEN I SAY THIS MEANS
THERE ARE NO ABUSES ARE
CONCERNS. INSTEAD THIS IS
ACTUALLY INDICATIVE OF A MUCH
BROADER PROBLEM. THE NON
COMPLIANCE A NON REPORTING A
SIGNIFICANT DATA POINTS IN
RELATION TO THOSEWHO UTILIZE
PROVISIONS OF CURRENT LAW. A
COUPLE AREAS OF CONCERN. WITH
THE CURRENT DATA WE DON'T HAVE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT.
PATIENTS ILLNESSES EVEN WERE-
WHEN THERE'RE CONCERNING THE
MEDICATION. THERE NO STATS
ABOUT REFERRALS FOR
PSYCHOLOGICAL EVALUATIONS- WE
FEEL THERE. ARE BEEN NO REASONS
LISTED FOR PATIENTS DEATH
REQUESTS UNLIKE IN OTHER STATES.
AND WE DON'T THINK IS DATA
RELATED TO THE MOST CRITICAL
TIME IN THE WHOLE PROCESS WHEN
THE PATIENT AND JUST LEGAL
DRUGS- MOVING ON. WE FEEL THAT-
WE DON'T SEE ANY REQUIREMENT
FOR SOMEONE TO BE PRESENT AT
THE TIME OF THE INGESTION. NOT
PRESCRIBING DOCTOR NORTE
OBJECTIVE WITNESS YOU CAN
REPORT BACK TO US THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTH. AND WE
DISAPPROVED SB THREE EIGHTY
WITH THE SENSOR CLOTHING
REMOVED IT'S TOO PREMATURE. AND
ON BEHALF OF SEE IF I'LL SEE I
STRONGLY URGE OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. SO THEN WE HAVE SERRANO
OVER IT. YEAH. GOOD MORNING
SERENA ALVAREZ EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SALVADORI OVER
IS INSTITUTE FOR NONVIOLENCE
I'M HERE REPRESENTING SENIOR
THE TEEN EXPEL US FROM OUR
INSTITUTE AS WELL AS CALIFORNIA
LUWAK UNDER THE DELEGATED
AUTHORITY OF OUR STATE DIRECTOR
JOSE BARRERA LUWAK IS BEEN
AROUND LEADING CIVIL RIGHTS FOR
NINETY YEARS AND I'M HERE
CARRYING A BINDER OF THE LIEU
LACK POLICY GUIDANCE WITH
STANDING RESOLUTIONS THAT THAT
PRECEDED THE PASSAGE OF THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN LAW BACK TO TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT SIGNED BY
ROSA ROSE ALL IS THAT
NATIONALLY LACK THE HUMAN AT
LEAST- DENIES THE ASSISTED
SUICIDE IS A HEALTH CARE MODEL
FOR OUR FAMILIES WHO ARE DENIED
DALY AT THEIR HEALTHCARE RIGHTS
TO BASIC CARE. PRIMARY CARE
WERE FIRST IN THE STATE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS FIRST IN
STATE FOR END OF LIFE FRAUD HOW
IT IS THAT YOU ARE PASSING
BILLS AT THIS VERY MOMENT TO
ADDRESS THE L. A. TIMES
ARTICLES THAT SAY THAT RAMPANT
FRAUD THE FEDERAL REPORT LAST
YEAR. FEDERAL LAST YEAR I DID
FEDERAL PARTY JENNIFER
CALIFORNIA'S LEADING THE NATION
IN SERIOUS COMPLAINTS
INSPECTION CONCERNS SUBPAR CARE
HOSPICES L. A. TIMES NEW BILLS
TARGET ABUSES IN STATE HOSPICES
TO ST. THE TIMES INVESTIGATION
FOUND AN EXPONENTIAL MOVING
HOSPICE PROVIDERS THAT
TRANSFORMED END OF LIFE. CARE
AND IT'S DOMINATED NOW BY
PROFIT DRIVEN OPERATORS YOU GOT
SB SIX SIXTY FOUR YOU'VE GOT AB
TWELVE EIGHTY AND YOU HAVE. ON
THE SICK AND DYING IS
DESPICABLE AND UNACCEPTABLE
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE NATION IN
HOSPICE FRAUD THESE BILLS ARE A
FIRST STEP. BUT EVERYTHING'S
GOING FINE IN END OF LIFE
ASSISTED SUICIDE WHAT WE
CONGRESS ALSO SEES THIS
CONGRESS IS ACTING IN SEIZE THE
NEW MEASURES THAT BEFORE
CONGRESS. THAT QUALITY OF
FAILURES IN HOSPICE INCLUDE THE
SPANISH MEDIC MEDICATIONS ALSO
DAILY TIMES NEGLECTED WAS
INFESTED WITH MAGGOTS EVEN IN
THE FACE OF SUCH BAYLOR'S
HOSPICES. HAVE RARELY BEEN
PENALIZED LARGELY BECAUSE THE
REGULATED FAR LESS RIGOROUSLY
THAN OTHER HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS THE TIMES FOUND WE'VE
GOT MOLD ISSUE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE YOUR FIRST
END OF LIFE FRAUD IN YOUR FORTY
NINTH IN MEDICAL SPENDING ON.
THE LOW INCOME LATINO
POPULATION WHO IS A. THIRD OF
THE CARE IN YOUR- PEOPLE IN
YOUR QUE. THAT IS WHY DO I
COULDN'T THE FOR OF THIS BIG.
THAT'S NICE FOR ALL PEOPLE AND
ALL THE DOCTORS WHO CALLED IN
GREAT FOR YOU TO HAVE HEALTH
CARE. MEDINA OUR FAMILIES DO
NOT HAVE HEALTH CARE. FORTY
NINE IS NOT OKAY LOW
REIMBURSEMENT RATES AND OUR
COUNTY SANTA CLARA COUNTY WE
HAD TO FIGHT TO KEEP OUR
HOSPITALS SOME OF THE DISTRICTS
IN THE STATE DON'T HAVE
HOSPITALS. SO WE CAN'T GET
ACCESS WERE DENIED ACCESS AND
YEAH WE'VE BEEN OUT SORRY THAT
WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE A SLEW OF
THE LATINO COSBY'S NATIONAL
RESOLUTIONS. GOING INTO A
BECAUSE WE'RE FIGHTING FOR
VACCINES IN CITIZENSHIP AND
WORKING THREE JOBS. BUT THESE
NATIONAL RESOLUTIONS REPRESENT
A COUNCIL WHO WENT TO A
DISTRICT WHO WENT TO A STATE
CONVENTION WHO HAD TO GO TO A
STATE RESOLUTIONS COMMITTEE GO
TO THE STATE ASSEMBLY FOR. AND
HAVEN'T DEBATED ON THE SEASON
BEFORE THEY GO TO THE NATIONAL
CANCER. AND THEN HAVE THEM GO
TO RESOLUTIONS COMMITTEE AND
THEN HAVE THIS NATIONAL
ASSEMBLY. THAT'S THREE TIMES IN
TWO DECADES THAT WE HAVE OPPOSE
ASSISTED SUICIDE. THIS IS NOT
THE TIME FOR SENSE THAT TO BE
TAKEN AWAY. YOU ARE TARGETING.
USING THE LOTUS WHAT BATH AND
MY FATHER WAS A CO FOUNDER AND
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF HER
FOUNDATION HE WAS THE U. F. W.
AND IF YOU WEAR THAT MASK. SHE
BETTER LIVE BY THAT MASK.
BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT. THE
FOUNDATIONAL RIGHT TO CARE. AND
THIS IS AN OBSTRUCTION TO CARE
AND IT'S AN INJUSTICE IT'S-
CONSCIONABLE. THIS IS WHAT
YOU'RE ANY TO THE LATINO
POPULATION. TARGETING THEM.
COMPASSION TO WEBSITE BY LEGAL
NOTCHED TWENTY NINETEEN. SAYS
IS THERE ANY. ANY THOUGHTS ON
HOW CAN BETTER IN THOSE UNDER
POPULATIONS MAYBE NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING POPULATIONS. SO CALLED
HEARING THAT'S GOING INTO THE
DATA THE COMING AFTER LATINOS I
SAID THE VERY FIRST HEARING IN
THE SENATE STOP TRYING TO KILL
LATINOS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THIS
NATION IT'S UNACCEPTABLE. THANK
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE WILL NOW
MOVE TO OTHERS WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OR INDICATE
OPPOSITION SB THREE EIGHTY
ANYONE ELSE HERE. HEARING ROOM.
OPERATOR SOME THERE'S A MIKE
OPEN FOR SOMEONE COULD YOU
ADDRESS THAT PLEASE. SO HERE
THEY WILL TAKE NAME AND
AFFILIATION AND YOUR STANCE ON
THE BILL WE WILL NOT TAKE ANY
FURTHER TESTIMONY THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M KATHLEEN
DOMINGO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE AND I'M HERE TODAY
IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE EIGHTY. THANK YOU. HAVE A
SAFE AND ON THIS FLOOR IS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
RIGHT SEE NONE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
THOSE WHO'D LIKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE EIGHTY
AGAIN WE'RE TAKING NAME
AFFILIATION AND OPPOSITION. DO
YOU IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION-
SB THREE EIGHTY MY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AGAIN THAT'S ONE
AND THEN ZERO FOR S. B. THREE
EIGHTY UP. OPPOSITION. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS
IS MERI LEE SCHNEIDER WITH
RIGHT TO LIFE OF KERN COUNTY IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BOB NAYLOR FOR FUEL SAID IN
COMPANY- BROTHER OF THE SISTER
WHO QUALIFIED FOR THE END OF
LIFE OPTION BUT DID NOT
EXERCISE IT- OPPOSE THIS BILL
BECAUSE FORTY EIGHT HOURS IS
TOO SHORT. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF ONE FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF ONE EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
SUSAN ON ALL I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF OUTREACH AND ENGAGEMENT FOR
THE RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE
SB. THREE EIGHT ZERO. THANK YOU
NEXT ABOUT THE LINE OF ONE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS GLORIA DURAN AND I'M
AN INTERN WITH THE RIGHT TO
LIFE LEAD OR SOMETHING
CALIFORNIA AND WE OPPOSE SB.
THREE EIGHTY. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE NINETY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ANY
HARRINGTON FROM CANADA COUNTY I
SUPPORT LIFE AND OPPOSE SB
THREE EIGHTY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO IN THE LINE OF
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR TEN MEMBERS
THOMAS GARDNER WITH THE GLOBAL
GROUP ON BEHALF OF OUR CLIENT
THE CHURCH OF JESUS CHRIST OF
LATTER DAY SAINTS IN OPPOSITION
OF THE WAR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT TO GO TO A LINE OF TWO OH
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS
IS GREG BURCH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB. THREE
THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE OF ONE
FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS TONY WERE ABOLISHED
WITH CAPITOL RESOURCE INSTITUTE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB THREE.
THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF
ONE SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
AGAIN YES THANK THANK YOU I
MARILYN GOLDEN SENIOR POLICY
ANALYST WITH THE DISABILITY
RIGHTS EDUCATION AND DEFENSE
FUND FOR CALLING IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE EIGHTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF ONE SEVENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH MAYBE
CHECK SAN LUIS OBISPO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE LOOSENING THE
SAFEGUARDS AT THIS BILL DURING
THE CALL THAT NINETEEN WITNESS
DIRECTLY THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE OF ONE SIXTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CONDRON
REYNOLDS IN WITH THE NONPROFIT
DISABILITY RIGHTS LAW FIRM OF
WASHINGTON CIVIL AND DISABILITY
ADVOCATE. AS AN ATTORNEY AND
SOMEONE OF MUSCULAR DYSTROPHY
AND OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU AND ACCESSIBLE TO A LOT OF
ONE NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
NICOLE HAYES WITH THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF MEDICAL ETHICS AND
WE ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY. THANK
YOU AN ACTUAL GO TO LINE OF
WHAT ONE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THIS IS PETER KAISER'S
BELIEVE IN SANCTITY OF LIFE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THREE EIGHTY
AND WITH THE SHORTER FORTY
EIGHT HOURS SOME PEOPLE MAY
CHANGE THEIR MIND THANK YOUNG
WILL BE TOO LATE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU FOR YOU THE MAY
CLOSE THE LINES WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. RIGHT
HIS ADDRESS. I DO WANT TO BEGIN
BY THANKING THE SENATOR GREAT
RESPECT FOR SUCH A EGGMAN THE
WORK THAT SHE DOES IN THIS AS
AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER NOW AS A
SENATOR. I HAVE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SENATORS
WORLD WAS WITH US WITH THOSE
WHO SUPPORT AND THOSE WHO
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THERE ARE.
SOME THERE IS SOME DATA THAT
HAS BEEN COLLECTED SO FAR FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STATE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. IT SHOWS THAT
OVER 65% OF THOSE WHO'VE.
ACTUALLY CONDUCTED GESTEDE- THE
MEDICATION AND- THE. 1810065%
ARE OVER THE AGE OF SEVENTY. IT
IS ABOUT EQUAL BETWEEN MEN AND
WOMEN. 75% HAVE SOME COLLEGE.
OR UP TO A DOCTORATE DEGREE.
88% OF THOSE WHO HAVE INGESTED
THE MEDICATION OUR FLIGHT. I DO
APPRECIATE MOST ESPECIALLY THE
COMMENTS OF THE TESTIMONY FROM
DR CATHERINE REGARDING HER
HUSBAND. THOSE ARE VERY REAL
CASES. I KNOW THAT IN THE FIVE
YEARS SINCE THIS WAS
IMPLEMENTED TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED HAVE ASKED FOR THE
PRESCRIPTION EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
HAVE ACTUALLY INGESTED IT. THE
TESTIMONY GIVEN TODAY ALSO IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. ON A
PERSONAL NOTE TO MAKE SURE THIS
WITH THE SENATOR MY FATHER WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH TERMINAL CANCER
WAS GIVEN SIX TO LIVE. THE SIX
WEEKS WERE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
TO THE FAMILY I RECOGNIZE THAT
NOT EVERYBODY FEELS THE SAME
WAY AND SOME MAY WANT TO MAKE
THE DECISION NOT TO HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THAT. THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT I HOPE WILL BE ADDRESSED
THERE'S NO REASON FOR ANYONE TO
HAVE PHYSICAL PAIN. DURING
THEIR END OF LIFE PERIOD. THERE
WAS ANECDOTAL TESTIMONY. AND I
STAY ON A TOTAL BECAUSE THERE
IS NOTHING IN THE DATA THAT IS
COLLECTED AT THAT WOULD TELL
US. THAT FROM THE TIME THAT
SOMEBODY FIRST REQUESTED. THE
TO BE CONSIDERED FOR THIS TO
THE TIME THREE DECISIONS IS
MADE THAT THEY HAVE PASSED AWAY
WE DON'T HAVE THERE'S NO DATA
THAT HAS BEEN COLLECTED
REGARDING THAT. MY GREATEST
CONCERN WITH THE BILL. THREE
THINGS. REDUCING THE TIME
PERIOD TO MAKE THIS DECISION
FROM TWO WEEKS DOWN TO TWO DAYS.
REMOVING THE SUNSET ALL
TOGETHER AND I RECOGNIZE THAT-
YOUR YOUR TIME. HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE IS LIMITED BUT
THERE ARE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
SUPPORTED THIS THAT I THINK.
HAVING THE SUNSET EXTENDED I
THINK WOULD PROVIDE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING THIS UP
AGAIN. THE OTHER IS THE REMOVAL
OF THE REQUIREMENT FOR MENTAL
EVALUATION OR PSYCH PSYCHIATRIC
PSYCHOLOGICAL EVALUATION. TODAY
HAPPENS TO BE MY FATHER'S
BIRTHDAY. THAT WE CELEBRATE IN
A DIFFERENT WAY. BUT I THINK
THE. THE SAFEGUARDS PROVIDED IN
YOUR INITIAL BILL. AB X. TO
FIFTEEN I THINK PROVIDE US
ENOUGH OF AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THOSE WHO WANT TO AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF. OF THIS OPTION.
TO BE ABLE TO DO IT AND IN FACT
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE HAVE
DONE IT. IN THE FIVE YEARS
SINCE THIS WAS FIRST PASSED. I
DO WANT TO SEE MORE INFORMATION
I DO WANT TO DATE THE
SPECIFICALLY FROM THE TIME IT
IS FIRST REQUESTED TO THE TIME
IT THIS THIS LEAD TIME THAT HAS
BEEN TESTIFIED TO. I'D LIKE TO
KNOW MORE ABOUT THAT. FOUR I
COMPLETELY VOTE TO DO AWAY WITH
THE SUNSET. AND IT IS FOR THOSE
REASONS THAT TODAY RIGHT. WILL
BE WILL BE LAYING OFF ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU THIS GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU- AGAIN EIGHT EIGHT
ECHO- MY COLLEAGUES. DISCUSSION
ABOUT HOW MUCH WE RESPECT YOU
KNOW AND I THINK THAT THAT'S
CLEAR BUT I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO SAY AND I KNOW
THAT WE'VE HAD SO MANY
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS-
PROBABLY COULD CHARGE ME FOR
THERAPY AFTER THE MANY YEARS
WE'VE DISCUSSES. LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE- I WATCHED MY MOM
DIED OF CANCER AND- IN FIVE
DAYS IT WOULD HAVE BEEN HER.
SEVENTY SEVENTH BIRTHDAY- IT
WAS QUITE AWHILE AGO SHE SHE
PASSED AWAY AND I ALSO HAVE
SUCH DEEP EMPATHY- FOR THE
COLORS WHO TALKED ABOUT THE
PAIN AND WITNESSING LOVED ONES
AND WHAT THEY GO THROUGH ON AND
I DO BELIEVE WE HAVE TO DO A
BETTER JOB OF- HELPING PEOPLE.
BELIEVE EIGHT THEIR PAIN. I
DIDN'T VOTE FOR THE INITIAL
BILL AND WHEN THIS- CAME ABOUT.
A- I. THOUGHT I HAVE TO BE
HONEST AND TAKE A SECOND LOOK
AT THIS. BUT I AM ALSO
CONCERNED THAT WE'RE CHANGING
THE WAIT PERIOD AND GETTING RID
OF THE SUNSET- I THINK THOSE
TWO THINGS TOGETHER DON'T MAKE
A LOT OF SENSE TO ME- I HAVE
SOME ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AS
OPPOSED TO DEAL AND- PEOPLE
WHO- WHAT WE DON'T KNOW IT DID
THEY DIE- AND NOT TAKE THE
MEDICATION OR- ARE THEY STILL
LIVE- I REALLY WOULD LIKE TO
SEE MORE INFORMATION. ABOUT
PEOPLE'S LIFE EXPENSE
EXPECTANCY IN WHAT THEY'RE TOLD
AND HOW LONG THEY LIVE I HAVE A
BEEN VERY OPEN SHE'S BEEN OPEN
SIGN I WILL SAVE A DISTRICT
DIRECTOR WHO IS BATTLING NOW
STAGE FOR LUNG CANCER THAT HAS
SPREAD TO HER BRAIN AND BONES
AND- YOU KNOW WE JUST PASSED
THE TWO YEAR ANNIVERSARY AND
SHE WAS. SHE WERE QUALIFIED
FOR- THIS DRUG WHEN SHE WAS
INITIALLY- DIAGNOSED SO. I ALSO
HAVE CONCERNS AND WILL CONTINUE
HAVE CONCERNS- FOR INDIVIDUALS.
ALTHOUGH IT HASN'T REACHED THE
UNDERSERVED YET WHO MAY SEE
THIS IS NOT A CHOICE BECAUSE WE
DON'T. PROVIDE ADEQUATE HEALTH
CARE FREE HEALTH CARE AND-
THERE IS A VERY REAL
POSSIBILITY AS THIS EXPANDS
WITH US. KATHLEEN THE VERY-
WHAT I FIND IMPORTANT ASPECT OF
SINGLE PAYER UNIVERSAL HEALTH
CARE FOR PEOPLE TO BE GIVEN A
FALSE CHOICE. A CHOICE OF
BURNING THEIR FAMILY WITH WITH
MEDICAL BILLS- EXTENSIVE
MEDICAL BILLS OR OF CUTTING
SHORT THEIR LAST DAYS WITH
THEIR FAMILY AND I WORRY ABOUT
THAT- BECAUSE WE'VE ALL SEEN
PEOPLE MAKE DECISIONS THAT. ARE
RATIONAL DECISIONS EVEN IF YOU
WILL FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND I
THINK IT UNTIL WE CAN GET TO A
POINT WHERE INDIVIDUALS TRULY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAKE A
DECISION. NOT BASED ON- A
FAULTY MEDICAL SYSTEM THAT
WOULD THAT WOULD CURRENTLY
HAVE- THAT I CANNOT SUPPORT
THIS BILL BUT I DO WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR. I KNOW THIS ALL
SOUNDS STRANGE BUT CONTINUING
TO CHALLENGE ME- I THINK AT.
WHAT YOU'RE DOING. YOU BELIEVE
IS RIGHT I JUST WISH WE HAD
MORE INFORMATION AND THAT WE
WEREN'T DOING BOTH THE SUNSET-
ELIMINATION AND A CHANGE IN THE
POLICY AT THE SAME TIME- BUT I
CAN'T SUPPORT IT TODAY. THANK
YOU. BUT THE QUESTIONS ARE
COMMON. RIGHT SENATOR I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR DEDICATION
TO THE ISSUE AND I KNOW IT WAS
ON HOW TO WORK A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO TO GET THE ORIGINAL
BILL PASSED AND IT IS HARD.
THIS IS ABOUT HUMAN DIGNITY.
AND THAT'S WHY IT IS SO
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE RE
VISITING US AT THIS POINT. AND
CASE IN POINT. WILL FORCE AND
MANY OTHERS WE KNEW GOING IN
THAT MANY WOULD. CONTEMPLATE
THE OPTION BUT NOT TAKE THE
OPTION AND THAT'S WITH THE
DIGNITY COMES IN IS WHEN
SOMEONE WHO IS GOING THROUGH
THE PROCESS OF DYING. AND CAN
DO SOMETHING TO TAKE CONTROL
THEMSELVES AND WHETHER NOT THE
EXERCISE THAT CONTROL JUST
HAVING THAT OPTION IS FOR THE
DIGNITY COMES IN BECAUSE
THERE'S SO MANY OTHER FACTORS
THAT ARE AT PLAY WHEN SOMEONE
IS GOING THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
DYING THIS IS JUST THAT.
MODICUM OF CONTROL FOR THAT
INDIVIDUAL AND THAT'S WHY. IS A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I THINK
THIS ALSO IS A VERY IMPORTANT
ILL. FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS WE HAVE LEARNED
OVER FIVE YEARS. THAT A LOT OF
THE FEARS THAT LED TO THE
COMPROMISES THAT YOU TOOK. I
HAVE NOT REALLY BEEN REALIZED
EITHER A LOT OF OTHER THINGS
GOING ON AND WORRIES ABOUT THE
MEDICAL DELIVERY SYSTEM. THAT
IS ON ALL OF US TO CONTINUE TO
MANAGE AND ENSURE THAT WE HAVE.
APPROPRIATE ARTICLE ACCESS FOR
EVERYONE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS IS A VERY SMALL
SUBSET. AND THIS IS A REALLY
BILL ABOUT DIGNITY SO IT IT IS.
PAST TIME WE LOOKED AT THIS AND
WE START TO RELAX NOT SOME OF
THE REAL. PROTECTIONS THAT
YOU'VE GOT IN HERE AND I KNOW
YOU'RE NOT TOUCHING THOSE BUT I
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE TO TAKE
THE SUNSE OFF. THE WAITING
PERIOD. WE CAN HEAR FROM THE
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS WHO HAVE
BEEN ACTIVELY ENGAGE WITH
INDIVIDUALS WANTING TO TAKE
THIS OPTION. THAT THEY FEEL
THAT IS AN IMPORTANT STEP.
AGAIN FOR THE EXISTING DIGNITY
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS SO I.
RESTATE THE YOU BROUGHT THIS
FORWARD AND- THAT- ALSO HOPING
WE WILL MOVE THIS OUT OF OUR
COMMITTEE TODAY SO. WITH THAT
SENATOR MAKE CLUBS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I WANT I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR YOUR-
YOUR COMMENTS AND THE TIME I
KNOW YOU TOOK WITH THIS AND I
KNOW EVERY TIME I BRING
SOMETHING LIKE THIS UP. IT
BRINGS BACK YOUR MOTHER AND IT
BRINGS BACK YOUR FATHER I KNOW
THAT RIGHT THAT THAT IS A PART
OF LIFE RIGHT THAT WE ALL GO
THROUGH AND EVERY TIME THAT WE
LOSE SOMEBODY WE LOVE SO
DEARLY. WE EXPERIENCED
EVERYBODY'S DEATH ALL OVER
AGAIN AND SO- AND WE AS HUMANS
ARE ARE DEATH DEFYING CREATURES
RIGHT WE FORM WHERE THERE'S NO
WATER WE CAN BUILD BRIDGES A I
MEAN WE DO THINGS THAT PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW JUST BECAUSE WE THINK
WE'RE GONNA LIVE FOREVER. BUT
THE TRUTH IS WE'RE NOT WE ARE
ALL GOING TO DIE AND SOME
PEOPLE WANT THE OPTION OF
MAINTAINING THEIR DEATHS LIKE
THEY'VE MAINTAINED THEIR LIFE-
I'LL SHARE WITH YOU EITHER HAVE
A VERY CLOSE FRIEND THAT IS A
PART OF MY FAMILY WERE IN OUR
ARTICLE COVERED BUBBLE TOGETHER
AGAIN HE MENACE- HELLO LATINO.
CATHOLIC AT AND HE WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH COLON CANCER
TWENTY THIRTEEN HOUSING ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE I WE NURSED HIM
THROUGH THAT ARE VERY CLOSE TO
ALL UP IN THE GABER HOOD THERE
IN VICTORY PARK NEIGHBORHOOD-
AND HE MADE IT- HE HE NOW HAS
STAGE FOUR LUNG CANCER AND HE'S
HAD THAT NOW FOR FOUR YEARS-
AND HE HAS A VERY. FLAMBOYANT
BEAUTIFUL MAN- DIAMOND DAN AND
HE CURRENTLY HAS BLISTERS ALL
OVER HIS HEAD AND HIS FACE. IN
HIS CHEST- INTO IS NOT AS
PRETTY BUT HE WEARS FANCY
CLASSES AND HATS TO BE ABLE TO
STILL BE AS PRETTY AS HE LIKE
TO BE. AND WE TAKE HIM TO CHEMO
EVERY SINGLE WEEK AND WE
NURSING AFTER THAT AND HAVE
DONE THAT FOR FOUR YEARS. AND
WILL CONTINUE TO. YOU CAN. OVER
TO MY HOUSE. AND I NOTICED TALK
ABOUT THIS THIS WEEK. HE'S A
GIRL. THE DOCTOR SAID. NO
MARKING AND I SAID WHAT WHAT'S
NEXT DOCTOR AND HE SAID THERE'S
NOTHING LEFT. AND YOU SAID IT
IT TOOK ME FROM AND I SAID IT
HAS TO BE SO THEY'RE GONNA TRY
EXPERIMENTAL THINGS AND HE'S
GOING TO HE'S GOING TO DO IT.
BECAUSE HE HAS SUCH A WILL TO
LIVE BECAUSE HE GETS TO GO DOWN
TO PUERTO VALLARTA. TWO TIMES A
YEAR AND WE ALL HELP SO HE CAN
DO THAT BECAUSE HE DID NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE WE'VE GOT
A MEMETIC CAL ALL THOSE THINGS
NOW WE TOOK CARE OF. AND I KNOW
WHAT THE AND I DON'T KNOW FOR
SURE. BUT I THINK HE'S GOING TO
USE THIS. AND THERE IS NO WAY
THAT MAN HAS NOT FOUGHT. WAY
HARDER THAN I KNOW ANYBODY
WOULD FIGHT TO LIVE BECAUSE HE
FEELS SO FABULOUS. THE POINT IS
NOT GONNA BE ABLE LIVE FOR EVER
AND HE WANTS TO HAVE SOME SAY
OVER THE LAST COUPLE THINGS HE
HASN'T GIVEN AWAY ALL HIS CHINA
I THINK I'M GETTING HIS BIG
FANCY LIQUOR CABINET. I'M NOT
SURE. HOWEVER I KNOW THIS
BRINGS DIGNITY AND PEACE TO
PEOPLE. I KNOW THAT AT THE END
OF SOME PEOPLE'S LIVES DATE AND
TIME WE TALKED ABOUT IT'S NOT
LATINOS WHO USES IT IS NOT A
LOT OF CATHOLICS WHO USE IT.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT A LARGE
PERCENT OF CATHOLICS SUPPORT
THIS AND A LARGE NUMBER OF
LATINO SUPPORT THIS- BUT PEOPLE
WHO ARE WHITE WHO HAVE COLLEGE
EDUCATION AND SOME MONEY HAVE
HAD AGENCY THROUGHOUT THEIR
LIFE THEY'VE HD AGENCY TO BE
ABLE O SEE WHAT THEY WANT WHAT
THEYDON'T WANT AND TO LIVE
THEIR LIFE IN A DIGNIFIED
MANNER THEY WANT. THOSE OF US
OF COLOR THOSE OF US ARE
DIFFERENT SO SHOULD I HAVE NOT
HAD THAT AGENCY THROUGHOUT OUR
LIVES AND SOMETIMES DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT OTHER PEOPLE
WANT TO BE ABLE. TO SAY WHEN
THE END IS HERE. THIS BILL IS
NOT REQUIRED FOR ANYBODY IT IS
AN OPTION. IT IS AN OPTION THAT
SOME PEOPLE LIKE TO UTILIZE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUT WE ARE NOT
TAKING OUT THE MENTAL
EVALUATION THAT IS STILL IN
THERE. IT WAS ALWAYS IF IT THE
VISIT ONE OF THE PHYSICIANS
THOUGHT YOU NEEDED IT. YOU
WOULD BE REFERRED THAT IS NOT
BEING REMOVED THAT IS THAT IS
STILL THERE- IT IS INTERESTING
THAT WE DON'T. YOU KNOW I'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SAY EXACTLY.
HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE DIED
WITHIN THAT FIFTEEN DAY WAITING
PERIOD. BUT WE DON'T BECAUSE WE
ALSO KNOW THAT WHAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO GET THE MEDICATION.
DON'T EVEN USE IT IT'S JUST
KNOWING THAT IT IS THERE THAT
IF IT GOT TOO BAD. THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE A DIFFERENT OPTION.
THAT BRINGS PEOPLE PEACE. AND
AT THE END OF PEOPLE'S LIFE.
DON'T WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THEM A LITTLE PIECE
THAT WE WANT TO GIVE A LET PUT
OUR FEARS ASIDE. AND LET PEOPLE
MAKE THE ONUS THEIR OWN
DECISIONS IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THEIR PHYSICIANS. ABOUT THEIR
VERY LAST MINUTES ON THIS WORLD.
I THINK WE DO. I THINK THERE'S
ENOUGH SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE I
THINK SOME OF THE SAFEGUARDS TO
BECOME BARRIERS. AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR I AM LOOKING
FOR A MOTION. THANK YOU THEN I
WILL SECOND THAT. WE DO HAVE A
MOTION TO SECOND THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE. STONE AYE
STONE AYE GALLAGHER. CHAU CHIU
DAVIES GONZALEZ. HOLDEN
GOLDENEYE KALRA KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN REYES. SO THE BILL
NEEDS FOR MORE VOTES WE DON'T
HAVE EVERYONE HERE SPOKE WITH
BILL ON CALL AND ASK FOR
RECONSIDERATION OF ITEM ABOUT.
OKAY THEN ITEM NUMBER TEN S. B.
SENATOR YOU HAVE ONE MORE BEST.
I'M HELLO OKAY SO THIS ONE
MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT EASIER
FOR PEOPLE FILE. OKAY THIS IS
AB FIVE OH SEVEN WHICH I WENT
UP WAY TOO LONG AS BEFORE-
SEVEN A RANDOM NUMBER TEN YEAH
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THIS SIMPLY SAYS AGAIN WORKING
ON A LAW THAT I WORKED ON
BEFORE LAURA'S LAW CURRENTLY
RIGHT NOW ASSISTED OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT. ARE YOU HAVE TO BE
SUBSTANTIALLY DETERIORATING TO
BE ABLE TO BE ADMITTED IF
PEOPLE ARE COMING OUT OF A
HIGHER LEVEL OF CARE INPATIENT
THERE HOPEFULLY ARE NOT
SUBSTANTIALLY DETERIORATING AND
THEN WOULDN'T BE AVAILABLE-
MEET THE CRITERIA FOR ASSISTED
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT THIS JUST
SIMPLY SAYS IF SOMEBODY'S
COMING OUT OF. AN INPATIENT
FACILITY AT A CONSORTIUM THAT
THEY THEN WOULD BE CALL IF THEY
MEET ALL THE OTHER CRITERIA
THAT GOES ALONG WITH-
OUTPATIENT ASSISTED OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT- AND ALSO- THAT SOME
OF THIS CAN BE DONE REMOTELY AS
NEEDS TO BE DONE THESE DAYS-
AND ALSO. THAT- THE- THAT. THE
OFFICER ALSO ENOUGH.
CONVERSATION ABOUT MEDICATION.
JUST THAT'S DOCUMENTED AND THAT
WE START THAT PROCESS. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND WITH ME TODAY I HAVE-
RANDALL HAGAR. IN A SECOND
WITNESS. THANK YOU I HAVE
LISTED TWO WITNESSES RANDALL
HAGAR AND CAROL STANCHFIELD
BOTH WITH US ON THE TELEPHONE
RANDALL HAGAR ARE YOU WITH US.
I AM VERY PLEASED. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I AM
RANDALL HAGER I REPRESENT THE-
THIRTEEN HUNDRED PLUS MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE- WHO
PRACTICE IN ALL PRACTICE
SETTINGS- IN PARTICULARLY THE
PUBLIC SETTINGS WHITE SINCE
FREE LIKE NEEDED TO PLAY
OUTSIDE THE CHANGES THAT ARE
CONTEMPLATED HERE I ALSO HELPED
DRAFT THE ORIGINAL LAW YEAH- WE
ALWAYS THOUGHT. THAT LAURA'S
LOT WORSE IS THAT PATIENT
TREATMENT- IF YOU WANT TO BE A
LOT MORE CLINICAL IS SOMETHING
THAT COULD BE USED AS A STEP
DOWN- DEVICE- FOR PEOPLE-
ENTERING THE COMMUNITY BUT
BECAUSE OF A DEMONSTRATED
HISTORY- DETERIORATION ONCE
THEY HAD DONE THAT LEFT AN
INSTITUTION AND DONE THAT. WELL
WERE YOU KNOW PRETTY
PREDICTABLY GONNA COME BACK
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ARRESTED
MAYBE THEY MAY MAY GO TO THE
HOSPITAL- THEY ACTUALLY MAKE
COMMIT ACTS OF VIOLENCE WILL
BECOME ALMOST A LOT ABOUT VERY.
IMPORTANT OUTCOMES THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO- DEAL WITH HERE AND I
THINK THIS THIS- PROGRAM AS IT
IS NOW THERE'S A REALLY GOOD
JOB BUT AS THE LPS REPORT- DOES
INDICATE THAT AUDITOR DECLINED-
DISCRETE POPULATIONS. THAT
COULD BE SERVED BY A ON P. BUT
WERE NOT BEING ABLE TO ACCESS
IT BECAUSE OF THE- PARTICULAR
CRITERIA THAT SENATOR EIGHT
WHEN JUST REFERRED TO AND SO
AGAIN YOU KNOW I THINK THIS IS
AN EARLY INTERVENTION AND
PREVENTION TOOL- THAT CAN BE
VERY USEFUL TO LET NEW NEW
POPULATIONS PARTICULARLY THOSE
WHO'VE BEEN CONCERNED. AND
MIGHT NEED SOME HELP IN THE
COMMUNITY- SO THAT THAT. THEY
DON'T RETURN TO CONSERVATORSHIP.
IT IS A EARLY INTERVENTION AND
PREVENTION TOOL IN THAT
RESPECT- IT IS EVIDENCE BASED-
WE PROVIDE THE MENU CHANGES
THAT I BELIEVE RESPOND TO THE
THIS MOMENT IN TIME. TO HELP
EVEN MORE PEOPLE- AND WE
COMMEND. IT TO YOUR APPROVAL.
THANK YOU. AND THEN WE HAVE
STANFIELD. I DO NOT SHARE HER I
DO NOT SHOW HER CONNECTED AT
THIS TIME OKAY SO WE WILL THN
MOVE ON TO OTHERS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB
FIVE OH SEVEN IS THERE ANYONE.
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
SEEING THAT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING NONE
RIGHT OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN
THE LINES FOR THOSE WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE
OH SEVEN AGAIN WE'RE TAKING
NAME AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT NO
FURTHER TESTIMONY. THANK YOU IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
OH SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOUR SUPPORT OF SB.
FIVE OH SEVEN. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE AT NUMBER TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED SKEWS ME TWO HUNDRED
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU. A
GOOD MORNING SHARON MEMBERS
COLLINS WORSE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF BUT TO
TWENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING HERE TO MEMBERS
CHRISTOLOGY .COM WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO
LINE OF ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOU HAVE A PHONE.
LINE ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YEAH I WAS ON MUTE. RIGHT
THEN WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES CHAIRED RIGHTLY ON BEHALF
OF THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL WE ARE
THE COURT WE ARE SPEAKING IN A
SMALL CLARIFIED AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT YOU QUEUE AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WE WILL
MOVE TO OPPOSITION I DO NOT
HAVE ANY WITNESSES LISTED IN
OPPOSITION SO IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE OH SEVEN.
C. TWENTY SITE. ALL RIGHT SEE
NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OF THE
LIGHTS FOR THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE OPPOSITION SB FIVE
OH SEVEN. IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE OH SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
AND THEN THEY'RE OFF IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE OH SEVEN.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF- ONE
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE UP OF A. TWO THIRTEEN. TWO
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHAD BELL THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION SOCIAL
REHABILITATION AGENCY- IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME RIGHT THANK YOU
OPERATOR YOU MAY CLOSE THE
LINES AND I'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR A QUESTIONS
COMMENTS THIS GALLAGHER.
SENATORS APPRECIATE YOUR
CONTINUED WORK ON THIS ISSUE
AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT I THINK
WE MAKE THESE VERY REASONABLE
REFORMS- AND- AT THE OPPORTUNE
TIME WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR WILL BE SUPPORTING.
TODAY THANK YOU. FOR THE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR- C. NOT
SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE STRICTLY
ABOUT THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THAT MOTION
IS TO PASS CALDERON PLEASE.
STONE AYE STONE AYE GALLAGHER-
GALLAGHER I'D SHOW. CHIU DAVIES
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HOLDEN HI
HOLDEN HI KALRA KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN REYES HI RES I. I
THINK WE NEED ONE MORE. SO
WE'LL PUT THE BILL ON CALL AS
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. RIGHT
SENATOR DATO. SIX IS THE ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB. SEVEN OH THREE.
SECOND THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO SUBCOMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED IN THIS
BILLS ANALYSIS. SB SEVEN ZERO
TWO THREE THE POULTRY AND
LIVESTOCK LIKE LAB SAFETY ACT
ENSURES THAT ALL CALIFORNIA
LABORATORIES PERFORMING TEST
FOR SPECIFIED REGULATORY
DISEASES OR CONDITIONS IN
ANIMALS AND THEIR PRODUCTS ARE
MEETING STANDARDS SET BY THE
STATE DEPARTMENT'S OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE. CALIFORNIA'S
REBELS POULTRY AND LIVESTOCK
PRODUCT INDUSTRY GENERATES
EIGHT POINT THREE. FIVE BILLION
IN ANNUAL INCOME AND PLEASE ONE
MILLION PEOPLE. THE OUTBREAK OF
A FOREIGN ANIMAL DISEASE IN OUR
STATE COULD TRIGGER COSTLY
RECALLS IN DANGER CONSUMER
HEALTH AND ARE IN THE FOOD
SUPPLY CHAIN WORLDWIDE.
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO EXISTING
STATE LAW THAT AUTHORIZES CDFA
OVERSIGHT AND CERTIFICATION OF
LABORATORIES ANALYZING
CALIFORNIA POULTRY AND
LIVESTOCK SAMPLES. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF DETECTING CONDITIONS
THAT WOULD TRIGGER A STATE
RESPONSE. FURTHER THERE IS NO.
REQUIREMENT THAT SUCH LAPTOP
HERE TO REGULATIONS PRESENT AN
EXISTING STATE RUN
LABORATORIES. WITH THE SAME
OBJECTIVE. SB SEVEN ZERO THREE
ADDRESSES THE SHORTCOMINGS OF
EXISTING LAW BY GRANTING CDFA
THE AUTHORITY TO ADOPT TO
ENFORCE STANDARDS TO REGULATE
THE OPERATION OF AND VERIFY THE
RESULTS. COMING FROM LAB TESTS
POULTRY AND LIVESTOCK SAMPLES.
BEES FROM LAB SEEKING CDFA
CERTIFICATION WILL OFFSET THE
COST OF IMPLEMENTING THESE NEW
REGULATIONS TO POTENTIALLY SAVE
CALIFORNIA FROM FUTURE
FINANCIAL LOSS AS A RESULT OF
ANIMAL DISEASES. PREVIOUS
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL ENSURE
THAT LABS ALREADY APPROVED
CERTIFIED CREDIT BY THE STATE
OR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
PROVIDE THE TYPES OF SERVICES
AYE DISCREPANT AYE CAPTURED
WITHIN THE BILL'S. SCOPE SB
SEVEN ZERO THREE OF THE STREET
FORWARD MEASURE THE SIX CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA LABORATORIES.
TESTING POULTRY AND LIVESTOCK
FROM POINT DISEASES PROVIDE
EQUALLY RELIABLE RESULTS AND
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I
HAVE BILL MEADOWS WHO IS THE
PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
POULTRY. FEDERATION THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE BILL MODELS LISTED
THAT IS THE ONLY. WITNESS IN
SUPPORT WITH US ON THE
TELEPHONE BILL MATTERS ARE YOU
HERE. GOOD MORNING CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN. JUST GERMANS
DAHLE MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK THIS MORNING THANK YOU
SENATOR HER TITLE FOR THIS
LEGISLATION THE CALIFORNIA
POULTRY FEDERATION- I AM
PRESIDENT OF THE ASSOCIATION
FOR THE PAST THIRTY ONE YEARS.
AND WE APPLAUD AND SUPPORT YOUR
LEGISLATION SENATE BILL SEVEN
OH THREE IT PROVIDES THAT
LABORATORIES TO GAUGE IN
CERTAIN DIAGNOSTIC SERVICES
WILL BE HELD A HIGH QUALITY
CONTROL STANDARDS WHICH MEANS A
LOT FOR THE LIVESTOCK INDUSTRY
IN THE STATE. VETERANS AN
ANIMAL OWNERS IN ON ACCURATE
LABORATORY RESULTS TO MAKE
ANIMAL HEALTH DECISION. IT ALSO
WILL REDUCE REDUNDANCIES AND
COSTS FOR LABORATORY RETESTING
AND AUTHORIZED CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF NAGLA CULTURE TO
PROMULGATE READ REGULATIONS WE
APPROVE- OUR OFFICE IS OFF THE
HOME TO THE NATIONAL POULTRY
IMPROVEMENT PLAN THAT WE
CERTIFIED POULTRY IN A YOU CAN
BE SHIPPED ACROSS STATE LINES.
AND THROUGHOUT THE WORLD SAFELY.
AND WITHOUT. AND STRONG POULTRY
ROBERT ARE STINGY IN MAINE. A
HIGH. FOODS OF. WE IS SOMETHING
CAL. MAIN UPDATE FOLLOWED. WE
THANK YOU. LISTENING TO OUR-
PRESENTATION AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. HI
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR SB SEVEN OH THREE. C. NOT
ABOUT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO DECADE SUPPORT
FOR SB SEVEN OH THREE WILL TAKE
NAME AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN ALL THREE MY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
AND THEN ZERO IF YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN ALL. THREE
AND MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
MOVED OPPOSITION I DO NOT HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION LISTED. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN OF THREE.
SEE NOT. JUST MONEY SITE.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANY
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN OH
THREE. THANK YOU IF YOU'RE NOT
PHYSICIAN OF SB SEVEN ALL THREE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AGAIN THAT THE ONE THEN ZERO IN
OPPOSITION. OF SB SEVEN ALL
THREE. AND WE DO HAVE ONE IN Q.
TWO AND Q. ONE MOMENT WHERE WE
GIVEN THEIR LINE NUMBER. AGAIN
WE'RE ON OPPOSITION OF S. B.
SEVEN ZERO THREE. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO TO GET INTO
Q. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE UP.
TO SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS ON THE BALLOT-
ALMONT POLICE UP ALL THREE MADE
IT TWENTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK
OKAY AND AGAIN WE ARE ON S. B.
OLD THREE. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF THE. TWO THIRTY SIX.
LINE TWO THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO ONE TO THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU AND MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
OLD FOR THEIR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME I THINK YOU'RE
PRETTY BECAUSE THE LINES OF
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND ALREADY. SORRY BUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU THE
PROBLEM. RIGHT CENTER REMAIN
CLOSE. THANK YOU I RESPECT LAST
FOR NAVAL THANK YOU WE DO HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. STONE HI STONE HI
GALLAGHER AND GALLAGHER FIVE
CHANNELS QIU. DAVIES GONZALEZ
HOLDEN HOLDEN HI. KALRA KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN REYES REYES AYE
THINK THANK YOU NEEDS TO MORE
VOTES WERE PUT IN A CALL THANK
YOU. RIGHT SENATOR LEYVA THAT
TAKES US TO OUR ITEM NUMBER
FIVE SB SEVEN TWO SEVEN. ALL.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM HAPPY TO BE HERE
TO PRESENT SB SEVEN TWO SEVEN
WHICH AIMS TO PREVENT WAGE
THEFT WITHIN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY HERE IN CALIFORNIA I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT WE ARE
SEEKING TO GO AFTER THE BAD
ACTORS IN THE INDUSTRY AND TO
HELP THOSE THAT PLAY BY THE
RULES AND MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
WORKERS ARE PAID ON TIME. DUE
TO THE SKILLS REQUIRED IN THE
FAIR WAGES AND BENEFITS WORKERS
RECEIVE THE INDUSTRY PROVIDE A
PATHWAY TO THE MIDDLE CLASS FOR
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS WHO COULD
AFFORD TO PURCHASE THE HOMES
THAT THEY BUILT LIKE MANY OTHER
SECTORS CONSTRUCTION WAGES HAVE
GONE DOWN BUT WAIT STAFF IN
CASH PAYMENTS HAVE INCREASED
AND A KEY FACTOR FOR THIS IS A
LACK OF ENFORCEMENT OF BASIC
LABOR LAWS ON THE JOB SITE.
UNSCRUPULOUS CONTRACTORS THAT
DO NOT PLAY BY THE RULES HAVE
BEEN ILLEGAL AND UNFAIR
ADVANTAGE OVER ON ITS
CONTRACTORS AS A UNDERMINE
WAGES AND WORKING CONDITIONS
THROUGHOUT THE INDUSTRY BUT I
WILL SHARE TAT WELL SEVENTEEN
A ONE BY THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURMAN WHICH TOOK EFFECT IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN HAS BEEN
A DIFFERENCE IT HAS NOT DONE
ENOUGH SOME CONTRACTORS STILL
CONSIDER WAGE THEFT JUST THE
COST OF DOING BUSINESS HERE
WITH ME TODAY IS DANNY CURTAIN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE
OF CARPENTERS. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR I HAVE ONE WITNESS
LISTED DANIEL CURTAIN. GO AHEAD
PLEASE- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. LAST APRIL A
SUBCONTRACTOR WORKING ON A
HOMELESS HOUSING PROJECT WAS
CHARGED WITH FAILING TO PAY ITS
WORKERS NEARLY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS. THE DA'S OFFICE SAID
THEY COULD NOT IDENTIFY MANY OF
THE WORKERS ELIGIBLE FOR
COMPENSATION BECAUSE OF SCANT
PAYROLL RECORDS. SB SEVEN TWO
SEVEN IS NOT A WAGE BILL THE
ONLY WAGE LAW THAT APPLIES IS
THE MINIMUM WAGE IT IS A PLAY
BY THE RULES BILL. RIGHT NOW
THE RULE IS EVERY CONTRACTOR IS
REQUIRED BY LAW TO KEEP PAYROLL
RECORDS. ABOUT 20% OF OUR
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY DOES NOT
PLAY BY THE RULES AND THE STATE
LOSES ABOUT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR IN TAXES. THE
LIKELIHOOD OF A CONTRACTOR
FACING INSPECTIONS ABOUT ONCE
IN EVERY THREE HUNDRED YEARS.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER REPORTED A TWELVE
MILLION DOLLAR. WAGE THEFT CASE
THE LARGEST IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY. MORE THAN ONE THOUSAND
WORKERS WERE CHEATED OUT OF
ALMOST TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
WAGES. IT'S STILL IN LITIGATION
AND WILL BE FOR YEARS.
UNFORTUNATELY JUST 17% OF THE
WORKERS WHO NGUYEN RECEIVE EVEN
SOME OF THEIR PAY. IN 50% OF
CASES THE EMPLOYER SOLD
TRANSFERRED OR ABANDON THEIR
BUSINESS BEFORE THE JUDGMENT
WAS EVEN DELIVER. JOINT AND
SEVERAL LIABILITY WILL MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. WE'RE NOT IGNORING
OUR OPPONENTS CONCERNS WE'VE
TAKEN SERIOUS AMENDMENTS
REQUESTED BY CONTRACTORS THE
MOST IMPORTANT IS THE SAFE
HARBOR AMENDMENT. A DIRECT
CONTRACTOR CAN PROTECT
THEMSELVES FROM ADDED LIABILITY
BY ONE. PERIODICALLY MONITORING
LEGALLY REQUIRED SUBCONTRACTOR
PAYROLL RECORDS AND TO TAKING
DILIGENT ACTION INCLUDING
WITHHOLDING A SUBCONTRACTORS
PROGRESS PAYMENTS. THEY DON'T
HAVE TO MONITOR EVERY SUB FOR
EVEN ANY SUBS THEY SHOULD KNOW
THEIR SUBS THEY SHOULD KNOW
THEIR JOBS AND THEIR WORK FORCE
NEEDS THEY SHOULD HAVE
CONTRACTS WITH RESPONSIBLE
LICENSED SUBCONTRACTORS WHO
HAVE PAYROLL RECORDS. JUST
WEEKS AFTER THE ONE MILLION
DOLLAR CASE I MENTIONED WAS
ANNOUNCED MORE WAGE VIOLATIONS
WERE DISCOVERED THE WHOLE JOB
IS CURRENTLY UNDER
INVESTIGATION. IRONICALLY THE
JOB HAD BEEN THE SITE OF AN
EARLIER PRESS CONFERENCE BY KEY
OFFICIALS PRAISING THE HOMELESS
HOUSING PROJECT FOR THE SPEED
OF CONSTRUCTION. AND THE LOW
COST. LET'S MAKE SURE THE
WORKERSAND HONEST CONTRACTORS
DON'T GET LOST WHILE WE ATTEMPT
TO SOLVE THE HOUSING CRISIS
THIS IS A GOOD BILL IT'S NOT A
MIRACLE CURE BUT IT'S AN
IMPORTANT BILL. I WANT TO THANK
SENATE A LEYVA. AND HER STAFF
FOR THE HARD WORK ON THIS BILL
PLEASE VOTE YES. ON SB SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TWO SEVEN.
C. NONE OF THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
SITE. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
SUPPORT FOR SB. SEVEN TWO
SEVEN. GIVE YOUR SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN TWO SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS MAXIMUM
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEVADA CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MARIO SENATORS
WOULD NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WILL
RAISE THE PRESENTING THE
NORTHERN FORTY SIX COLONIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRED MEMBERS THIS IS
ED EVANS OF CARPENTERS LOCAL
TWO SEVENTEEN SAN MATTEO COUNTY
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT
WE WILL GO TO LINE OF FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS DAN MCCALLUM THAT
SENIOR FIELD REPRESENTATIVE FOR
CARPENTERS LOCAL SEVEN FIFTY
ONE AND THIRTY FIVE
REPRESENTING CARPENTER'S NAME
MAUREEN CINEMA NAPA LAKE
MENDOCINO DEL NORTON HUMBOLDT
COUNTY. AND CALLING HIM FOR
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NOT SO GO TO LINE OF
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING SURE MEMBERS
IS AN AUGIE BELCHER AND WITH
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CARPENTERS REGIONAL COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT TO SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO SEVEN
FIVE. NINE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MODERATOR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY COMMITTEE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALSO SUPPORT. THANK YOU I FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JOHN BILL
PERRY OAK REPRESENTING
INDUSTRIAL CARPENTERS LOCAL
TWENTY TO THIRTY SIX- WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT AS WELL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT TO SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING I'M AT ANATOL GABBER
LOOK ON BEHALF OF CARBON LOCAL
FORTY SIX REPRESENTING
SACRAMENTO CONNIE AND FOUR
THOUSAND MEMBERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU RANGERS
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CITY
BERNACCHI ABOUT THE NATIONAL
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE CONFERENCE THE
PLUMBING HEATING AND PIPING
INDUSTRY NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
ALLIED TRADE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GLASS MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION WALL AND CEILING
ALLIANCE AND WESTERN WALL
CEILING CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION- WHAT WE'RE LISTED
IN OPPOSITION IN THE ANALYSIS-
WE HAVE REMOVED OPPOSITION OR
NOW A NEUTRON THE BILL
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT. FOR
THE MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VICE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CLEARLY YES
WE CAN'T YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
DURING THIS MORNING THIS IS
GOING TO WIN YOUR FROM
CARPENTERS LOCAL SEVEN THIRTEEN
REPRESENTING ALAMEDA COUNTY
CALLING THEM IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB. SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU NINE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS HASN'T SHOWN HE
BARRED REPRESENTING CARPENTERS
LOCAL FIVE OH FIVE AND SIX OH
FIVE OF SANTA CRUZ AND MONTEREY
COUNTIES RESPECTIVELY AND OUR
MEMBERS ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF. SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE CALL AFTER. YES
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DAVID
KIRSCH- THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CARPENTERS CONTRACTORS
COOPERATION COMMITTEE LABOR
MANAGEMENT ORGANIZATION FOCUSED
ON CRACKING DOWN WAIT STAFF AND
CROWD WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL WE ARE ON THE
GROUND AND SEE FIRSTHAND
EVERYDAY WITH THE WORKPLACE
TAKING RETURNS THE MONEY BUT-
JUST SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. YEAH
NINETEEN. THANK RYAN SIXTY
THREE PLEASE CALL. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS JEFF
MARTINEZ REPRESENTING LOCAL
SEVEN OH ONE. FRESNO MADERA
TULARE AND KINGS COUNTIES WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU AND HAVE
A NICE DAY. THANK YOU I'M
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
THREE ZERO. YEAH GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE THIS IS
EUGENE MORRIS WITH CARPENTERS
LOCAL ONE FIFTY TWO
REPRESENTING SAN JOAQUIN
STANISLAUS MERCED MARIPOSA
CALAVERAS AMADOR INTO ALL OF
THE COUNTIES AND CON IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS JESSE BRALETTES
CALLING FROM CARPENTERS LOCAL
ONE FIFTY TWO REPRESENTING-
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND OVER
THIRTY NINE HUNDRED MEMBERS AND
WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT S. B.
SEVENTY SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
JERRY MEMBERS THIS IS DOUG
HICKS WITH LOCAL SIX ONE NINE
REPRESENTING SAN DIEGO AND
IMPERIAL COUNTY FOR THE
SOUTHWEST REGIONAL COUNCIL OF
CARPENTERS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU RYAN FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FIVE THREE. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES GO AHEAD YES.
FIVE BILLION STREET FIELD
REPRESENTATIVE CARPER'S LOCAL
TWENTY TWO AND SERVICES GO I'M
CALLING IN FULL SUPPORT OF- SB.
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
I'M THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS ALL DAY I'M A
WORK STOPPAGE REJECT COUNCIL
PARTNERS LEADER CALIFORNIA
LOCAL SEVEN TWENTY ONE AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU I TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT YOU KNOW CANCEL. LOOKING
RESPONSIBLE THANK YOU SOMEONE
TO TWELVE. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. RIGHT THANK YOU
OPERATOR WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE ONE WITNESS
LISTED SILVIO FERRARI. YES
HELLO MISTER CHAIRMAN CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. WONDERFUL MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AGAIN SO WE
OVER HERE WE HAVE TO CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION- AT THE AUTHOR STATE
I'LL AND ONE ALSO REMINDED ME A
LITTLE BIT OF HISTORY ON ON HOW
WE GOT HERE AND BACK IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. SEVENTEEN OH ONE
ANSWERED- WE THOUGHT IS AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION WHICH IS
WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN WHEN A
SUBCONTRACTOR FAILS TO PAY AN
EMPLOYEE. GREEN AT THAT TIME
WAS THAT A DIRECT CONTRACTOR IN
OUR CASE THE HOME BUILDER. BUT
STEP FORWARD HEY THE
SUBCONTRACTOR'S EMPLOYEE
DIRECTLY SO AT THAT TIME WE'VE
ESSENTIALLY PAID TWICE WE PAID
THE SUBCONTRACTOR AND WE'VE NOW
PAID THE EMPLOYEE. IN THAT SAME
AGREEMENT WAS MADE CLEAR THAT
WE'RE GONNA STEP UP. DO THE
RIGHT THING AND PAY THE
EMPLOYEE WE'RE NOT ALSO GOING
TO BE PENALIZED FOR DOING SO.
HELD A LIQUIDATED DAMAGES WOULD
NOT BE PUNITIVELY APPLY TO HOME
BUILDER IN THAT CASE. WE
PROVIDED SEVERAL DOCUMENTS EACH
YEAR OFFICE THAT REINFORCE THAT
DEAL. ON THE FIRST HOLE WITH A
LETTER FROM THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES THAT
MEMORIALIZE THAT DEAL AN
AGREEMENT. THE SECOND WAS A
LETTER FROM CBI RESTATING THE
AGREEMENT AS THE REASON FOR
GOING NEUTRAL. THERE WAS ALSO A
LETTER IN THE JOURNAL FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN THAT
REINFORCED THE AGREEMENT. AND
LAST WITH A FUNDING MESSAGE
FROM GOVERNOR BROWN THAT STATED
THE OFTEN SPONSORS THE BILL
HAVE COMMITTED TO PROPOSING
LEGISLATION NEXT YEAR. TO
RESOLVE THE DISPUTE AND IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE NEXT YEAR.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY FIVE BY
THURMAN WAS PASSED AND SIGNED.
AND RESOLVE THE DISPUTE. SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN IS A DOING ALL OF
THAT WERE. THAT BEING SAID
WE'VE MADE A CLEAR. THAT WE ARE
WELL. TO GO ALONG WITH SOME
BILLS FOR. SO LONG AS THE STATE
PUT THAT HAVE BEEN REFERENCED
ACTUALLY WORK. IN A MEANINGFUL.
WE HAVE OFFERED THREE SETS
AMENDMENTS TO DATE. WE HAVEN'T
RECEIVED WHAT I WOULD REFER TO
A SUBSTANTIVE FEEDBACK TO THOSE
AMENDMENTS- WE TALK WITH. YOU
ABOUT OUR OUR LATEST REQUEST
WHICH IS SIMPLY TO ALLOW
ALTERNATE COMPLIANCE PATH. OF
THE DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT CAN CONDUCT THE
REVIEW. IN OUR MINDS THAT IS
PRO WORKER. THEY ARE THE
AGENCIES THAT ARE THE RIGHT
PEOPLE TO DO THE REVIEW HAVE
THE WORK RIGHT SKILL SET TO DO
THE REVIEW. AND ABSENT THE
ABILITY TO USE THEM AS THE
REVIEWING AGENCY OUR VIEW IS
THAT THIS IS REALLY SETTING UP
HOME BUILDERS TO FAIL AND THEN
BE PENALIZED FOR IT. SO WERE
STRONGLY OPPOSED WE BELIEVE
WE'VE OFFERED MEANINGFUL
AMENDMENTS TO PUT THIS IN THE
RIGHT HANDS OF THE RIGHT
PEOPLE- AND UNTIL WE CAN MAKE
SOME HEADWAY ON A MAN'S. WE
WOULD URGE YOUR HELP OUT. THANK
YOU. THIRTY ONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO IT UP OF B.
C. SO. SEE NONE AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING THAT
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
pLINES FOR THOSE WHO'D LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION TO SEVEN SB
SEVEN TWO SEVEN AGAIN WE'RE
TAKING NAME AFFILIATION AND
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB SEVEN TWO SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I HAVE ABOUT SEVEN INK YOU WILL
GO TRYING TO NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING ASHLEY
HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN A POSITION TO BE A LEARNER
COMMENTS ABOUT THE MISTER
FERRARI THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M FORTY ONE THREE IS GOING.
GOOD MORNING ON BEHALF OF THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
OF LOS ANGELES VENTURA WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL MY NAME IS DIANA CORONADO.
THANK YOU I'M FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JIM COLLITON CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL CONTROLLER K.
HOVNANIAN A DEVELOPER AND
HOMEBUILDER THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE SB SEVENTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU I WON ALL FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE ONE ZERO FOUR.
MATTHEW HARPER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE SEVEN I'M SORRY
NINE TO SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH SUNBEAMS BANQUETS
IN NORTH STATE BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION ON
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SEVEN TWO SEVEN.
THANK YOU RYAN TO NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS CORNELIUS BURKE WITH
THE NORTH STATE BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU RYAN SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE SEVEN ZERO. MY NAME
IS STEVE WE'RE NUMBER LICENSE A
CONTRACTOR FOR CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY ON ENTERPRISE WRITTEN
SERVICEMEN STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN. YOU'RE
RIGHT ONE OF SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME'S CHAD
SCOTT OF THE SHASTA BUILDERS
EXCHANGE REPRESENTING
CONTRACTORS AND SHASTA SISKIYOU
MODOC LASSEN DANN MATERNITY AND
GOING COUNTIES- WE OPPOSE THIS
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU RYAN TO
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MATTHEW ADAMS
CALLING FROM THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OF SAN
DIEGO COUNTY CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. I THINK YOU ARE
FRIENDLY YOU MAY CLOSE THE
LINES ON SB SEVEN TWO SEVEN AND
I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. IT IS REYES THE
MINISTER HOLDEN. THANK YOU
SENATOR- IT I THINK IT WAS
CLEAR SPECIALLY FROM THE- THE
ANALYSIS THAT EVEN WITH THE
LEGISLATION TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THERE'S BEEN NO
EFFECTIVE DETERRENTS FOR
CONTINUE WAGE THEFT VIOLATIONS-
AND I APPRECIATE THAT THE
TESTIMONY FROM MISTER CURTAIN
REGARDING THE VERY ISSUES THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. AND I
APPRECIATE ALSO YOUR COMMENTS
INITIALLY THAT THIS HELPS THE
HONEST CONTRACTORS- EIGHT IN
PCS SCRUPULOUS ONES WHO STEAL
AND ALLOW SUBCONTRACTORS TO
STILL FROM THE VERY WORKERS WHO
HELP THEM BUILD THEIR PROJECTS
SO WITH THAT I WOULD MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MR HOLDEN. THANKS THANK YOU
SENATOR- AS I'VE MENTIONED TO
YOU BEFORE I'M SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL I BELIEVE THAT- WELL YOU
HAD ME AT THE BILL TO ADDRESS
WAGE THAT SO- AND I KNOW THAT
OVER. A PERIOD OF TIME THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN VERY
AGGRESSIVE IN ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE IN VARIOUS SECTORS OF TE
MARKET PLACE AND I THINK WE
RIGHTEOUSLY SO- I WANTED TO ASK
YOU A QUESTION AROUND THIS
ALTERNATIVE TO THE SAFE HARBOR-
BECAUSE I THINK. IT I DON'T
EVEN IF YOU'RE WILLING THIS
ACCEPT THIS AMENDMENT I'M NOT
SURE I'VE HEARD FROM. THE
OPPOSITION THAT THEY WOULD
REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION- I'D BE
INTERESTED TO KNOW IF THEY
WOULD. BUT I'M JUST CURIOUS
BECAUSE THE DIVISION OF LABOR
STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT. DOES
SEEM LIKE A- APPROPRIATE AREA
OR AGENCY TO BILLY KIND OF GET
IN THERE AND- AND MAYBE DO A
VERY THOROUGH. AND THOUGHTFUL
INVESTIGATION OF THESE RECORDS
ARE TO BE ABLE TO COME BACK
WITH. SOME CLEAR VIOLATIONS OF
ANY- AND SO I WAS JUST CURIOUS
AS TO. WHETHER YOU THOUGHT IF
THERE WAS A PROBLEM WITH THIS
APPROACH AS AN ALTERNATIVE
WHICH YOU ALREADY HAVE IN THE
BILL- WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ARE
ON. THAT WHICH YOU THINK THIS
DOES OR DOESN'T DO AS A AS A
PROPRIA MEHMET TO THE BILL
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR THE QUESTION SO I
THINK THAT PEOPLE GET VERY
ENAMORED WHEN THEY HEAR A
BUSINESS THEY WILL PAY FOR IT-
AND WIND- WE LOOK AT D. LOC AS
WHERE THEY WOULD HOUSE THIS.
DEAL AS HE DOES THIS NOT HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO DO THAT AND IF
THE CORPORATION IF THESE IF BE
A IS WILLING TO PAY FOR IT THEY
CAN HIRE A COMPANY THEY KIND OF
HURT A COMPANY YEARS AGO THEY
CAN HIRE A COMPANY TODAY. THAT
DOES THE AUDITING FOR THEM. I
PERSONALLY SEE THIS AS A STALL
TACTIC BECAUSE IF WE PUT IT
INTO THE GOVERNMENT TO DO WE
ALL KNOW GOVERNMENT MOVES
SLOWLY I WISH THAT IT DID NOT
BUT IT DOES BUT THIS IS GOING
TO CREATE A WHOLE NEW
DEPARTMENT. WE REACHED OUT TO
DELISTING WE HAVEN'T EVEN HEARD
BACK FROM THEM SO IF THEY CAN'T
EVEN RETURN OUR CALL ABOUT THIS
IT MAKES ME WONDER IF THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY ENACT
THIS PROGRAM. AND TO ASSEMBLY
WOMAN RAISES POINT SEVENTEEN NO
ONE WENT A LONG WAY IN HELPING
WITH WAGE THEFT BUT IT DIDN'T
GO ALL THE WAY UNTIL WE MAKE
SURE THAT NO WORKER. LOSES PAY
ON NO CONTRACTOR- THINKS OF-
WAGE THEFT AS A COST OF DOING
BUSINESS WE HAVEN'T DONE OUR
JOB WE HAVE SPOKEN WITH BE A
MANY TIMES WE'VE LISTENED TO
ALL OF THEIR CONCERNS. YOU KNOW
MR FOR OUR SAID THAT THEY HAVE
OFFERED MEANINGFUL AMENDMENTS
WELL I KNOW THAT THEY THINK
THEY'RE MEANINGFUL ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION WHO OFFERS
AMENDMENTS THINK SERMON
AMENDMENTS ARE MEANINGFUL SO I
DON'T DISAGREE WITH HIM ON THAT
POINT. WE JUST DON'T THINK THE
AMENDMENTS ENHANCE THE BILL WE
THINK IN. SOME POINTS IT EVEN
HURTS THE BILL. I THANK YOU.
THOSE OUT. YEAH THANK YOU
SENATOR- SO SOMEONE WHO
SUPPORTED SEVENTEEN NO. ONE-
YOU KNOW I. AND THE WHOLE AT
THE CONCEPT AS I REMEMBER IT
BACK THEN I MEAN THAT WAS A FEW
YEARS AGO BUT THE CONCEPT WAS
HAVE BEEN GENERAL HAS A JOB IN
THE SUB CAN'T CONTRACT IT
DOESN'T DO IT LET'S HAVE.
LIABILITY THERE BECAUSE SINCE
IT'S THE WHOLE PROJECT THEY'RE
THE ONE OVERSEEN RIGHT- BUT THE
DEAL WAS AND I THINK IT'S
ALREADY BEEN TALKED ABOUT BUT
THE DEAL WAS IS THAT WE'RE NOT
HAVING PENALTIES ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT GENERAL BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT THE ONE WHO. DID
THAT IT WAS THE SUB WHO
ACTUALLY DID THAT AND AS WE
FOLLOW THROUGH ON THAT WE HAD
LEGISLATION TO CLEAN THAT UP
THE NEXT YEAR BY. MR THURMAN'S.
AND I FEEL LIKE THIS IS KIND OF
GOING BACK ON. WHAT THAT
PRINCIPLE WAS. AS I UNDERSTAND
IT THERE'S ONLY BEEN ONE CASE
WHERE WE HAD. WHERE SEVENTEEN
NO ONE. WAS USED TO ENSURE THAT
SOMEONE. WAS PAID. SO IT'S NOT
LIKE WE'VE HAD A LOT OF THESE
TYPE OF CASES OUT THERE- AND
AGAIN I THINK THAT THE LAW IS
WORKING I THINK THE OTHER
THINGS THAT WE HAVE A PLACE-
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER AND
OTHERS. OUR ENFORCEABLE AND ARE
A RESULT IN ENSURING THAT
WORKERS GET PAID SO. I JUST
DON'T SEE THE NEED AND NOT LOOK
UP IN SUPPORT OF THE CONCEPT OF
I THINK THERE ARE CASES WHERE
GENERAL'S NEED TO BE LIABLE FOR
THE FACT THAT THIS DOESN'T
HAPPEN. BUT WE START THROWING
IN PENALTIES THAT USUALLY
ASSOCIATE WITH AN INTENTIONAL
NONPAYMENT OF- OF WAGES WHICH
IN THIS CASE IS A SUB. IT IS
DONE THAT NOT THE GENERAL SO I
JUST I FEEL LIKE HAVING PEOPLE
ALMOST LIKE A PAYMENT PUNITIVE
DAMAGES PENALTIES. ON SOMEONE
WHO WASN'T THE DIRECT THAT
ACTOR JUST DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
THE RIGHT APPROACH TO THE AND I
MEAN. SO I WOULD JUST RESPOND
WITH THIS IS SOMEONE WHO
NEGOTIATED CONTRACTS FOR MANY
YEARS BEFORE I RAN FOR OFFICE.
WITHOUT A PENALTY IT'S JUST A
SUGGESTION SEVENTEEN NO ONE IS
A SUGGESTION THERE IT WITHOUT
AN ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM WITH
THE PENALTY THEN WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN THE CONTRACTOR DOESN'T PAY
WHEN THE SUB DOESN'T PAY WHAT
HAPPENS THEN TO THE WORKER.
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO SUFFER AND
IF YOU DO IT RIGHT AND IF YOU
DON'T AND YOU ABIDE BY THE LAW
THEN THE PENALTY IS NOT A
PROBLEM. AND I MEAN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE I CAN ASK- MY
WITNESS TO TALK ABOUT THE
SEVENTEEN A ONE TO GO SHE
ASIANS BUT- THIS IS A DIFFERENT
BILL. IT'S A DIFFERENT AUTHOR
IT'S GOING TO A DIFFERENT
GOVERNOR IF SEVENTEEN OH ONE
WERE WORKING IN ITS ENTIRETY
THIS BILL WOULDN'T BE NEEDED.
BUT IT ISN'T SO THAT'S WHY
SEVEN TWO SEVEN IS NEEDED. BUT
DOESN'T WORK BECAUSE THE IDEA
IS THAT IF THEY DON'T GET PAID
IN THE GENERAL. IS LIABLE AND
YOU CAN ACTUALLY COLLECT FROM
THAT GENERAL. THE UNPAID WAGES
THAT WASN'T SO SEVENTEEN OH ONE
IS NOT A SUGGESTION IT'S A
LEGALLY BINDING LAW. THAT PUTS
THEM ON THE HOOK AND- AT LEAST
RIGHT NOW THE ONLY WE ONLY HAVE
ONE DOCUMENTED CASE WHERE THIS
HAPPENED AND THEY DID PAY THEM.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ONLY ONE
DOCUMENTED CASE WE HAVE A-
REPORT THAT SAYS IS ABOUT FORTY
PERCENT. OF WORKERS WHO- HOW
ARE THEIR WAGES HAVE BEEN
STOLEN SO THAT I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT IS JUST ONE CASE. AND
IF YOU HAVE THERE ARE CASES
WHAT. HAVE THEY BROUGHT CASES
US AND TRY TO RECOVER FROM THE
GENERAL FUND. IT AND IF THEY
DON'T IF THE GENERAL DOESN'T
HERE HERE'S THE IMPORTANT PART
ABOUT SEVEN TO SEVEN VERSUS
SEVENTEEN OH ONE. IF THEY ARE
NOT PAID. THEN WHAT HAPPENS TO
THE GENERAL NOTHING. THERE'S NO
PENALTY FOR NOT PAYING YOUR
WORKERS THERE'S NO PENALTY
NOTHING HAPPENS. BUT THE WORKER
DOESN'T GET PAID HE'S THE ONE
OR SHE'S THE ONE WHO CAN'T PAY
THEIR BILLS I GUESS THAT'S WHY
I'M CONFUSED. MY UNDERSTAND IS
THAT YES THEY DO GET PAID
BECAUSE THEY THEY SEE THE
GENERAL THE GENERAL HAS TO PAY
THEM. IF THEY ARE NOT THAT
GENERAL GETS PENALIZED ENOUGH
TO PAY ADDITIONAL PENALTIES AND
DAMAGES THAT'S THAT'S- THAT'S
YOUR BILL. RIGHT BUT TO SAY
THAT THEY DON'T GET PAID THAT'S
NOT TRUE. IT IS TRUE I WOULDN'T
BE DOING THE BILL FOR BECAUSE
WE'RE GETTING PAID IF WAGE
THEFT WASN'T OCCURRING I
WOULDN'T BE DOING TO FILL SO.
YOU'RE TELLING ME IS RIGHT NOW
IF SOMEONE COMES AND SAYS HEY I
DIDN'T GET PAID BY MYSELF. AND
SUIT IS WHAT JOINED SEVERAL
pTHE GENERAL. AND THEY PROVE
THEY WEREN'T PAID. THE GENERAL
WILL BE ORDERED TO PAY THOSE
WAGES SO I'M THE WORKER. AND I
DON'T GET PAID. SO I HAVE TO GO
GET AN ATTORNEY AND I HAVE TO
SUE THE GENERAL WHAT HAPPENS
ALL MY BILLS DURING THAT TIME
WHO PAYS MY RENT WHO PAYS MY
HOUSE PAYMENT. WHO PAYS FOR
CHILD CARE WHO PAYS FOR FOOD.
SUING SOMEONE. IS NOT THE
REMEDY. I MEAN YOU CAN DO IT
FOR SURE I MEAN IT IS A REMEDY
WELL YEAH BUT I MEAN. I KNOW
YOU'RE A LAWYER AND I'M A
LAWYER I'M NOT A LAWYER IT IS
IN FACT A REMEDY IT IS A REMEDY
IS. NOT A VIOLENT REMEDY THAT'S
USED BY A LOT OF PEOPLE.
RECOVER DAMAGES WHEN THEY'RE
NOT. WHEN SOMEONE BREACHES OF
CONTRACT IS ESSENTIAL WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT I COME I AGREED
TO WORK FOR YOU FOR. YOU KNOW
AND AGREED PAY. YOU DON'T PAY
ME- I'M GONNA GO I AM GOING TO
SUE YOU OR USE WHATEVER
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM I CAN'T
RECOVER THAT. WAS SEVENTEEN OH
ONE WE SAID. I MEAN USUALLY
THAT'S THE SUB THAT'S YOUR.
SOMETIMES THERE'S BAD ACTORS
THERE- AND A SUB MAYBE. DOESN'T
PAY LET'S MAKE SURE THAT AT
LEAST THE GENERAL. IS GONNA PAY
THAT AND MAYBE THE GENERAL
DOESN'T EVEN KNOW BUT STILL IT
WAS THEIR JOB IT WAS THIS
OVERALL PROJECT. SO IT MAKES
SENSE TO SAY LOOK YOU MAKE SURE
THIS PERSON GETS PAID THEY
WORKED ON YOUR JOB. RIGHT HI
I'M 1100% OKAY WITH THAT IS WHY
SUPPORTERS SEVENTEEN OH ONE.
BUT IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
PUNITIVE DAMAGES AND PENALTIES
ON TOP OF THAT. TO ME THAT
SHOULD BE THE SUB NOT THE
GENERAL WHO JUST WHO. IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
THAT THAT HAPPENED. I THINK WE
JUST HAVE A FUNDAMENTAL
DISAGREEMENT AND WE'RE JUST
GONNA HAVE TO AGREE TO DISAGREE.
AND NO I'M NOT AN ATTORNEY NOR
DO I THOUGHT I HAD THAT ON TV.
MY BAD I WILL. I WAS A LABOR
LEADER THIS MONEY IS A. OTHER
QUESTIONS ARE COMMON. THIS IS A
I FIRST LIKE TO POINT OUT TO BE
A LABOR LEADER IN INTERNET OR
NOT USUALLY EXCLUSIVE THAT IS
TRUE THAT IS VERY TRUE I THINK
THERE'S ANOTHER PERSON IN THE
SENATE ALSO WHO HAD THOSE
DISTINCTIONS- I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU FOR THIS BILL
OBVIOUSLY IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART I
ALSO. JUST SO PEOPLE UNDERSTAND.
WANT TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE THAT
WICKS THAT COMES IN A LOT OF
FORM. IT IN AND YES YOU AS A
WORKER MAY SAY I DON'T GET A
PAYCHECK AND HOW MAY BE VERY
OBVIOUS. YOU MAY ALSO- BE IT
NOT. BEING GIVEN OVERTIME OR
MEAL AND REST BREAKS OR- YOU
KNOW ANY FORM OF COMPENSATION.
THAT IS OFTEN SKIMMED OFF. THE
TOP IN ORDER TO ADD. IN SHORT I
GUESS THE SUB CONTRAST MORE
PROFITS IN THE WORKER DOESN'T
GET WHAT THEY DESERVE. AND ALSO
IT'S NOT ALWAYS CLEAR TO THE
WORKER THAT THEY'VE BEEN A
VICTIM OF WAGE THEFT- AND
SOMETIMES EVEN IF IT IS THE
WORKER MAY BE SO VULNERABLE.
THAT PURSUING A WAGE THEFT
CLAIM- FOR VARIETY OF REASONS
ISN'T. WITHIN- A REALISTIC YEAH
I GUESS REMEDY SO I I'M GLAD
THAT YOU'RE DOING THIS I THINK
YOU KNOW IT WE HAVE GOT TO
STOP. WHICH HAVE TO SPECIALLY
IN THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
WHICH IS RAMPANT AND THAT WE
KNOW- I AM WHEN THOSE PEOPLE
ENAMORED WITH THE IDEA OF MORE
MANY CLAIMS TO THE STATE AT. SO
YOU KNOW BUT OBVIOUSLY THAT'S
THAT'S NOT A DEAL BREAKER FOR
ME- I AM GLAD YOU'RE DOING THIS
AND WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY. AND JUST WHAT ENCOURAGE
AT LEAST A DISCUSSION- WITH CBA
SO THAT THEY CAN SIT NOT
SUGGEST ANYMORE THAT. THERE'S
NO DISK I'M SURE YOU WOULD HAVE
LOVED TO CBSA ALL THE TIE JUST
GOOD GOLLY FOR MYSELF IS HERE
CAN TELL YOU THAT SHE EMAILS
AND TALK TO THEM ALL THE TIME I
HAVE MET WITH THEM. I THINK
THAT SOMETIMES OPPOSITION LIKE
TO IMPLY ABSOLUTELY I JUST
BECAUSE WE DON'T LIKE YOUR
AMENDMENT DOESN'T. GIVE YOU AN
EXPLANATION AS TO WHY WE DIDN'T
LIKE IT AND YOU KNOW THANK YOU
FOR SUGGESTING IT BUT NO THANK
YOU. WELL I DO AGREE ON THAT
THE BUILDERS CAN DO THIS THEY
THEY CAN COMPLY WITH THIS LAW
THEY DON'T NEED AN ALTERNATIVE
BUT- SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
FORTY. STATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
RIGHT THANK YOU SENATOR YOU MAY
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
EIGHT ON AYE VOTE SO THAT.
WORKERS CAN BE TREATED FAIRLY
AND THAT WAGE THEFT IS NOT THE
COST OF DOING BUSINESS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION TO SECOND THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
CALDWELL PLEASE. STONE AYE
STONE AYE GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER
NO SHALL CHU CHU FIVE DAVIES
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ HI HOLDEN
HOLDEN I KALRA KALRA I. KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN II
REYES BRAESIDE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
SENATOR GONZALEZ ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SB. SIX OH SIX. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THANK YOU
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT SB
SIX OH SIX WHICH DIRECTLY
ADDRESSES SOME OF THE WORST
EMPLOYER ABUSES SEEN DURING THE
COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC. BUT
THAT WILL REMAIN UNFORTUNATELY
JUST AS IMPORTANT AS A PANDEMIC
WINDS DOWN IT WILL CODIFY PARTS
OF FEDERAL OSHA POLICY FOR
GREGIS VIOLATIONS GIVING
KALISTO THE AUTHORITY TO IMPOSE
ADDITIONAL PENALTIES ON
EMPLOYERS FOR WILLFUL
VIOLATIONS WERE WORKERS HAVE
BEEN KNOWINGLY HARMED BY IF
THEY ARE FAILURE TO COMPLY WITH
HEALTH AND SAFETY LAWS. THE
BILL THE FEDERAL OSHA'S
CORPORATE WIDE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT POLICY BY PROVIDING
CAL OSHA THE AUTHORITY TO ISSUE
AN ENTERPRISE WIDE CITATION
THAT WOULD APPLY TO ALL
OCCASIONS UNDER COMMON
OWNERSHIP ON AN EMPLOYER'S
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
DIRECTLY VIOLATE LABOR AND
HEALTH. VIOLATE LABOR HEALTH
AND SAFETY STANDARDS AS CHAIR
OF THE SENATE SPECIAL COMMITTEE
ON PANDEMIC RESPONSE LAST YEAR
I HEARD FIRST HAND THE CALL
OSHA HAS BEEN INUNDATED WITH
MORE COMPLAINTS THAN INSPECTORS
CAN HANDLE LEADING STAFF TO
RELY INCREASINGLY ON LETTER
ONLY INVESTIGATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN INSUFFICIENT. SB SIX A SIX
PROVIDES COLOR SHE WITH THE
NECESSARY TOOLS TO MAXIMIZE THE
USE OF THEIR LIMITED RESOURCES
SO THEY'RE ABLE TO RESPOND MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY TO
HEALTH AND SAFETY VIOLATIONS.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY
HAVE JUST A GREAT WALL
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR U. F.
C. W. WESTERN STATES COUNCIL
AND MITCH SNIDER POLICY
ADVOCATE FOR CALIFORNIA. LABOR
FEDERATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SO I DO HAVE. TWO
WITNESSES LISTED JESSE GRUEL
AND MITCH STEIGER BOTH WITH US
ON THE TELEPHONE JESSE GROUP.
GOOD AFTERNOON TERRY MEMBERS I
THINK THAT THE MOST MINUTES
BACK AND I'LL MAKE SURE TO KEEP
MY COMMENTS BRIEF MY NAME IS
JACKIE GRAY WHILE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR WITH THE U. S. B. W.
WESTERN STATE COUNCIL IF YOU
HAVE YOU REPRESENT OVER A
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND WORKERS
IN CALIFORNIA ALL OF THEM HAVE
BEEN GAME FRONTLINE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS THROUGHOUT THIS
PANDEMIC. YOUR CONSTITUENTS ARE
MEMBERS LED TO THE OCCASION AND
CUT THEIR AND THEIR FAMILIES
HEALTH AND SAFETY ON THE LINE
TO START CALIFORNIANS
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC.
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT PERMIT
CALLOW SAID TO LEVY FINES OR
OTHER REMEDIES EVERY STEP
INSIDE THE CONSEQUENT SHOULD IT
TURNED DEADLY CONDUCT BY LARGE
CORPORATIONS AND MAKES
ENFORCEMENT NEEDLESSLY
DUPLICATIVE AND EXPENSIVE. THIS
IS WHY WE NEED SB SIX SX THANK
YOU SENATOR GONZALEZ FOR
OFFERING THIS IMPORTANT MATTER
I THINK EXPENSE EXPENSE
ASSEMBLY RACE COLORS THE
PENALTY FOR ALL EMPLOYERS IT
TAKES A TARGETED APPROACH TO
RAISING PENALTIES BUT THE MOST
EGREGIOUS AND WHERE YOU CAN
THAT WELL FOR VIOLATIONS.
SERVING AS A REAL INCENTIVE FOR
EMPLOYERS TO VOLUNTARILY COMPLY
WITH HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS I DEFINITELY HELLO
SIR DOES NOT CURRENTLY HAVE
TOOL THAT IS DISPOSABLE THE
WHOLE TRAIN COMPANIES
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN AN EMPLOYER
THREATEN POLICIES OR PROCEDURES
ARE IN DIRECT VIOLATION OF
HEALTH AND SAFETY ORDERS. AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC
WHEN IT WITH CAUTION THAT
KILLED NINETEEN COULD BE SPREAD
THE AFTER CONTACT CAL OSHA
ISSUED INDUSTRY GUIDANCE THAT
PROHIBITED WORKERS FROM
HANDLING REYES ALL THAT BUT A
LARGE CHAIN GROCERY EMPLOYER
AND IT'S RIGHT IN POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES ASK WORKERS TO
CONTINUE TO HANDLE RESULT BACK.
AND DIRECT CONTRADICTION OF THE
CALLOUS ORDER AND THEIR
SITUATION OVER A HUNDRED
COMPLAINTS WOULD HAVE BEEN
NEEDED TO BE FILED WITH CARLOS
AT THE AFRICAN EMPLOYER TO
ABATE THE HAZARD WORKPLACE BY
WORKPLACE THIS IS NEEDLESSLY
DUPLICATIVE AND WORKERS WILL BE
WAITING MONTHS IF NOT YEARS
UNTIL THEY FIND THE BASEMENT OF
THE HOUSE- CONTINUING TO PUT
WORKERS HEALTH AND SAFETY AT
RISK. SB SIX SX IT'S CRITICAL
TO OUR STATE RECOVERY WE MUST
SLOW WORKS RIGHT WORKPLACE
PRIDE IN PREVENTATIVE SMALL
OUTBREAKS IF WE HAVE ANY HOPE
OF RETURNING TO NORMAL FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
AFTER I FELL ON SB SIX ATTACKS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND THEN
MITCH STAGGER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURKE MITCH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WE CENTER PROUD TO
CLOSE THIS HELLO WITH YOUR SET
UP AND WORKS A STAT ARE GOING
THROUGH A FEW ROUNDS OF NOW
DOES BASIC THREE CHIANG BEFORE
IS THAT IT ALLOWS ENTERPRISE
WIDE SO. THAT WILL STREAMLINE
THE OF SETTING EMPLOYER LARGE
EMPLOYER THAT ARE BREAKING THE
LAW IN MULTIPLE LOCATION AT
ONCE BUT WE IT'S A VERY FAIR
AND YOU DO WAY OUT FROM PLAYERS.
DON'T HAVE A BLANK HEALTH AND
SAY POLICY THAT COVERS THE
ENTIRE ESTABLISHMENT IT ALSO
IT'S NOT WHICH IS THE CATEGORY
OF THE EGREGIOUS CITATIONS AND
THESE ARE A SUBSET OF WHAT ARE
CALLED WILLFUL CITATIONS WHEN
AN EMPLOYER IS AWARE THAT THE
CONDITION IS HAZARDOUS OR
ILLEGAL AND TAKES NO ACTION TO
ABATE THAT HAZARD WHEN THERE'S
SOME SORT OF AGGRAVATING
CIRCUMSTANCE LIKE A BUNCH OF
WORKERS GOT HURT OR BUNCH OF
WORKERS DIED AS HAS HAPPENED IN
OCTOBER NINETEEN. WILL BRING IN
THIS CONCEPT OF EGREGIOUS
CITATIONS FROM FEDERAL LAW TO-
BE USED IN THOSE RARE CASES AND
WE DO MEAN VERY RARE- LAST YEAR
THERE WERE TWO WILLFUL
CITATIONS OF THE YEAR PRIOR TO
THAT THERE WERE THREE OF THESE
WOULD BE A SUBSET OF THOSE SO
THESE ARE GONNA BE
EXTRAORDINARILY RARE ONLY USED
IN THE WORST OF THE WORST
CASES. AND THE LAST THING IS
THAT IT CLARIFIES THAT HELLO
SIR CAN SITE VIOLATIONS OF THE
LABOR CODE RIGHT NOW CALLOUS
ONLY SITES TITLE EIGHT
REGULATION VIOLATIONS AND SO
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE FOR
EXAMPLE WANTS TO TAKE ACTION ON
A WORKER SAFETY ISSUE THAT.
GOES IN THE STATUTE WHICH
DOESN'T REALLY LEAVE ANY THERE
TO IT AND SO THE PROVISION
GIVES LEGISLATURE MORE
AUTHORITY OVER THESE OF SAY SO
YOU ALL CAN WAY AND WHEN YOU
THAT'S A- JUST A QUICK TOUCH ON
THE THAT DONE WILL DO TO THE
NINETEEN CPAS ABOUT PRESENT OF
ATTACK. WE ALSO BELIEVE
LANGUAGE EXT BUT OF COLORS.
BAKER RESULT IN A CITED. WE
ALSO REPLACED WHAT WAS A BRAND
NEW PROCESS OF REVIEWING.
CERTAIN TYPES OF APPEALS WITH
THE ACTUAL LETTER PROCESS THAT
ALREADY EXISTS THAT SOMETHING.
MORE FAMILIAR WEST CLOSER WE
URGE YOUR- THANK YOU RIGHT WE
WILL NOW GO TO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX OF SIX IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SEEING NONE AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR THE ANYONE WHO LIKED
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB SIX OH
SIX. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX OH
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AT TEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OKAY WE HAVE
ABOUT STRIVING Q. ABOUT TRYING
TO NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS LOOK UP THE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATIVE BOARDS MARC
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RIGHT NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES YOU
ARE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE ONE
TWENTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JUSTIN RATHER ON BEHALF OF
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA ROOTS OF
CHANGE CALIFORNIANS FOR
PESTICIDE REFORM AND PESTICIDE
ACTION NETWORK ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
JESSICA CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND
RETURNING ADVOCATES NETWORK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RAIMES THREE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. COOL
QUERY WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES CALLING IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME RIGHT THANK YOU WE
WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION I HAVE
ONE WITNESS LISTED ROBERT
MUTRIE. WITH US ON THE
TELEPHONE NUMBER WHICH WE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. YES GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR SORRY I CAN'T. BE
THERE WITH ALL OF YOU A LITTLE
UNDER THE WEATHER I PREFER NOT
TO BE THE PERSON COUGHING AT
THE CAPITOL SO I. HOPE YOU
DON'T MIND- AGAIN ROBERT METRIC
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AT THE
TEXAS TECH- SO. I'LL BE BRIEF
GET RIGHT TO THE POINT. ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT- SB SIX AFFECT
HER A COUPLE OF POINTS NUMBER
ONE. CONCERN THAT THE LAWYER
WIDE PATIENTS OR CUT THE
ENTERPRISE WHAT THAT PATIENT-
CREATED BY SB THICKER THICK- DO
NOT ACTUALLY REQUIRE THAT. YOU
PRACTICE BEING- CITED FOR. IT
AFFECTED MULTIPLE LOCATIONS ARE
THE- THE KIND OF THE POLICY IS
THERE SO WE SHARED SOME
LANGUAGE WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR. TO TRY TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS THERE SO THAT WE CAN
BE SURE THAT THE ENTERPRISE
WHAT THAT HAITIANS. ARE
ACTUALLY APPLIED WHETHER IT'S
ENTERPRISE WIDE PROBLEM. AND
WE'RE IN DISCUSSIONS ON THAT
POINT- AS YOU DEGREE GET THEM
PLAYER POINT WE'VE ALSO BEEN
DISCUSSION OF YEP THEY'RE
THEY'RE IN THE HOPES OF.
CLARIFYING THAT DEFINITION- IT
IS A MISTER SPEAKER NOTED I
BELIEVE IN IN FEDERAL LAW
COMING FROM THERE. WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT DEFINITION
DOESN'T. UNINTENTIONALLY HARM
LONG TERM EMPLOYERS WHO WILL
FALL INTO SUMMIT DEFINITIONS
MORE QUICKLY THAN SHORTER- I
BELIEVE THE AUTHOR HAS
EXPRESSED INTEREST IN MOVING
THEIR STORE THANKFUL FOR THAT.
OR IF YOU NEED A SPONSOR AND
EXPRESSED SOME INTEREST MOVING
THERE- WE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT-
IT DIDN'T CHANGE THE CALLOW
SHOULD. ENFORCEMENT SUCH THAT
THE FORCE WILL BEGIN BEFORE A
REGULATIONS PUT IN PLACE
INTERPRETING AND KIND OF THE-
DEFINING EXACTLY WHAT FORSMAN
SHOULD BE THERE- IF THE CONCERN
THERE THAT THE REGULATIONS
GENERALLY TEND TO BE QUITE.
MORE PRECISE AND MORE EXACT
THAT'S WHAT COMPLIANCE IT WE
HAVE CONCERNS THAT WITHOUT
THAT. ENFORCEMENT AGAIN TRUMP
PLATE THAT MAYBE IT'S MORE BAG.
I DON'T THINK OF THE PLACE WILL
BE ABLE TO COME TOGETHER WITH
THE- WITH THE SPONSORED I'VE
SPOKEN WE SPOKE ON THIS POINT.
BUT THAT THE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN. FOR US- YEAH BEEN
WE'VE BEEN INTO THEIR CHRIS.
AND I APPRECIATE IMMENSELY THEM
IT'S STEIGER ARE WE- TO
PARTICULARLY CLEAR IF I NEED.
PROCESS WITH THE PRAYER LINE
WAS REAL- JUST. AT NOT AT LINE
CREDIT PRESS. CONCERNING PRESS.
WE HAVE ON THE CONCERNS DO A
PRE THE DISCUSS. AFTER THOSE
WRITTEN WE HOURS. OPPOSE AND
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. RIGHT IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO
LIKE TO SPEAK IT UP AS OF US
SIX SIX. SEEING NONE OF THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING
THE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO DECADE OPPOSITION TO SB SIX
OF. SIX THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB
SIX OH SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT SEVEN LINE
THANK YOU OF OUR TO LINE THREE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING HERE MEMBERS PERSONAL
KID OFF ON BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC
GREAT INNOVATION SOLUTIONS AND
MANAGEMENT PRESENT IN THE
COUNTY OF KERN INTERSECT
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN TO AWAIT PLEASE GO AHEAD-
GOOD MORNING I MISSED YOUR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON A
MATTHEW WILD WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE ALSO AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. THANK YOU RYAN THREE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE K<c.cyan> CAMPAIGN</c>
WITH A CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN ONE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING PAPER GETS
ON BEHALF OF THE FAMILY
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
HIM BUT MINOR COMMENTS THAT
THAT THE MR MICHIE. THANK YOU
I'M THREE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING REBEKAH
BACKEND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA GROCERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA COTTON
GENERATION GROWERS ASSOCIATION
AND AMERICAN PISTACHIO GROWERS
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT TO SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE CHRIS WALKER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STACY
SUSPICION OF SHEET METAL AND
AIR CONDITIONING CONTRACTORS.
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. THANK YOU RYAN THREE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD-
THIS IS JAMIE CONN ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATED GENERAL
CONTRACTORS IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TWO SEVEN CHARGE SIX OF SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN THREE
TEAM PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE BRIAN LITTLE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU%
FEDERATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
ENUMERATED BY MR MITRI WITH THE
CHAMBER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME RIGHT THANK
YOU YOU MAY CLOSE THE LINES
OPERATOR OF BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SING DANCE CENTER YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL ON
BEHALF OF MANY CALIFORNIA
WORKERS OF THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. STONE AYE STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER NO CHAU
CHIU CHU FIVE DAVIES. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN HOLDEN I
KALRA RIGHT KALRA AYE KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN HI RES.
I THINK THE BILL IS OUT DOUBLES
UP THANK YOU SIR. CORRECT WE'LL
TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN SB
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT THE BEEN
PULLED OFF OF CONSENT. THANK
YOU THE MOTION IS THEIR SECOND.
WE DO NOT HAVE A SECOND SENATOR
WELL HOPEFULLY BY THE END OF
THE PRESENTATION WE WILL SO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT. SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT AT TWO THIS MORNING
ASSEMBLE TO RADIATE ESTABLISHES
A SINGLE STEP CONVERSION
PROCESS FOR CALIFORNIA
CORPORATIONS TO BECOME FOREIGN
CORPORATIONS OR BASICALLY WHAT
THAT MEANS IN THIS CONTEXT IS
AN OUT OF STATE CORPORATIONS.
BUSINESS OWNERS OFTEN DESIRE TO
CHANGE THE FORM OF ORGANIZATION
OF THEIR BUSINESS OR THE STATE
IN WHICH THEIR BUSINESSES
FORMED THIS MAY BE NECESSARY
FOR EXAMPLE TO RESPOND TO
CHANGING ECONOMIC CONDITIONS
CHANGES IN THE IN THE
BUSINESSES THEY CAN DOCTOR
CHANGES IS CHANGES. IN THEIR
SHAREHOLDERS PRIORITIES ALL
CALIFORNIA PROVIDES A MECHANISM
FOR PARTNERSHIPS AND LLCS TO
CONVERT FROM ONE TYPE OF AN
ENTITY TO ANOTHER IN A SINGLE
STEP WE ARE ONE OF THE FEW
STATES THAT DOES NOT OFFER
SINGLE STEP PROCESS FOR THE
CONVERSION OF A CORPORATION.
FOR EXAMPLE LET'S SAY A
CALIFORNIA CORPORATION DESIRES
TO CONVERT INTO A DELAWARE
CORPORATION THEY MUST EITHER
INCORPORATE AS A NEW
CORPORATION IN DELAWARE AND
THEN MERGE THE TWO ENTITIES
TOGETHER WITH THE DELAWARE
CORPORATION SURVIVING THE
MERGER AND THE CALIFORNIA
CORPORATION CEASING TO EXIST
OR- CONVERT INTO ANOTHER TYPE
OF CALIFORNIA BUSINESS ENTITY
SUCH AS A PARTNERSHIP OR LLC.
AND THEN CONVERT THAT INTO T.
INTO A DELAWARE CORPORATION
MULTISTEP CONVERSIONS ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE CUMBERSOME
TIME CONSUMING AND EXPENSIVE
WELL MAKING IT EASIER FOR BOTH
THE BUSINESSES TO INCORPORATE
ELSEWHERE MAY SOUND LIKE IT
WILL FINAL BUSINESS OUT OF
CALIFORNIA WILL ACTUALLY HAVE
THE OPPOSITE EFFECT. IF A
BUSINESS IS CREATED AND THEY
BELIEVE THERE MAY BE A REASON
TO INCORPORATE IN ANOTHER STATE
ONE DAY THEY'RE LIKELY TO
CHOOSE TO INCORPORATE. THERE
NOW JUST IN CASE. TO AVOID THE
ONEROUS CONVERSION PROCESS OF A
CORPORATION IN CALIFORNIA. FIG
PARTNERS KNOW THEY COULD
UTILIZE A SINGLE STEP FOREIGN
CONVERSION PROCESS SHOULD BE
NET BECOME NECESSARY ONE DAY IN
THE FUTURE. THEY ALWAYS
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE LIKELY TO
INCORPORATE IN CALIFORNIA.
SINCE THE BURDEN OF THE PROCESS
TO MOVE THE LOCATION OF THEIR
INCORPORATION OUT OF STATE WILL
BE MUCH LESS CUMBERSOME AND
COSTLY. I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
HERE AND YOU KNOW THAT JUST
MEANS IF THEY WANT TO. MOVE
THAT THE LOCATION OF THE
INCORPORATION NOT THE ACTUAL-
PHYSICAL. LOCATION OF THEIR
HEADQUARTERS OR WHERE THEY
OPERATE. THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
CORPORATIONS WITH SOME
FLEXIBILITY AVAILABLE TO
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS AND
LLCS AND CORPORATIONS AND OTHER
STATES HAVE A PRACTITIONER
THERE ARE NONE ON THE CO HOST
TELECONFERENCE LINE TO SHARE.
HIS REAL WORLD EXPERIENCE AND
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THAT MAY COME UP. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU I DO
HAVE THE ONE WITNESS LISTED
THERE ARE NONE. PLEASE GOOD
MORNING YEAH YES GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DARREN NINE I AM THE
VICE CHAIR OF LEGISLATION OF
THE- CORPORATIONS COMMITTEE OF
THE BUSINESS LAW SECTION OF THE
CALIFORNIA LAWYERS ASSOCIATION.
AND THE WAY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THIS BILL WOULD CONFORM THE
CONVERSION PROVISIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA CORPORATIONS CODE
WITH THE CONVERSION PROVISIONS
OF THE CALIFORNIA UNIFORM
PARTNERSHIP ACT OF NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR. THE CALIFORNIA
UNIFORM LIMITED PARTNERSHIP ACT
OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHT. AND A
CALIFORNIA REVISED UNIFORM
LIMITED LIABILITY COMPANY AT.
ALL THREE OF THE EIGHT STATUTES
PROVIDE FOR A SINGLE STEP
CONVERSION PROCESS. FOR THOSE
ENTITIES TO CONVERT TO AND NOW
THEY'RE OUT OF STATE ENTITY.
THE CALIFORNIA CORPORATIONS
CODE DOES NOT. IT THE IT ALLOWS
ONLY THE CONVERSION. OF A
CALIFORNIA CORPORATION INTO
ANOTHER TYPE OF CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS ENTITY SUCH AS A
GENERAL OR LIMITED PARTNERSHIP
OR LIMITED LIABILITY COMPANY.
IN THE ABSENCE OF A SINGLE STEP
PROCESS AND CALIFORNIA
CORPORATION WISHING TO CONVERT
INTO A BUSINESS ENTITY
ORGANIZED UNDER THE LAWS OF
ANOTHER STATE. IS LEFT WITH A
TWO STEP PROCESS. WHICH WAS
DESCRIBED BY SENATOR JOHNS JUST
NOW. THE CALIFORNIA CORPORATION
CAN CONVERT INTO ANOTHER TYPE
OF BUSINESS ENTITY IT JUST
REQUIRES ADDITIONAL HOOPS TO
JUMP THROUGH. SB TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT WOULD ESTABLISH THE
PROCEDURES FOR THE DIRECT
CONVERSION OF A DOMESTIC
CORPORATION INTO A FOREIGN
BUSINESS ENTITY OR QUORUM
CORPORATION. MAYES PROCEDURES
WITH CLOSELY TRACKED THE
PROCEDURES THAT CURRENTLY
APPLIED TO THE CONVERSION OF
DOMESTIC CORPORATIONS INTO
DOMESTIC OTHER BUSINESS
ENTITIES. CALIFORNIA LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THIS BILL AND I WILL STAND BY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
THE MEMBERS MAY HAVE THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO'D LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR SB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT. SEEING
NONE THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES PLEASE
FOR ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT. YOUR PARENTS PART
OF S. B. TWO EIGHTY EIGHT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO OF
YOUR SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO EIGHT
EIGHT. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU WE WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE NO OPPOSITION
LISTED. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO
SPEAK WITH US AND- OF SB TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT. SEEING NONE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR JOB ALIGNS
FOR ANY OPPOSITION TO SB TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR IN
UP IN OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO
EIGHT EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND
THEN THEIR OWN FEAR IN
OPPOSITION OF SB. TWO EIGHT
EIGHT. WE HAVE NOT BUSINESS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU OPERATOR YOU MAY CLOSE THE
LINES WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE THIS GONZALEZ. AND AT
THANK YOU FOR REACHING OUT WHEN
I PUT UP CONSENT WONDERING-
WHAT INFORMATION WERE RELYING
ON TO YOU KNOW STUDIES ARE.
SURVEYS THAT BUSINESSES CHOOSE
NOT TO INCORPORATE IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF THIS- TWO
STEP PROCESS. THAT'S A VERY
GOOD QUESTION AND I THINK I'LL
WOULD DEFER THAT TO MR DONE.
YES THANK YOU VERY BIG
CALIFORNIA LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
WHICH IS THE- SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. AND ANY ENTITY THAT I
SERVE AS VICE CHAIR OF
LEGISLATION IS COMPRISED OF
CALIFORNIA AND CORPORATE.
TENSIONERS AND IT THE- THE
SOURCE OF THE BILL IS BASED
UPON OUR CUMULATIVE EXPERIENCE
WORKING WITH. ENTREPRENEURS IN
CALIFORNIA IN ADVISING THEM AS
WELL AS INVESTORS AND OTHER
PARTICIPANTS IN THE MARKET WITH
RESPECT TO STARTING
CORPORATIONS AND OTHER BUSINESS
ENTITIES IN CALIFORNIA AND
ELSEWHERE. AND THIS ISSUE COMES
UP- ALL THE TIME WHEN
ENTREPRENEURS ARE IN. BECAUSE
IN THE START A NEW BUSINESS
THEY WILL ASK THEIR ADVISERS
THEIR LEGAL ADVISORS WHERE THEY
OUGHT TO INCORPORATE. AND THE
AND THAT THE LEGAL ADVISERS
HAVE TO GIVE THEM PROS AND CONS
OF STARTING IN CALIFORNIA OR
STARTING IN ANOTHER
JURISDICTION. AS SENATOR JONES-
MANSION INCORPORATING IN
ANOTHER JURISDICTION DOESN'T
MEAN THAT THAT THAT THE
BUSINESS IS LOCATED IN THAT IN
THAT OTHER JURISDICTION IT JUST
MEANS THAT THE CORPORATIONS.
I'M LEGAL STRUCTURE IS BASED ON
THE LAWS OF THAT OTHER
JURISDICTION. AND WIN IT
PRACTITIONERS ADVISING US OR I
COULD GO AHEAD WITH THERE WAS
ACTUALLY A DIRECT QUESTION
THERE AND YOU'RE NOT ACTUALLY
ANSWERING THE QUESTION THE
QUESTION WAS WHETHER OR NOT
THERE WERE STUDIES OR DATA.
THAT THAT SHOW THE PROBLEMS SO
OPEN LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT
STATE STICKING TO THE ANSWER TO
THE QUESTION PLEASE. YES I'M
SORRY I WAS ATTEMPTING TO THE
STATE THAT THE- THAT THERE
THERE AREN'T ANY STUDIES. THAT
ARE THE FOUNDATION OF THIS BILL
IT'S RATHER THEIR CUMULATIVE
EXPERIENCE OF THE PRACTITIONERS
IN. THE CALIFORNIA LAWYERS.
ASSOCIATION OKAY THANK YOU. AND
I THOUGHT THAT THAT WAS THE
CASE BUT I DID WANT TO GET
ANSWERED ON OPPORTUNITY THERE
WAS A SHARE TICKER STUDY THAT
YOU CAN I THINK I AM SORRY I
CAN'T FIND IT RIGHT NOW I READ
THAT THAT CALIFORNIA'S
PREFERABLE BECAUSE IT IS
CHEAPER THAN A NUMBER OF.
STATES TO FORM CORPORATION
AIRCRAFT THAT IS YES SO YOU
KNOW I JUST HAVE TO SAY. AND I
UNDERSTAND ON. IT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT IF A CALIFORNIA
CORPORATION SOMEHOW STREAMLINED
TO WANT TO BECOME A DELAWARE
CORPORATION THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY LEAVING EVERYTHING IS
RIGHT I JUST CAN'T I CAN'T
BRING MYSELF. CREATING AN
AVENUE BY WHICH WE ALREADY HAVE
LOWER FEES TO INCORPORATE HERE
TO THEN- STREAMLINED TO MOVE.
THE CORPORATION HEADQUARTERS TO
ANOTHER STATE WHICH BECOMES A
TALKING POINT QUITE FRANKLY-
AGAINST A LOT OF STUFF THAT
HAPPENS CALIFORNIANS SO
ALTHOUGH WE'RE GOING INTO
DETAIL HERE I FEEL MUCH MORE
COMFORTABLE IF THERE WAS. ONE
AVAILABLE DATA- THAT SAID YOU
KNOW THIS MANY CORPORATIONS
DON'T INCORPORATE CALIFORNIA IT
SOUNDS TO ME LIKE WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO GIVE ANOTHER GIFT TO
CORPORATIONS TO LEAVE THE STATE
SO I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS I'M
SORRY ONE ONE RESPONSE TO THAT
IN IN THAT CERTAINLY AND-
LEGITIMATE CONCERN ONE OF THE-
SO THE IMPETUS OF THE BILL IS.
PARTLY WHAT MR DONE ALREADY
SHARED AND THEN SECONDLY TO
THAT AND I THINK JUST AS AS
IMPORTANT MAYBE- YOU KNOW MORE
REASON HOW THE BILLS WE ARE THE
PROCESS THAT WE'RE SETTING UP
FOR CORPORATIONS TODAY WITH
THIS BILL. WE ALREADY DO FOR
PARTNERSHIPS AND LIMITED
LIABILITY CORPORATION SO JUST
KINDA- CLARIFYING THINGS SO IT.
MAKES SENSE ACROSS THE BOARD
FOR ALL TYPES OF. CORORATE
STRUCTURES I APPRECIATE THAT
AND PERHAPS IF I HADN'T BEEN AN
UNDATED WITH- INUNDATED WITH-
TALKING POINTS- OVER THE LAST
EIGHT YEARS THAT WE'VE SERVED
TOGETHER OFF AND ON ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING TO CALIFORNIA
CORPORATIONS I MIGHT BE MORE
OPEN TO SUGGESTING STREAMLINING
THE MOVING OUT OF CALIFORNIA
BUT I DON'T THINK I'M READY TO
DO THAT TODAY OKAY PERSONALLY.
THANK YOU THIS MAIENSCHEIN YEAH
COUPLE COMMENTS- AND A QUESTION.
FIRST UP TO SOME EXOTIC THIS IT
APPEARS AT LEAST TO BE KIND OF
A- SOLUTION LOOKING FOR A
PROBLEM. THERE'S NO- STUDIES
THAT SHOW THAT THIS IS AN ISSUE
INTERESTINGLY THE ONLY. SUPPORT
I SEE FOR THIS IS- A DIVISION
OF THE CALIFORNIA LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION THERE'S NO BUSINESS
GROUPS WHO WERE- SAYING THIS IS
AN ISSUE I CERTAINLY HAVE BEEN
CONSULTED BY ANY. BUSINESSES
WHO. I SAID THIS IS A PROBLEM
OR THEY WON'T INCORPORATING
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE UNDER. A
CERTAIN OPERATING STATUS THEY
COULDN'T SOMETIME IN THE FUTURE
SWITCH- I AM SURPRISED THAT
THIS IS EVEN PROCEEDED TO THIS
POINT WITHOUT ANY SORT OF.
REALLY FACTUAL BASIS TO SUPPORT
IT- AND ALSO TO I. AGREE WITH
MY COLLEAGUE SAID- YOU KNOW. IT
IT'S A- HARD POSITION IN MY
OPINION TO BE TRYING TO MAKE IT
SIMPLER FOR A CORPORATION TO
LEAVE CALIFORNIA- IN ADDITION
WHAT IS THE FEE. THAT THEY
WOULD BE SAVING. WELL I THINK
THAT DEPENDS ON IF THERE'S A
SPECIFIC NUMBER THAT I YES TO
ME BASED ON HOW HOW LONG THE
TOURNEY TAKES TO DO THE
PAPERWORK TO WHATEVER OTHER
JURISDICTION THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE MISTER DUNN HAS A
PARTICULAR ANSWER FOR THAT I'LL
ACTUALLY AND ASK WHAT'S WHAT
HOW MUCH IS THE- COST. OF THE
FORM. HELLO MR DONE. T. SHIRT
THAT. YOU'RE SO YOU'RE NOT YOU
DON'T. RIGHT I DON'T KNOW IT IS
N. AS IN IS IT SPEAKING TO THE
CONCERNS ABOUT. YOU KNOW THE
SUPPORT FROM CORPORATIONS AND
SUCH YOU ARE CORRECT IT HAS
KIND OF MOVED THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATURE- FAIRLY
SIMPLY BECAUSE I THINK MOST-
WOULD AND I DON'T KNOW IF THIS
MAKES A DIFFERENCE OR NOT
CENTER MEN IS A IS A CO AUTHOR-
YOU KNOW SAW THE BENEFIT OF
THIS FOR THE CORPORATIONS. IN
HIS AREA- WHEN WE STARTED THE
BILL AS FAR AS SPECIFICALLY
ANSWER YOUR BILL IN THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT I'LL SEE IF- MISTER DUNN
HAS AN ANSWER FOR THAT MR
NINETY TO. GIVE AN ANSWER THE
QUESTION. JUST THE UP THE FEES
ONE LET. ME YEAH THE FILING FEE
IS NOMINAL M. I DON'T KNOW THE
NUMBER BUT TYPICALLY FIFTY
HUNDRED DOLLARS BUT THAT'S NOT
WHERE THE COST SAVINGS COMES
FROM THE COST SAVINGS RESULTS
FROM. THE CORPORATE.
INCORPORATING IN ANOTHER STATE
AND BEING SUBJECT TO THE
FRANCHISE TAX. PROVISIONS OF
THAT OTHER STATE THAT'S WHAT
MAKES INCORPORATING CALIFORNIA
LESS EXPENSIVE. OKAY SO EVEN
THOUGH IT. I DIDN'T GET AN
ANSWER ON THE COSTS THE FORM I
BELIEVE THE CASA FROM SOMEWHERE
AROUND A HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS
OKAY SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
HUNDRED. AND FIFTY DOLLAR
SAVINGS TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR A
COMPANY TECH COMPANY AT A
CERTAIN FORM OF INCORPORATE
COMPANY TO DO THIS I WOULD ALSO
AS AN ATTORNEY ACTUALLY DID IN
PREPARATIONS IT'S A IT'S REALLY
A ESPECIALLY FOR SOMEBODY WHO'S
DOING THEM ALL THE TIME IT'S A
VERY MINIMAL AMOUNT OF TIME FOR
A LAWYER WHO'S DOING THEM AT
CENTER IT'S A VERY SIMPLE.
PROCESS WHICH BY THE WAY HAS
GOTTEN SIMPLER OVER TIME IS NOW
YOU CAN DO IT ONLINE IT YOU
KNOW THERE'S A STANDARD FORM
THAT YOU THAT YOU USE SO THE
AMOUNT OF TIME FOR A LAWYER TO
DO THIS WOULD. YOU KNOW NOT
EVEN TOTAL AN HOUR EARLY. TO DO
THAT SO- I- I WILL SAY I WILL
BE. OPPOSING THE BILL TODAY. I
DON'T SUPPORT. I MADE IT LAYING
OUT THE RED CARPET FOR. CERTAIN
CORPORATE ENTITIES TO LEAVE THE
STATE I THINK I THINK WE NEED
TO BE DOING WHAT WE CAN TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE MAKING. AND IT
IT- ATTRACTIVE FOR- THESE THESE
BUSINESSES THE SAME CALIFORNIA-
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT JUST
ADD AN ANECDOTAL. NO STUDIES NO
FAX NO BUSINESS GROUPS EVEN IN
SUPPORT OF THE US- IT'S NOT
SOMETHING I CAN SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU THIS GALLAGHER. YEAH
MISTER CHAIRMAN I THINK THERE'S
A MISUNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT IT'S NOT ABOUT
CORPORATIONS LEAVING CALIFORNIA
THERE ARE MANY CORPORATIONS
THAT YOU WOULD THINK OF IS
CALIFORNIA BASED BUSINESSES WHO
ARE INCORPORATED IN ANOTHER
STATE. THIS IS ALL ABOUT
INCORPORATION NOT ABOUT WHERE
THE BUSINESS IS LOCATED WE
ALREADY DO THIS AND IT'S VERY
SIMPLE YOU WRITE IS A VERY
SIMPLE PROCESS AND WE MADE IT
VERY EASY FOR A PARTNERSHIP FOR
EXAMPLE TO CONVERT. TO A
FOREIGN PARTNERSHIP OR TO OR
FOR AN LLC TO CONVERT TO A
FOREIGN LLC THIS IS JUST SAYING
DO THE SAME THING FOR
CORPORATIONS- IT'S NOT ABOUT
LEADING GOING TO SOME OTHER
STATES ABOUT INCORPORATING- AND
IF WE'RE GOING TO USE AS THE
BASIS THAT WE NEED TO HAVE ALL
THIS DATA. TO SUPPORT A BILL
PASSING OUT MAN THERE'S A LOT
OF BILLS THAT SHOULD NEVER GET
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE- AND
SHOULD NEVER GET OFF OF THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR- FOR THAT MATTER
BUT OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE
PRACTITIONERS THE PEOPLE WHO
PRACTICE CORPORATE LAW- AND WHO
OF WHO ARE SO ACTIVE IN IT THAT
THEY'VE JOINED THE BUSINESS LAW
SECTION. AND GOT TOGETHER AND
SAID THIS THIS WAS AN ISSUE FOR
THEIR CLIENTS THAT SEEMS TO BE
PRETTY SUFFICIENT DATA FACTORS
COMMITTEE PASSES A LOT OF BILLS
THAT ARE BROUGHT TO US BY THE
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION- AND MANY
TIMES THERE ON CONSENT- BECAUSE
ARE THE PRACTITIONERS ARE
COMING TO US WITH THE PROBLEM
THAT THEY'RE SEEN- IN THE
PRACTICE OF LAW SO. I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THE BILL I THINK IT'S A
VERY YOU KNOW SIMPLE
COMMONSENSE CHANGE THAT WE
ALREADY DO FOR OTHER BUSINESSES
IN THE STATE- DOESN'T ENCOURAGE
THEM TO GO SOMEWHERE ELSE IT'S
JUST ABOUT WHERE THEY'RE
LEGALLY INCORPORATED- AND SO I
WILL BE SUPPORT TODAY. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU. THE
QUESTIONS ARE. RIGHT SEEING
NONE OF YOUR BILL HAS A MOTION
BUT NOT A SECOND SO WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO TAKE A VOTE ON IT UNTIL
WE CAN- WE'LL SEE ONCE WE GET
THE FULL COMMITTEE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR PATIENT THAT NOW
LOOKS UP TO MR GALLAGHER'S
COMMENTS AS THE CLOTHES BECAUSE
HE DOING GREAT JOB THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU PHOTO IF
YOU THE CLOSE BUT- HE DID. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. SO WILL NOW
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SB
THREE TWENTY ONE SENATOR TO
ROSS. THANK YOU THERE'S A
MOTION IS THERE A SECOND AND WE
DO HAVE A SECONDS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THERE ARE
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOMESTIC
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA AND THEY
SERVE OVER TWO MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS- AND THEY THEY DID
WE DEPEND ON THEM TO CARE FOR
HOMES AND FAMILIES. IN THE
WILDFIRES THAT CONTINUE TO
DEVASTATE CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLD
DOMESTIC SERVICE WORKERS- AND
THEY LABOR IS ASKED TO STAY
BEHIND HELP WITH THE PROPERTIES
GUARD HOMES ARE PETS TO WORK IN
SMOKY CONDITIONS BUT WORSE
CLEAN UP. TOXIC ASH- THEY FACE
DANGERS NONE OF US SHOULD
TOLERATE THEIR ALREADY
CLASSIFIED AS EMPLOYEES BY%
STATUTE DID THEY CONTINUE TO
CARRY THE LEGACY OF BLACK WOMEN
SLAVES EXCLUSION FROM BASIC
STATE HEALTH AND SAFETY LAWS.
IN RESPONSE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
VETO PRIOR LEGISLATION. WE HAVE
AMENDED- OUR BILL TO CREATE AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT WILL
DEVELOP THE GUIDELINES
VOLUNTARY AND EDUCATIONAL
GUIDELINES FOR PROTECTING THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF DOMESTIC
SERVICE EMPLOYEES. AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHAT THE
DECISIONAL STEPS- WE AS A
LEGISLATURE OR THE DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS MIGHT
TAKE TO BETTER PROTECT THEM.
THIS MEASURE IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP. TOWARDS WHAT WE REALLY
NEED TO PROTECT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF HOUSEHOLD DOMESTIC
SERVICE EMPLOYEES- MY WITNESSES
BY PHONE TODAY OUR NORMAL ERICA
TORRES. AND- MOLINO MY ORTEGA.
THANK YOU BUT I DO HAVE THOSE.
WITNESSES LISTED ERICA TORRES
AND MILLION AMERICA I ALSO HAVE
IN A SHOP ON THE LINE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS SO WE'LL GO TO ERICA
TORRES. GOOD MORNING I'M
ACTUALLY GOING TO BEGIN MYSELF-
MY NAME IS MELINDA MY DAUGHTER
AND I AM DIRECTOR OF LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT AND CREDIT. YEAH HE
LEFT. I WOULD WAIVE BY DOMESTIC
WORKER. AND TODAY I WANT TO
INTRODUCE YOU TO PALLA AN
INDIGENOUS WOMAN FROM CENTRAL
AMERICA. THE LONG BRAIDS AND
SHINE AS- FOR CHILDREN AND
MIGRATED HERE OUT OF NEED. TO
CARE FOR MY CHILDREN MOST OF MY
CHILDHOOD. WELL BOTH OF OUR
PARENTS WERE. EVERY DAY SHE
COOK SHE CLEANS COULD NOT SHE
WALKED THE THREE OF US THE
SCHOOL. EVERY DAY SHE'S
SACRIFICING HER OWN CHILDREN.
OR FAMILY TO DO THE- BEST YOU
COULD FEED THEM SO THAT SHE
COULD CREATE HER OWN CHILDREN
EVERY DAY HER OWN CHILDREN
MISSED HER. ONE THOUSAND GREEN
SHE USED THE PRODUCT MY PARENTS
PROVIDED. THEY WERE HARSH TOXIC
CLEANING CHEMICALS AND I CAN
STILL SMELL THEM ON HER HAND.
SHE WAS EXPOSED TO THEM DAILY
AND SO WITH THAT I. WHEN I WAS
A YOUNG ADULT I LEARNED THAT
BALLOT HAD DEVELOPED STOMACH
CANCER. SHE RECEIVED ALL THE
MEDICAL CARE THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE YEAH IT WAS TOO LATE.
I DON'T. GO COLD I LIKE JAPAN
AND COLUMBELLIDAE FINALLY TO BE
WITH HER FAMILY IN HER LAST
DAYS. SHE SERVED AWAY BARELY
FOR. I'M HERE TODAY HONOR ABOUT
I NEED BECAUSE I DO NOT WANT
ANYBODY TO SUFFER AND DIE
UNNECESSARILY BECAUSE OF THEIR
WORKING CONDITIONS. I BELIEVE
THOUSAND DIED IN THE
CLASSIFICATION OF THE COSTA
DALY AND THAT MY PARENTS WOULD
HAVE MADE DIFFERENT CHOICES
HAPPY UNDERSTOOD BETTER. TAX
OPTION THE TECHNOLOGY COMPANY
SAFETY. ABOVE THAT OF THEIR
CHILDREN. I WISH MY PUT HELP
AND SAFETY GUIDELINES THE
COMPLAINERS. LONG FORGET. TODAY
IN CALIFORNIA HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS MAKE FOUND
ANY HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROTECTION AND EMPLOYERS NEED
GUIDANCE AND STANDARDS FOR HOW
TO DO THAT. SO I AM HERE TODAY
TO ASK YOU. DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
OUR LOVE LIFE MATTERED DO YOU
BELIEVE HER LIFE WITH WHAT I
THINK. SO PLEASE THE POOR THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY FOR. ACT SB
THREE TWO ONE. LIVE BEHIND ON
IT. AND NOW WE'LL HEAR FROM
ADDED THAT THOUGH OKAY A WORKER
LEADER FROM G. LAST. THANK YOU
WELL I MEAN I'M NOT WRITING ALL
RIGHT- BUT AGAIN MY MEMBER ID
THEN THAT SHE RAN THE BANK
CARE. ACT HAVE ON IF YOU HAVE
TIME YOU CAN GET LOOKED AFTER.
HELLO MY NAME IS AND NOT. GOT
THOSE I AM A- LEADER OF SHE I
NOT ANGELES I HAVE. MORE THAN
TEN. MEANING HOUSE. IF YOU KNOW
YOUR PEOPLE VIDEO GET THEM
RECORD BECOME ARE HANDLED TO BE
ON THE BACK PRESS LOVE MATH AT
THE WHEN THEY LOOK AT THANK YOU.
AND THEN ANY OTHER THANK. BOB I
CAN'T PREDICT THE OUTCOME OF
THE I'M NOT LITTLE MAN. PLEASE
BE ON THE LOOK AT BOOK.
IMPOSSIBLE RENDON LOOKING INTO
YOUR- I DON'T KNOW IF I'VE GOT.
EVERY MOTHER I MEET THAT LIKE
THAT. YOU HAVE BEEN YOU KNOW
NAKED HAVE BEEN THE FOCUS OF.
AND I'M GONNA LOOK. GOOD BUT
IDEA TO. IN. I AM HERE BECAUSE
OF THAT THERE NEXT I HAD
WORKING. HOW AND MONTH OF THE
FIVE IN THE FLATHEAD AREA. I
WAS THREE DAYS A WEEK AMONG I
MEAN HOUSING THAT HAD. DOWN
DURING THE- INTO THE PLANT.
IDEA IN ONE OF THE HEALTHIEST
TO HAVE HAD. DOWN AND LADY
WANTED A DIRECT YOU THE THING
THAT WERE STILL IN. YEAH I'M
GONNA NUMBER OF YOUR Y. THEIR
MASCOT YEAH. NOT UP WILL BE
SOLD. ON SAMPLE ONE OF GOING TO
HAPPEN YOU'RE THAT THERE WERE.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABOUT
BETTER GOT THAT A LOT THE
COVERAGE UP AND WE IT. IN A
MONTH WHAT THIS ON THE BALLOT
AND WILL. THERE ARE MIDDLE
MANAGEMENT. WE ARE FORWARD TO
THEM UP I THE- THAT TIME I DID
IT AND NINETY NEAR YOU LET ME
GO. THAT LOOK TO POINT LATELY
TO YOUNG MEN LOCAL. AND
AMERICAN COMBINED. ON MY HEAD
THERE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE RETENTION OF MY EYES THAT.
AFFECTED ME THE MOST. WHEN THEY
WHEN THEY ARE NOT GOING NO THEY
WILL NOT IT'S NOT GONNA GIVE OR
TAKE A LOOK AT THE ROCK. YEAH
YEAH GIVE ALTHOUGH THEY KEEP
IRAQ FROM ONE FIFTY MCCARTY
YES. YEAH I'M LOOKING FOR THE
PERFECT YOUNG LITTLE ECONOMIC
AND ALSO THAT YOU HAVE ALSO
FINISHED. UP A LITTLE. ALL
WOULD BE THAT I'M K. YOUR HAVE
YET. THERE IS SOMETHING THAT IS
NOT. I'M NOT I LOVE THEM YOU
KNOW BUT I THE OPEN HERE
WELCOME. HAVE BEEN. I MEAN THE
MOBILE. THE MOST HOME. BUT I
DEAL WITH THEM THAT I'M MAKING
IT YOU'VE EVER LOOK. I REMEMBER
DAY THE ONLY OF ONE THESE HOW
GEN TO CHECK ALL AND SHE
ARRIVED POLITICALLY WITH GLOVES
AND A MARK BUT SHE THOUGHT YOU
WERE WITHOUT FACT AND NEVER
SAID ANYTHING TO US OR ABOUT
OUR HEALTH STATE. EVEN THOUGH
KNEW WHAT I WAS TRUTH MY I
DIDN'T HAVE ANOTHER BE MY WHOLE
HAD LOTS HIS JOB AND WE HAD
LOST OUR APART WE HAD LOST
EVERYTHING I FELT SO DESPERATE
I HAVE A GUN WORK. WELL THE
PROBLEM AND THEN IF I OF THINK
IT THAT THE YOU'LL- AND
ACTIVISTS YOU KNOW AT THEM. ON
IT. CREEK WILL NOT AT ME WHILE
IN MY. BOB ROCKWELL IT SB THAT.
LOCAL MARK. MOLTO MANAL.
BUILDING THEM ARE. ARE LOADED.
IN THE LAKE I WOULD THINK THAT.
LET ME LOOK AT THAT WILL BE
LEFT. IT ALMOST PERFECT THEIR
OWN AND OFF THE- STAFF. THREE
WE HAVE TO PASS A THREE TWO SO
THIS AND I EMPLOYEE TO REACH
AND VALUE OUR WORK AND OUR- WEARE NOW MUCH WE ARE KEEN RIGHTS
WHO LIKE ALL OTHER. ALSO THE
AND GET INJURED AND MEET JUNE
EIGHTH. THAT WERE THANK YOU.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO OTHER SUPPORT
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO OFFER SUPPORT FOR
SB THREE TWENTY ONE COVER THE
MICROPHONE PLEASE WE WILL NOT
TAKE FURTHER TESTIMONY BUT WE
WILL TAKE NAME AFFILIATION AND
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS THE ROUGH
SCHOOL CRAYON YOUNG ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FOURTEEN DELEGATE AND
FORMER VALLEJO SCHOOL BOARD.
MEMBER IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYONE
pELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM SEEING
NONE ANYONE IN THE ROOM TO
SMOKE STATION. SEEING THAT
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES PLEASE FOR THOSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR SB THREE TWENTY ONE AND
AGAIN WE'RE TAKING. AN
AFFILIATION AT SUPPORT ONLY NO
FURTHER TESTIMONY. THANK YOU IF
YOU IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
TWENTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT OF SB.
THREE TWENTY ONE. AND WE WILL
GO TO THE FIRST LINE OF NINETY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTH
MARICO YOSHIHARA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION A PREP COOK AUTHOR
OF THE FELT STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF THE
THREE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO EXPLORE. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE OF TWO FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BY TWO FIFTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WE IS NEW WORK
STILL. WHO SHOULD TO BE NORMAL.
ALL YOU DO WHICH WELL ARMENIAN
SHOWN SHOULD TOWARD WHAT IS
BEING WEIRD HE WILL. THANK YOU
ANEXO LINED UP TO TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS MEGAN WHEN I MET WTH THE
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC WORKERS
COALITION AND I LIVE IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND JOHN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE TWO ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE UP TO NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SHE TOOK MY NAME
IS ANA MARTINEZ I AM A DOMESTIC
WORKERS. AND I LIVE IN LOS
ANGELES. EMBED OFF G. LAST IN
NINE SUPPORT SB THREE TWENTY
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE A ONE NINETY
SIX YOUR LINES OPEN. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN BIRTH
JESSICA CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES A PROUD
SPONSOR IN SUPPORT AS WELL AS
THE STRONGER CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES NETWORK IN CHOCOLATE.
THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE OF
THREE TWENTY SIX THEIR LINES
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS JUSTIN ROWS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER ALSO A
CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF ONE NINETY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TINA SHOP
THE HIGHER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DOMESTIC WORKERS COALITION I
LIVE IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND
I'M JOHN SUPPORT SB. THREE TWO
ONE. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF THREE FORTY SIXTY LINES
OPEN. NINE THREE FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DO YOU HAVE A
SUMMIT. ONE OF THE AVAILABLE
ELEMENT THAT THE ANIMALS
VULNERABLE IF THE WEATHER WILL
CRITICS OF MONKEYS PUBLICIST
BRITNEY UP ALL YOUR LIFE
SERVICE IT IS BEING YOU KNOW.
THANK YOU AND NEXT TO GO TO
LINE UP TO THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINES OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
BADLY ABOUT THE SOUND WITH THE
NON ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY CENTER
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT SB
THREE TWO ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CONNECT ABOUT THE LINE OF A
THREE OH SIX AIRLINES OPEN.
NINE THREE OH SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN DO YOU HAVE A TIME YOU.
THE NEXT TO GO TO A LINE OF S.
THREE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SONNY MILANO NATIVE IN ONTARIO
CALIFORNIA I'M A PROUD MEMBER
OF CLEAR ONLY NEW SUPPORTER SB
THREE TO ONE. IT'S A PART SB
THREE TO ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND NEXT TO GO TO A LINE OF
THREE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS. MARTHA PANEL.
QUICKLY. FORTY ONE. YEAH LOOK
BETTER FOR ME TO TALK THAT YOU
YEP ARE YOU ALLOWED. TO SENATE
BILL. BAD THANK YOU AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE UP THREE FIFTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LINDSAY
EMI HONG I'M THE CALIFORNIA
DIRECTOR FOR HAND IN HAND THE
DOMESTIC EMPLOYERS NETWORK. AND
I AM A FORMER NANNY EMPLOYER IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
TWO ONE. THANK YOU AND NEXT TO
GO TO A LINE OF TWO THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BUT THAT
IF I LEFT THAT A. M. I BELIEVE
PALM CALIFORNIA I AM THE WITH
THE WORK AT THE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING. FOURTEEN AM SUPPORT
THAT IS. BEING MADE TO ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
ACCESSIBLE TO LINE OF THREE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINES OPEN.
THREE FORTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARIA
ELENA ZAMBON AND EMAIL I'M A
MEMBER OF TEAM AND THEN BONTA
BLOOD SB THREE TO ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO GO TO
THE LINE OF THREE FIFTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS VANESSA AND LEAD ORGANIZER
WITH THE CALIFORNIANS AND I
THINK WORKERS MISSION THEY'VE
BEEN LOS ANGELES AND I SUPPORT
SB THREE TWO ONE. THANK YOU
MEXICO SO LINE OF THREE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINES OPEN. THE
AFTERNOON HERE MEMBER PRISCILLA
Q. .COM WE HAVE THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE UP TO EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOMOKO COULD
NOT. THE NUMBER THANK YOU I
SUPPOSE SB ASK ME. TO ONE.
THANK YOU ANEXO THE LINE OF
THREE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINES OPEN.
I THINK THAT THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE NO. THREE FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOU CAN DISREGARD
THAT YOU KNOW. RIGHT. I WILL GO
TO THE LINE OF A THREE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS SHELLY. I'M NOT A
DOMESTIC EMPLOYER OF THE CAN'T
CANTON BURKE I'M CALLING ON THE
PART EACH REGION. THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE OF THREE FIFTY
YEAR OPEN. HI MY NAME'S TOOK
ELEVEN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I'M A
HOUSE CLEANER AND A STRONG
SUPPORT SB TOO ONE THANK. THANK
YOU ANEXO BUT LINE OF THREE
SIXTY YELLOW SO. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS LIBBY BENEDICT I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
WOMEN'S FOUNDATION CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB. THREE
TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU THE NEXT
TO GO TO THE LINE OF THREE
SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME MODEL
ONE ONE AND I'M NOT GONNA GIVE
TRUMP. AND I FLEW FOR
COMPLICITY SINCE. ONE FIFTEEN.
THANK YOU. NEXO SO LINE OF
THREE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NINE THIRTY BUT AGAIN
NOW I'M MY WIFE TONIGHT OR
DOMESTIC EMPLOYERS WE HAVE A
HOUSE CLEANER FOR THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS AND WE VERY MUCH
SUPPORT SB THREE TWENTY ONE.
THANK YOU ANNEX ABOUT THE LINE
OF THREE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WHEN OR THE ACT AND THE
COURTS. WE'RE NOT. YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WHAT THE ACTIVITY AND
ALL. YOUR AVAILABLE MEDICAL
WHAT THEY NEED WORKING AS A
THAT WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO UP OR
US OUT ALREADY IT WOULD BE AT
WELL YES MEAN WHAT COULD NOT
ANYMORE JACKSON SO THAT FOR
YEAH YEAH GUYS ARE IT'S ALWAYS
AT BAT LOOK BEFORE AND THAT I
NEED IT THANK THEY DEAL NOT
BACK AT THE DOM. SO I HAD NOT
BEEN SOLVED. OR NOT A WHOLE LOT
OF PLEASE MOVE ON THANK. THANK
YOU MEXICO CAROLINA THREE EIGHT
ALLY IS OPEN. HI THANK YOU MY
IS CHRIS LUBIN I MIX TO OF A
MONTH AND THEY GRADING LABOR
AND NINE INTO. TO AVOID MY VERY
STRONG- ARGUMENTS THE AT THREE
TWO ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FOR
THIS IMPORTANT YOU AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THEN
THE THROWS. SENATOR THERE ARE
AMENDMENTS IN THE- ANALYSIS YOU
ARE TAKING THOSE OF EVENTS OF
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY YES I HAVE
YES THANK YOU. OKAY THEN WE
WILL MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION I
HAVE NO OPPOSITION LISTED IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF. SB THREE TWENTY
ONE. SEE IS THERE ANYBODY
THROUGH TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING
THE OPERATOR COULD YOU MEET
THAT LINE PLEASE. AND THEN
OPERATOR WHICH YOU APPLIED FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
TWENTY ONE. YES IT HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE TWENTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE NINE
ZERO IN OPPOSITION OF SB. THREE
TWENTY ONE. AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THAT
TIME AT THIS TIME. RIGHT THANK
YOU WILL BRING YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THE DALLAS- I WANT TO
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR BRING THIS
PUMP HOW TO BE A JOINT AUTHOR
I'M DEVASTATED AT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT I KNOW THEY-
YOU. CAN'T POSSIBLY WANTED TO
TAKE BUT I DO UNDERSTAND THE
POSITION WHEN I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE AND- THIS IS TRULY A
VESTIGE OF SLAVERY IN OUR
COUNTRY THE FACT THAT WE TREAT
DOMESTIC WORK AND FIELD WORK.
DIFFERENT THAN ALL OTHER WORK.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S
UNCOMFORTABLE AND TOUGH. I
SUPPOSE FOR SOME PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND WHY BASIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY LAWS LABOR LAWS SHOULD
APPLY TO PEOPLE WHO ARE IN OUR
OWN HOUSEHOLD BUT UNTIL WE- GET
TO THAT POINT WE'RE ACCEPTING
IN- A WHOLE HISTORY. OF PEOPLE
OF COLOR SURVEEN- THOSE WHO ARE
THE DOMINANT CLASS WITH SUB
STANDARD- RIGHTS IF ANY RIGHTS
SO THANK YOU FOR BRING IN
SUPPORT OF I'M SORRY- IT'S NOT
THE FULL BILL I'M SURE YOUR
SORRY TO WE WILL CONTINUE THIS
FIGHT I JUST. YOU'RE SUCH A
CHAMPION AND HAVE BEEN SUCH
CHAMPION I KNOW- YOU KNOW CAN
IN HAND WITH YOU WHAT WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO DO BUT- I JUST
WANT TO TAKE KNOWLEDGE THAT
THIS IS- IT IS IN SOME PART
SHAMEFUL. THAT A BILL WITH NO
OP BUT NO FORMAL OPPOSITION-
CANNOT- WE CAN'T CONVINCE FOLKS
THAT THIS IS THE TIME. TO
REALLY REMOVE THE VESTIGES OF
SLAVERY THAT ALLOW. FOR US TO
MISS TREAT DOMESTIC WORK. THANK.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I WANT TO
SUPPORT THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
JUST MADE BY SUMMER GONZALEZ
AND THANK US HUNDRED ALSO OF
THREE CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO
WORKERS IN THIS CASE DOMESTIC
WORKERS I AGREE COMPLETELY- IS
LIKE A SECOND CLASS CITIZENSHIP
OF SORTS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
DIGNITY OF WORK- BUT
IMMEDIATELY SOMEHOW- THE
NUMBER. EVEN THOUGH THE AYE I
AM PRETTY CONFIDENT MANY OF
THOSE WHO OPPOSE PROBABLY TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE WORK OF THOSE
IN THEIR HOME AND YET- DON'T
SEE- THE HUMANITY AND THE
EQUITY- ISSUES THAT ARISE AND
WE DON'T PROVIDE THE SAME LEVEL
PROTECTIONS IN THE WORKPLACE
WHICH IS WHICH ARE THE HOMES
THAT THEY- GO INTO- AT GREAT
RISK AT TIMES AND SO I
APPRECIATE YOU AND. WILL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT SHOPPERS.
ALL RIGHT YOU. SERVICE I DO
WANT TO THANK YOU CENTER YOUR
YOUR OR- WITHOUT A DOUBT ONE OF
OUR CHAMPIONS WHEN IT COMES TO
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF
WORKERS ALONG WITH SOME OF THE
VERY MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
BUT YOUR- TIRELESS EFFORTS
REGARDING OUR DOMESTIC WORKERS
IS WITHOUT EQUAL. AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THOSE WHO PROVIDED
TESTIMONY. IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO
HEAR FROM THE VERY WORKERS WHO
ARE BEING ABUSED. AND I
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE- THE
COMMENTS FROM THOSE WHO WHO
HIRE DOMESTIC WORKERS. AND
RECOGNIZE THAT. THEY NEED TO BE
TREATED IN A BETTER WAY AND
THAT IS HOW THEY TREAT THEM
THEY TREAT THEM IN A BETTER
WAY. AND THAT SHOULD BE THE
STANDARD SO I APPRECIATE THEM
AS WELL BUT- AT TO YOU AND I
AGREE WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
GONZALEZ REGARDING THE
AMENDMENTS- BUT THE THIS IS A
ONE STEP AND I. APPRECIATE ALL
THE EFFORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS ARE COMMON.
CNN SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS OF
SUPPORT THOSE WHO CALLED IN
ESPECIALLY THE- EMPLOYERS FOR-
HAND IN HAND AS THEY SAY- WITH
THE DOMESTIC WORKERS AND I
PLEDGE TO YOU THAT WE ARE GOING
TO KEEP THIS GOING UNTIL THEY
ARE TREATED JUST LIKE EVERY
OTHER WORKING PERSON- IN THE
STATE- KILL THE SEEDS I LISTA
HOBBLED AS THE YSTIC BECAUSE
THEY GET IS THIS A LITTLE
IMPOSSIBLE ALMOST AS A YEAR OF
A LAND DAY. E. NOT IN THOSE UP
BUT I'VE BEEN TO A SCHOOL BUS
SO GOOD ON THE- THANK YOU TO-
TO EVERYONE WHO CALLED IN AND
SPOKE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR WE DO HAVE A
MOTION ND A SECOND THAT MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA PLEASE.
STONE ALL RIGHT STONE I
GALLAGHER. CHAO CHAO I CHIU.
DAVIES GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN HOLDEN I KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN YES I
HAVE RESIGNED. THE BILLS OUT
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THANK YOU RIGHT WE ARE IN OF.
BIT OF A QUANDARY AT THIS POINT
WE LOSE THIS ROOM AT ONE
O'CLOCK AND I'M NOT SURE YET IF
WE HAVE ANOTHER ROOM. SO THE-
BUT WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS TO
TAKE UP SINCE IT WAS PULLED OFF
OF CONSENT ITEM NINETEEN ACR
NINETY FIVE WHICH IS DEFINITELY
TAKING IT OUT OF ORDER. THAT
SHOULD NOT TAKE VERY LONG AND
THEN I'D LIKE TO SEE IF WE CAN
GET MISTER BRADFORD IN. BECAUSE
SB TWO IS SOMETHING WE
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO DO TODAY SO
I APOLOGIZE THE SENATORS WHO
HAVE BEEN WAITING. ADD IF WE
CAN GET A ROOM WE WILL THEN
CONTINUE THE REST OF THE
AFTERNOON BUT SB TWO WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE GET ACCOMPLISHED
WILL DO AS MUCH AS WE CAN TODAY
WE'RE GONNA LOSE THIS ROOM IN
ABOUT THIRTY FIVE MINUTES SO
COULD WE CONTACT MISTER
BRADFORD YEAH I KNOW HE'S
CHAIRING PUBLIC SAFETY IN THE
SENATE AND GET HIM HERE SO THAT
WE CAN MAKE SURE WE GET THIS
BILL AND WE WILL DISPENSE WITH
IT ACTUALLY LIKE TO THAT ALSO
TAKE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA TO MAKE SURE WE GET THAT
DONE TODAY. THERE ARE TWO.
THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE A MOTION
THAT HAD THE SECOND THERE ARE
TWO ITEMS ON IT SO CALL THE
ROLL OF CONSENT. STONE HI STONE
HI GALLAGHER SHALL I SHALL I
CHIU DAVIES GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE KALRA SHARKS
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
REYES RAZAK'S RIGHT THOSE ARE
OUT THAT IS SB SEVENTY SIX
NIELSEN AND S. B. TWO OH SIX
MCGUIRE BOTH ON CONSENT TO
APPROPRIATIONS MISTER
CUNNINGHAM THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT ACR NINETY FIVE WHICH
IS A BIPARTISAN RESOLUTION
ASKING THE CALIFORNIA LAW
REVIEW COMMISSION TO STUDY THE
CART RIGHT ACT WHICH IS
CALIFORNIA'S PRIMARY INTEREST
STATUTES. THAT ACT WAS PASSED
IN NINETEEN OH SEVEN HAS
WRITTEN A PROHIBITS TWO OR MORE
ENTITIES FROM COLLUDING TO
RESTRAIN TRADE OR FIX PRICES
BUT IT DOES NOT ADDRESS
SITUATIONS WHERE THERE'S NO
PRICE CHARGE FOR A PRODUCT OR
SERVICE NOR IS IT PROHIBITS
MONOPOLIZING CONDUCT- WHICH IS
NOT A SURPRISE THE CORPORATE
ACT WAS WRITTEN MANY MANY
DECADES BEFORE COMPUTER
NETWORKS EXISTED AND LITERALLY
A CENTURY BEFORE ANYBODY WAS
ABLE TO DEVELOP A MARKET IN
WHICH DIGITAL CONSUMERS
THEMSELVES ARE THE PRODUCT BY
MONETIZING DATA THAT IS DERIVED
FROM THEIR USE OF US A SENSIBLY
FREE. SERVICES IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT WE'RE NOT
PROPOSING ANY SPECIFIC POLICY
CHANGES OR FIXES TODAY WE'RE
ASKING THE EXPERTS AT THE LAW
REVIEW COMMISSION TO STUDY THE
CAR RIGHT ACT AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN AND PROVIDE SOME INPUT
ON WHETHER AND HOW IT SHOULD BE
UPDATED OR MODERNIZED. AND THEN
WE CAN TAKE FURTHER ACTION.
INFORMED BY THAT INFORMATION I
THINK CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE A
LEADER IN THIS CONVERSATION
SPACES TAKING PLACE. IN OUR
NATION'S CAPITAL AND STATE
HOUSES ALL OVER THE COUNTRY AND
THAT WE SHOULD FURTHER BE
THOUGHTFUL AND DELIBERATE. AND
I BELIEVE UTILIZING THE LAW
REVIEW COMMISSION- TO INFORM US
AND I SHOULD ALSO NOTE. THERE
IS AN OPPOSITION WATER YOU MAY
HAVE SEEN OR HAD A CHANCE TO
REVIEW- THE CALIFORNIA LAW OR-
LAW REVIEW COMMISSION'S PROCESS
IS AN OPEN PROCESS THAT CAN
TAKE INPUT FROM THE PUBLIC.
THEY CAN TAKE INPUT FROM
STAKEHOLDERS. THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE PROCESS SO THERE WILL BE
PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE
THAT WOULD LIKE THE CARD READ
ACT TO REMAIN AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN AND NOT BE CHANGED.
POSSIBLY AT ALL TO PROVIDE THAT
INPUT AND LAY OUT THE REASONS
DURING THE LAW REVIEW
COMMISSION'S STUDY PERIOD IN
PROCESS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S TIME TODAY. THANK
YOU NOT YET. THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU IS THERE SECONDS.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AND THERE
ARE SOME AMENDMENTS LISTED IN
THE- WE DO ACCEPT THE AMENITIES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT I DO NOT HAVE ANY
WITNESSES LISTED IN SUPPORT SO
WE'LL JUST GO TO THE TWO AND IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF ACR NINETY
FIVE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
SENAD REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR AT FOUR ACR NINETY FIVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
ACR NINETY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT THE END OF THE ROLE.
AGAIN THAT THE ONE THAT LENDS
ZERO IN SUPPORT OF AB. THE R.
NINETY FIVE. AND ONE MOMENT WE
HAVE ONE IN Q. DECEPTICON THAT
LINE NUMBER REAL QUICK. AND
AGAIN WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF ACR.
NINETY FIVE- WE WILL GO TO A
LINE OF THIRTY FOUR. LINE
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ARMS THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
AGAIN THAT'S ONE EIGHT ZERO
ZERO IN SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORTING QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU SO WILL
NOW MOVE THAT THE OPPOSITION
ZERO ONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF ACR NINETY FIVE.
SEEING NONE THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR OPPOSITION TO ACR
NINETY FIVE. EUROPEAN
OPPOSITION OF ACR NINETY FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF ACR.
NINETY FIVE. AND WE DO HAVE ONE
IN Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND WE
ARE WE ARE ON ACR NINETY FIVE
IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT THE END ZERO. AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO LINE IT YOU
EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK YOU EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINES OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS CAME
IN TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY I'M SURE IS IT OKAY
IF I GIVE A FEW COMMENTS ARE
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO JUST GIVE
ME TOO. NOT JUST TO ME TO
PLEASE. GENERATION AFTER
TACKLING. IN RESPECT OF
PETITIONS ACR NINETY FIVE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION IN CUBA THIS
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU THAT I
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
C. NINE WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND THAT MOTION IS THAT
THE RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED AS-
AS AMENDED AND SENT TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. STONE AYE STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. CHAO CHAO HI CHIU
DAVIES GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN HOLDEN I KALRA. KALRA
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES YES I.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED THANK
YOU MISTER BROTHERS COMMITTEE
OKAY IF HOPEFULLY WE CAN DO SB
TWO I AM TOLD WE DO HAVE THIS
ROOM UNTIL ONE THIRTY SO WE'LL
DO SB TWO AND THEN AS MUCH AS
WE CAN WE STILL SEEM TO BE
STRUGGLING GETTING A ROOM TO
CONTINUE SO IF NOT SB TWO IS
THE ONLY BILL THAT NEEDS TO BE
TAKEN UP TODAY BECAUSE IT IS
DOUBLE REFERRED TO US AND THEN
PUBLIC SAFETY. THE REST OF
BILLS WOULD BE PUT OVER TILL
NEXT WEEK AND I THINK WE HAVE
SCHEDULED NEXT WEEK HEARING THE
START EARLY ANYWAY SO WE MAY
HAVE ANOTHER LONG ONE NEXT WEEK
SO HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET SENATOR
BRADFORD HERE AND WE CAN THEN
TAKE UP. SPEAKING OF THE DEVIL.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD. WE
DEFINITELY WANT TO TAKE UP.
ITEM NUMBER. THIRTEEN SB TWO
SINCE THIS IS ONE BILL THAT
NEEDS TO BE- FROM COMMITTEE
TODAY SO SENATOR WELCOME THANK
YOU FOR. YOUR LOTUS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE
YOUR INDULGENCE HEARING THIS
IMPORTANT MATTER- STATED THIS
IS SB TWO TO. REMAKE OF WHAT WE
TRIED TO DO LAST YEAR- SB SEVEN
THREE ONE- THIS YEAR IT'S
BETTER KNOWN AS THE KENNETH
ROSS JUNOR POLICE TO
CERTIFICATION. BILL KENNETH
ROSS JUNIOR WAS A TWENTY FIVE
YEAR OLD YOUNG MAN WHO LIVED IN
MY NEIGHBORHOOD WHO WAS SHOT IN
THE BACK TWICE. BY A OFFICER
WHO HAD TRANSFERRED TO GARDENA
POLICE DEPARTMENT AFTER HAVING
THREE OTHER QUESTIONABLE SHOULD
THE SHOOTINGS AND ORANGE COUNTY
AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
WITH THIS MEASURE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE IN. THE WASH RINSE AND
REPEAT CYCLE OF SOME OF THESE
BAD OFFICERS- THAT WE KNOW ALL
EXIST. HERE IN CALIFORNIA
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY- THIS
MEASURE IS CO AUTHORED A MY
JOIN AUTHOR I'M- PROUD TO SAY
IS. PROTIUM TONI ATKINS AND-
IT'S A PRIORITY FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS. SO
AGAIN I APPRECIATE HEARING THIS
THING BILL THOSE. TWO VERY
SIMPLE THINGS THE GREAT TO
STATEWIDE PROCESS TO REVOKE THE
CERTIFICATION OF AN OFFICER.
AFTER THE CONVICTION OF A
SERIOUS CRIME OR TERMINATION
FROM EMPLOYMENT DUE TO
MISCONDUCT. WE'RE NOW ONE OF
ONLY FOUR STATES IT DOESN'T
HAVE A FAIR TRANSPARENT. AND
OPEN AND ON. A MATTER OF
GETTING RID OF BAD OFFICERS ARE
BY DECERTIFYING THEM AND- WE
LEAD IN THE ENVIRONMENT WE LEAD
IN THEIR KANEMI WE LEAD IN
TECHNOLOGY BUT- WE- TRAIL- MS.
BEHIND THESE OTHER FORTY SIX
STATES WHEN IT COMES TO REAL
PLEASED TO FOR OUR REFORM INDIE
CERTIFICATION. HE CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY NOW IS ABLE TO REVOKE
THE LICENSE OF A DOCTOR OF A
BAD DOCTOR ABOUT LAWYER. BAD
BARBER COSMETOLOGIST IT
SHOULDN'T BE EASIER TO REVOKE A
BEAUTICIAN'S LICENSE OR BARBERS
LICENSE FOR A BAD HAIR CUT BUT
UNABLE TO DECERTIFY A POLICE
OFFICER WHO IS BROKEN A LAW.
AND VIOLATED THE TRUST OF OUR
PUBLIC THIS BILL WOULD CREATE A
FAIR AND EFFECTIVE PROCESS TO
ENSURE THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WHO BREAK PUBLIC TRUST
ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
ACTIONS AND NOT ALLOWED TO
SIMPLY MOVE ON TO ANOTHER
DEPARTMENT WHICH WE ALL KNOW
THAT EXIST IN THE EXAMPLE THAT
I GAVE- WOOD MISTER ROSS IS ONE
OF THOSE EXAMPLES OF- A OFFICER
LEAVING ONE DEPARTMENT ONLY TO
COME TO ANOTHER ONE. AND REALLY
MOST OF THESE BAD OFFICERS ARE
QUESTIONABLE OFFICERS WIND UP
IN THE SMALLER COMMUNITIES
THESE. CITIES THAT CAN AFFORD
THE TRAINING AND- ACADEMY SO
THESE OFFICERS HAVE BEEN
TRAINED IN THESE COME FROM
THESE BIGGER METROPOLITAN AREAS
THE SMALL TOWNS WELCOME THEM
WITH OPEN ARMS DESPITE THEIR
CHECKERED PAST SO THIS WILL. IN
THAT. IT THIS BILL. ALL WELL
ALLOWS THE COMMISSION. ON PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING.
BETTER KNOWN AS A POST. AND A
COMMISSION THAT IS MADE UP
PRIMARILY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
INVESTIGATE THEIR GROUNDS FOR
OFFICERS MISCONDUCT. THIS AT
THE ALREADY IS IMPORTANT IN
ENSURING THAT WE ARE CREATING
AN EFFECTIVE DE CERTIFICATION
SYSTEM. IT WOULD ALSO CREATE AN
ADVISORY BOARD WITH IN POLLS
THAT WOULD MAKE INITIAL
RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHETHER POLL
SHOULD DECERTIFY AN OFFICER.
FINALLY THIS BILL ALLOWS THE
COMMISSION TO DEFINE BY
REGULATION THE SPECIFIC GROUNDS
OF SERIOUS CAUGHT MISCONDUCT.
THAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED FOR
DECERTIFICATION SEVERAL THESE
AGREE JUST BACKGROUNDS ARE LAID
OUT IN THIS BILL SUCH AS SEXUAL
ASSAULT DISHONESTY AND ABUSE OF
POWER AMONG OTHERS ALSO MADE
THE COMMISSION HAS THE
AUTHORITY. AND DEFINING WHAT
EXACTLY MISCONDUCT IS THAT CAN
LEAD TO DO CERTIFICATION OF
OFFICE. WE FEEL THIS IS A FAIR
APPROACH AND IT'S NOT RADICAL
BY ANY STRETCH OF IMAGINATION
AND IT'S CURRENTLY WHAT MANY
OTHER STATES AS I STATED ARE
DOING RIGHT NOW. AND THE MORE
RELEVANT TO THIS COMMITTEE THIS
BILL MAKES CHANGES TO
STRENGTHEN- THE THOMAS BAYNE
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT. IT ENSURES
THAT A FAMILY MEMBER OF A
PERSON KILLED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS ALSO ABLE TO
ASSERT BECAUSE OF ACTION UNDER
THE BAN ACT IT CLARIFIES THAT
THREE OF THE MOST EGREGIOUS
COMMUNITIES CALMLY ASSERTED BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT OR NOT OPTICAL.
TO CLAIMS BROUGHT UNDER THE
PLANE ACT. FOLLOWING THIS BILL
BEING HEARD AND SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WE HEARD
CONCERNS FROM MANY MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE REGARDING THIS
SECTION OF THE BILL. WE ARE
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THIS BILL
WOULD OPEN UP A FLOODGATE OF A
LIABILITIES. AND POSE A SERIOUS
FINANCIAL TOLL ON LOCAL.
GOVERNMENTS THIS IS WHAT MANY
MEMBERS FOUGHT WERE ABLE TO
pMEMBERS AND THE LEADERSHIP AND
OUR HOUSE TO LIMIT THE WRONGFUL
DEATH CLAIMS THAT CAN BE
BROUGHT UNDERTHE BANE ACT. TO
THE MOST SERIOUS OFFENSES THIS
AGREEMENT READ THAT A PERSON
WOULD ONLY BE ABLE TO BRING A
CAUSE OF ACTION IF THE CONDUCT.
ON WHICH THE CLAIM IS BASED
CONSTITUTES A CRIME OF VIOLENCE
OR CRIME OF MORAL TURPITUDE. WE
MADE A COMMITMENT TO MEMBERS OF
OUR HOUSE THAT ANY AMENDMENTS
MADE TO THIS PIECE OF THE BILL
WOULD BE SOLELY. TO CLARIFY THE
LANGUAGE WE DRAFTED BUT WE
WOULD NOT UNDO. THE INTENT OF
OUR AGREEMENTS. AS POINTED OUT
IN OUR ANALYSIS IS LANGUAGE IS
UNCLEAR IMPOSES MAJOR ISSUES AS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED. WE HAVE
SEVERAL CONVERT WE'VE HAD
SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS WITH
CHEERING COMMITTEE STAFF AND I
APPRECIATE THAT BUT WE WERE
UNABLE TO COME TO THE LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD MAKE THIS CLEAR
WHILE TO SAME TIME KEEPING OUR
COMMITMENT TO THE MEMBERS OF
OUR HOUSE I WANT TO THANK YOU
CHEERING THIS COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL WE
RECOGNIZE THAT. THERE'S MUCH
WORK TO BE DONE IN GOOD FAITH
AND I STAND HERE- WITH THE
DESIRE TO MAKE THIS BILLS AS
STRONG AS POSSIBLE AND- AND
IT'S FAIR AND TRANSPARENT AS
POSSIBLE ON IT APRIL
UNFORTUNATE I'M UNABLE. TO
TAKE- WELL WHEN I GO TO FIND
THAT SOLUTION AS WE STAND HERE
TODAY THAT BEING SAID I'M
MAKING A COMMITMENT TODAY TO
REMOVE THE SECTION RELATED TO
WRONGFUL DEATH CLAIMS. AS
AUTHOR MA'AM IT'S GOING TO
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY BUT I
REMAIN COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
COMING DAYS TO FIND A SOLUTION
ON THIS ISSUE WE ALL RECOGNIZE
THAT IT IS IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE LOST
LOVED ONES DUE TO POLICE
MISCONDUCT DESERVE A REMEDY. IN
ADDITION TO REMOVING THE
PROVISION ON WRONGFUL DEATH
CLAIMS WE WILL ALSO BE AMENDING
THE DECERTIFICATION PORTION OF
THE BILL FOLLOWING A LENGTHY
DISCUSSION WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION POST AND THE
RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS. WE FEEL
COMFORTABLE THAT THESE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS VARIOUS.
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES AND THESE
WILL BE MADE PUBLIC IN THE
COMING DAYS. AND WE'RE CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THE BILL WITH THIS
ADMINISTRATION THE COMMITTEE
STAFF INCLUDING AGAIN ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY'S ASSEMBLY PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND APPROPRIATIONS AND
ALL COMMITTED STAKEHOLDERS THIS
BILL IS A PRIORITY AGAIN AT FOR
THE LEGISLATIVE BLOCK
CONSTRUCT. A CAUCUS. SPONSORED
BY THE COMMUNITY GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATION PORTED BY
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS WERE
LOOKING FOR US TO PASS
MEANINGFUL. POLICE REFORM.
TESTIFIED TODAY AND SUPPORT
THIS MACHITO. MONTERROSA SISTER
SEAN MONTERROSA AND MEMBERS OF
CRIME SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE. CARL DOUGLAS. BOARD
MEMBER OF CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE ALSO WOULD
HAVE. JULIE JULIA ARE YOU
PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY PROJECT
UNVEILED ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. AND MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU IN CENTER JUST A NOTE
ON THE AMENDMENTS EVEN THOUGH
THE IT. THE ANALYSIS DOES LIST
AMENDMENTS WE'VE BEEN WORKING
PRETTY CLOSELY VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE CENTER'S OFFICE WHICH
WE APPRECIATE. WITH THE SENATE
PRO TEM'S OFFICE WE ARE NOT
ASKING FOR THOSE OF THEM IT'S
AT THIS TIME BUT I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT. TO
DEAL WITH THE WRONGFUL DEATH.
AS WE MOVE AS AS WE HAVE AGREED
SO. THAT PART OF THE ANALYSIS
WE ARE NOT JUST FOR MEMBERS WE
ARE NOT ASKING FOR THOSE OF
THEM IT'S AT THAT POINT AT THIS
POINT AND THAT IS FINE. WITH
WITH ME ALL RIGHT THANKS A WE
WILL MOVE TO. THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT CARL DOUGLAS AND
MICHELLE MONTERROSA. NOTING
THAT JULIA YOU IS AVAILABLE ON
THE TELEPHONE FOR. QUESTIONS
AND MICHELLE MONTERROSA YOU'RE
HERE IN PERSON WELCOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO TWO TWO
WHICH WOULD CREATE A MECHANISM
FOR DECERTIFYING OFFICERS WHO
ARE UNFIT TO WEAR A BADGE I'M
MICHELLE MONTERROSA THE
SURVIVING SISTER OF MY BROTHER
SEAN WITH THAT ASA WHAT OUR
FAMILY HAS BEEN PUT THROUGH BY
THE VALLEJO POLICE DEPARTMENT
WOULD BE MORE THAN THE TIME
THAT I HAVE HERE TODAY BUT I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE WAY IT
ILLUSTRATES THE NEED FOR SB
TWO. ON JUNE SECOND OF TWENTY
TWENTY SEAN WAS NEARLY WHAT IS
HANDS UP WHEN OFFICER GERAKAN
OF THE VALLEJO POLICE
DEPARTMENT SHOT THROUGH THE
WINDSHIELD BUT UNMARKED PICKUP
TRUCK. WITH AN A. R. FIFTEEN.
POLICE ARE THE ONLY LICENSED
PROFESSIONALS ARE CURRENTLY
CANNOT BE DECERTIFIED FOR
UNETHICAL AND HARMFUL ACTIONS.
VIRTUALLY EVERYONE ELSE FROM
BARBERS TO LAWYERS. WILL LOSE
THEIR LICENSE IF THEY VIOLATE
THE TRUST PLACED IN THEM BY THE
STATE. THIS IS ALSO A PERSONAL
ISSUE FOR ME. AS IT IS FOR MANY
OF THE FAMILIES WHO LOST A
LOVED ONE TO POLICE VIOLENCE.
YEAH CALIFORNIA IS ONLY ONE OF
FOUR STATES THAT HAS NO PROCESS
TO DECERTIFY COPS WHO ABUSE
THAT POWER. AND COMMIT SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT. THE OFFICER WHO
MURDERED SEAN. JERIT TIME HAS
BEEN INVOLVED IN FOUR OTHER
SHOOTINGS IN THE FOUGHT PAST
FIVE YEARS. BEFORE TRANSFERRING
TO THE VALLEJO POLICE
DEPARTMENT OFFICER TIME WORK
FOR THE GALT PD WHERE HE WAS
INVOLVED IN AT LEAST ONE
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTING THAT
WE KNOW WORK. IMMEDIATELY AFTER
SHAUN WAS SHOT. OFFICER TIME
CAN BE HEARD IN THE FOOTAGE
THANK I DIDN'T NEED THIS TODAY.
TO WHICH A SENIOR COMMANDING
OFFICER REPLIED IT'S OKAY WE'VE
BEEN THROUGH THIS BEFORE. AFTER
SHAWN'S DEATH THE PRESIDENT OF
THE VALLEJO POLICE UNION
ORDERED THE DESTRUCTION OF
EVIDENCE AND MY BROTHER'S CASE
BEFORE AN INVESTIGATION COULD
BE CONDUCTED. IT'S ALSO COME TO
LIGHT THE VALLEJO'S POLICE
DEPARTMENTS ONE OF THE MOST
VIOLENT IN THE COUNTRY. WE'VE
ALSO LEARNED THAT POLICE SYMBOL
AEL FENDER BADGES TO MARK HOW
MANY POT PEOPLE THEY'VE KILLED.
THIS IS IN NO WAY AN ISOLATED
CASE. THERE ARE MANY OTHER
FAMILIES NOT JUST THEM BUT
LEYVA BUT ACROSS ALL OF
CALIFORNIA WHO HAVE SIMILAR
STORIES. ABOUT THE WAYS THAT
THE POLICE HAVE SWEPT THE
DEATHS OF THEIR LOVED ONES
UNDER THE RUG. SIMPLY PUT THE
POLICE ARE NOT ABLE TO POLICE
THEMSELVES. SB TWO ALLOWS POST
TO CONDUCT INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATIONS WILL LOCAL
AGENCIES DESTROY OR SUPPRESS
EVIDENCE LIKE THE VALLEJO
POLICE DEPARTMENT DID IN MY
BROTHER'S CASE. WE ALL DESERVE
TO LIVE IN COMMUNITIES WHERE WE
FEEL SAFE AND PROTECTED. AND
OVER THE PAST YEAR IT'S MADE
MAKE IT'S BEEN MADE CLEAR THAT
NOT EVERYONE HAS THAT
PRIVILEGE. FURTHERMORE IT IS
LONG OVERDUE FOR CALIFORNIA TO
JOIN THE REST OF THE U. S. WITH
THE ABILITY TO REMOVE OFFICERS
WHO SHOULD HAVE NO LONGER BEEN.
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND REMOVE
THEM FROM OUR STREETS. I ASK
YOU RESPECTFULLY TO PLEASE VOTE
YES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
THEN CARL DOUGLAS WHO'S WITH US
ON THE TELEPHONE. THANK YOU SO
MUCHCHAIRMAN STONE AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
CARL DOUGLAS AND FOR FORTY TWO
YEARS I HAVE TOILED IN THE
STREETS AS A CIVIL RIGHTS
LAWYER. THIS BILL IS
PARTICULARLY MEANINGFUL FOR ME
CHAIRMEN STONE AND TELL YOU WHY.
BECAUSE MY OFFICE AT DOUGLAS
TAKE LAW REPRESENTS THE SEVEN
YEAR OLD SON OF KENNETH ROSS
JUNIOR. WE WERE FORCED TO FILE
OUR ACTION IN FEDERAL COURT.
BECAUSE BASED ON WHAT I THINK
IS A ROGUE INTERPRETATION OF
THE LAW. MISTER ROGERS SEVEN
YEAR OLD SON WAS PREVENTED FROM
SEEKING JUSTICE AND THE STATE
COURT OF CALIFORNIA. IT IS MY
HOPE THAT WITH CONTINUED
EFFORTS OF MY NEW HE WROTE
SENATOR BRADFORD. SB TWO WILL
CHANGE THAT. OKAY IN FORTY TWO
YEARS I'VE SEEN THE ABSENT AND
THE FLOWS OF THE LAW. IN MY
MIND IT MAKES NO LOGICAL OR
LEGAL SENT. THAT THE MAN THAT
SHOT MISTER ROSS. HE COULD- IF
MISTER ROSS HAD BEEN PARALYZED
WHEN HE WAS LAYING AND WRITHING
IN PAIN ON THE GROUNDS OF
RALEIGH PARK I'VE SEEN THE
VIDEO OF THAT SHOOTING. IT'S
IRONIC THAT WHILE MR ROSS COULD.
HAVE SUED WHERE HE PARALYZED
HIS SON. IS A PREVENTIVE STILL
BECAUSE POLICE OFFICER WAS A
SHE- AND KILLED HIM. I SEEN
DEVELOP IN COURTS OF TO ME. WE
HAD TO FILE IN A BROAD THE
THIRD CASE IN FEDERAL COURT. IT
IS COMPLICATED BY THIS PROCESS
CALLED QUALIFIED IMMUNITY. BOTH
QUALIFIED IMMUNITY IS A
COMPLICATED CONCEPT ABOUT
CLEARLY ESTABLISHED LAWS AND I
DARE SAY THOUGH I HAVE BEEN IN
THIS FIGHT FOR FORTY TWO YEARS
I AM I'M ABLE TO PROVIDE A
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
QUALIFIED IMMUNITY MEANS. THAT
IS A PROBLEM GIVEN WHAT I'VE
NOW LEARNING ARE THE
ADJUSTMENTS THAT ARE BEING
CONSIDERED NOW. GIVEN THE
WITHDRAWAL OF THE AMENDMENT FOR
THE NECESSARY CHANGES TO THE
BRAIN ACT I FEAR FOR MY CURRENT
CLIENT. I FEAR FOR MY FUTURE
CLIENTS AND I FEAR FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS BECAUSE THEY WILL
BE OUT BE WITHOUT THE POWER TO
SUE IN STATE COURT. TO CORRECT
AN INJUSTICE WHICH IMPACTS
THEIR LIVES FOR THE BETTER.
THAT'S NOT FAIR. THAT'S NOT THE
RIGHT. THAT'S NOT MY CALIFORNIA.
I APPLAUD SENATOR BRADFORD AND
I THANK HIM FOR HIS COURAGEOUS
EFFORT AT JUSTICE FOLKS I HAVE
KNOWN SENATOR BRADFORD BUT MORE
THAN THIRTY FIVE YEARS I
REMEMBER HE WAS SEEKING MY
PENNIES WHEN HE WAS RUNNING FOR
CITY COUNCIL IN GARDENA AND
NEVER HAVE I BEEN MORE PROUD
THAN CENTER BRADFORD THEN NOW.
FOR HIS COURAGEOUS EFFORTS ON
BEHALF OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
EFFORTS FOR JUSTICE I HOPE THIS
FIGHT IS NOT OVER. I HOPE TERM
AND STONE YOU ARE SINCERE WHEN
YOU SAY THAT YOU CONTINUE YOUR
TALKS WITH THE BANKING ACT. WE
HAVE MADE. SIGNIFICANT
ADJUSTMENTS FOR JUSTICE THOSE
TRUE PURVEYORS OF JUSTICE
SHOULD BE THE RIGHTEOUSNESS OF
OUR CAUSE. IT IS AN EASY VOTE I
SAY TO VOTE HI ON THE KENNETH
ROTH DECERTIFICATION BILL OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN ITS
CURRENT FORM. I LOOK FORWARD TO
STAND WITH PRIDE NEXT TO
SENATOR BRADFORD WHEN THE BANE
ACTIVE COMPONENTS ARE RETURNED.
I THANK YOU EVER SO MUCH FOR MY
TIME. THANK YOU IS THERE WILL
MOVE ON TO OTHERS IN SUPPORT IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM TO THE LEFT INDICATES
SUPPORT FOR SB TO. COME UP TO
THE MICROPHONE AND WE CANNOT
TAKE FURTHER TESTIMONY BUT WE
CAN TAKE NAME AFFILIATION AND
SUPPORT ACTUALLY MONTERROSA
ALSO THE SURVIVING SISTER
BROTHER SOME OF THE REST I WITH
JUSTICE LEAGUE CALIFORNIA
INSTRUCTS PART THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ROTH GOAL K.
YOUNG YOUNG SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF RICK PEREZ AND THE FAMILY.
LOST THEIR LOVED ONE PT CARESS
TO THE POLICE AS WELL AS-
FORMER RICHMOND COUNCILMEMBER
JOVANKA BECKLES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND SB
SIXTEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M ALEX SHOCKS I AM A-
ASKED VICE CHAIR FOR THE NAPA
COUNTY GANG AND YOUTH VIOLENCE
COMMISSION AND ALSO A FORMER
TRUSTEE ON THE SYLEENA A
UNIFIED SCHOOL- THE SCHOOL
BOARD TRUSTEES AND I'M JUST
HERE TO- I'VE EXPRESSED MY
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE. RIGHT
ANYONE OF THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR S. B. TWO
AND AGAIN WE'RE TAKING NAME
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT ONLY NO
FURTHER TESTIMONY. THANK YOU IF
YOU AREN'T SUPPORT OF S. B. Q.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE THEN
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TO. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE SLANG
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORTER SB TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO CAROLINA ONE
SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES AND
HEALTH ON BEHALF OF YEAH ARE
YOU CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
TO LINE OF THREE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MURS MITCH SNIDER WITH
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO EXPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF THREE
THIRTY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
LITIGATED ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION THE ALLIANCE
FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR
POLICY LIKE AN ANTI POLICE
TERROR PROJECT A CO SPONSORS IN
STRONG SUPPORT ALSO UNDERSTAND
THE TIME VERY LIMITED TO
RESPECTIVE ANYTIME WITH THE
CHARTS PERMISSION. I'D LIKE TO
READ OFF A LIST OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE ASKED
ME TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT IN
THIS COMMITTEE. GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU- PARTS OF THE CALIFORNIA
ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
CALIFORNIANS TO TAKE AND
JUSTICE. NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
VOICES FOR PROGRESS THE
CALIFORNIA INNOCENCE COALITION
PROSECUTORS WANT TO CALIFORNIA
DENMARK EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES
NORTHRIDGE INDIVISIBLE. FRESNO
BODY ALBANY DOES. LITTLE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
CALPERS PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION CONSUMER WATCHDOG
WE THE PEOPLE SAN DIEGO PILLARS
OF THE COMMUNITY SAN DIEGO. I
THINK THEY NINETY ASIAN HOLIDAY
ALREADY COLLECTED SHOWING UP
FOR RACIAL USTICE SAN DIEGO
SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL JUSTICE
NORTH COUNTY SAN DIEGO.
UPRIGHTS EITHER A SAN DIEGO Q.
T. P. O. C. COLLECTIVE OF.
MISSION IMPACT PLANTA P. DEL
SETTLED FOR BLM SOCIAL WORKERS
FOR EQUITY IN LEADERSHIP HELP
CRESSMAN A VISIBLE RISE OF SAN
DIEGO SAN DIEGO PROGRESSIVE
DEMOCRATIC CLUB. PARTNERSHIP
FOR THE ADVANCEMENT OF NEW
AMERICAN DEMOCRATIC CLUB THE
VISTA RACIAL JUSTICE COALITION
SAN DIEGO CHANGE BEGINS WITH ME
INDIVISIBLE DEMOCRATIC WOMAN'S
CLUB THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
ALAMEDA COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE THERE WAS
THAT THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER INITIATE JUSTICE.
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS COMMUNITY ADVOCATES FOR
JUST MORE GOVERNANCE. WITH THE
CHANGE ORANGE COUNTY EQUALITY
COALITION FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA DOESN'T
SEEM THAT WORK AND NATIONAL
LAWYERS GUILD AS A BAY. AREA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND I TOOK ALSO UP THIS NINE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS OF SCHOOL
WANTED ON BEHALF OF THE
RECORDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
OF AMERICA WE ARE ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NOTES ABOUT THE
LINE OF THREE NINETY NINE NO
LINES OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
JEANNIE MINOR ON BEHALF OF THE
GIPPER GLOCK BETTER TO PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE AS WELL AS SALES
FORCE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE OF
FOUR HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BILLY
CRYSTAL KID OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO SO LINE OF THREE
FORTY FOR YOUR LINES OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON OF COURSE YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN EVERYTOWN FOR
GUN SAFETY IN THE PARK. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE UP
FOR A ONE YEAR LINES OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MILLIE FIND WHAT YOU W. ASKED
ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY
INCH BOX SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE
OF THREE NINETY SIX FELINES
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JUSTIN HIGHER TO SELL CONNELLY
WE SHIP GROUP AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO TO THE LINE OF
THREE NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ELLIE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STOP COALITION AND I
AM PROUD CO SPONSOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF THREE NINETY FOR
YOUR LINES OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
TO ME THOSE ARE BEING USED
JUSTICE COALITION PROBABLY
COSPONSORED IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT SO I KNOW
THREE NINETY ONE YOUR LINES
OPEN. ALSO FUTURE FISCAL
MISSION BASED IN LOS ANGELES
FOR FUNDRAISING. FOR THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE UP FOR NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON JOE THE BLIND WOULD
YOU JUSTICE COALITION COULD
PROD CO SPONSOR AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND NEXT TO
GO TO A LINE OF TWO TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME-IS ERICA I'M FROM YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION. WELCOME ON. BOARD.
THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF
FOUR OH SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SH GOOD AFTERNOON MR TURN
MEMBERS RON ROB SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION WE'RE PROUD
TO SUPPORT SB TWO WE DO HAVE A
CO SPONSOR RECOMMENDATION
PENDING. AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF
FOUR TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON WILLIAM
AFTER BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MEXICO
CAROLINA FOUR OH TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON-
MANY DIFFERENT BILL MODEL THE
SENATE THERE WHEN SHE FINALLY
FOUND ME IN THE TRUNK THE
POLITICAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND AT. SO I DON'T FOUR OH NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS VERONICA SURELY OF GROUND
GAME UP THE ANGELES AND I
SUPPORT SB TO. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF THREE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE THREE THREE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF FOR ALL THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CATHERINE MARTINEZ WITH ENDING
QUALIFIED IMMUNITY PROJECT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THAT THE TWO.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF FOUR OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
DOCTOR ALLEY ANDERSON WITH ANY
QUALIFIED IMMUNITY PROJECT
EXPRESSING STRONG SUPPORT FOR
SB KO. THANK YOU HAVE TO GO TO
FOR TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
THE CRITIC I THINK THE NAME OF
THE NATIONAL LAWYERS GUILD OF
LOS ANGELES. EXPRESSING STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS CRITICAL BILL
IF HE CAN'T THINK HOW MUCH.
THANK YOU HAVE TO GO TO A LINE
OF FOUR TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH I'M SUPPOSED TO BE
UNDER OPPOSE. OKAY YOU'LL HAVE
TO RE QUEUE IT UP- OPPOSITION.
AND WE'LL GO BACK TELL WILL GO
TO LINE UP FOR ELEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MAKE MY BED BUT THE
ADVANCEMENT PROJECT CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
CAROLINA FOR TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS DONNA
ARE NOW THE- AND I'M CALLING ON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT CHILD- TO-
BOOK YEAH S. B. Q. AS THE
GROUND GAME LOS ANGELES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE
OF THREE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
GINA VIOLENT I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF WHITE PEOPLE FOR
BLACK LIVES IN LOS ANGELES IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB TWO AND
URGING EVERYONE OUT FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO SO LINE OF FOUR TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A
CHAMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ESPANA IS ON BEHALF OF THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND SOCIAL
CHANGE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOT TO
GO TO LINE OF THREE EIGHTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES HI-
SHEILA BAKED WITH BLACK LIVES
MATTER LOS ANGELES WHAT DOES
MATTER LONG BEACH BUT LET'S NOT
A CALIFORNIA AND EIGHTY. AND
ETHICALLY TERRIFIED TECHNION
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT AT
BOTH SPONSORED. BUT ALL OF
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS AND- I
REQUEST IT I ABOUT. THANK YOU
AN EXTROVERT SO LINE OF FOUR
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
EVERYONE- JUST THE CORRELATION
LOS ANGELES CROWD CO SPONSOR OF
SB TWO. AND INSTRUCT THE PORT
AND URGE YOU OFFERED AYE BOOK.
THANK YOU NXR GONNA GO TO LINE
UP. FOR THIRTY TWO. ONE FOUR
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE HEARING HELLO
LINE FOR THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY HELLO YES GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS- I APOLOGIZE.
OKAY WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTING QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU OPERATOR WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION I
DO NOT HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
LISTED FOUR MAIN WITNESSES IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO. SEEING
NONE ANYONE OF THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR OPPOSITION TO SB TWO
AND IT WILL TAKE NAME
AFFILIATION AND OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU EVERY IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO. AND WE
WILL GO TO A LINE OF FLORAL
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SURE
SHE REMEMBERS RIGHTS GENERAL
DISPATCHER CERTIFICATION
COSTUMES. CORONA REPORT BEACH
THEN I HAVE A ARCADIA FULLER
CHEN. MARA BURBANK RIVERSIDE.
CLOVER CITY LOS ANGELES POLICE
PATROL EACH SCHOOL POLICE
STATION.CALIFORNIA COALITION
ASKING FIFTY CONFESSIONAL.
EFFORTS AGAIN SHARKS. THE
TEACHER. ONSTAR OPPOSITION TO
ASK Q. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT LINE UP UP
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
FOUR THIRTY FIVE AIRLINE AS
WELL. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE THIS IS A PEOPLE ARE
CALLING IN FROM THE YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION AND SOUTH LOS
ANGELES TIMES- WE ARE ALSO CALL
OUR PROD CO SPONSORS OF SB TWO
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF THREE NINETY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD ACTORS
SHARON MEMBERS AT LEAST ARCADIA
KANO WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU RIGHT NEXT TO A PHOTO
LINE OF FOUR TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN A
MEMBER HERE AND READ
REPRESENTING PORAC IN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HIGHWAY PATROLMEN- WERE IN
OPPOSITION SO I DO WANT TO SAY
WE SUPPORT THE CERTIFICATION WE
WANT TO HAVE A FAIR PROCESS WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL NEEDS WORK
AND I NEVER COMMITTEE IS
STACKED WITH SEVEN PEOPLE WHO
ARE. BIASED AGAINST A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL WE WOULD
WANT TO SEE THAT MADE- WHAT
MADE UP OF A DIFFERENT
COMPOSITION- AND WE ARE WORKING
WITH- LEGISLATORS. IDEAS FOR
DECERTIFICATION BUT WE SUPPORT
DECERTIFICATION JUST NOT THIS
BILL AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT OVER LINE OF
FOUR SEVENTEEN YOUR LINES OPEN.
YOUR MEMBERS JONATHON FELDMAN
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION THANK.
THANK YOU NOT SO GO TO LINE OF
THREE NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CORY CELLS ARE
LOW ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT STILL GO TO
LINE OF THREE NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER JERRY
MEMBERS NOT USE I REALLY ONLY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO LOCK THAT
DOOR THAT IF YOU'RE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF FOUR THIRTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THIS IS MATTHEW
WHEATLEY RIBS IN THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU NEXT OF A LINE OF TWO
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CAREY MEMBERS JENNIFER
ROLE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF ORANGE COUNTY
DEPUTY SHERIFFS. THE CALIFORNIA
STATEWIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
FRATERNAL ORDER OF POLICE. THE
LONG BEACH POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION SACRAMENTO COUNTY
DEPUTY SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
AND THE STANFORD YOU KNOW
COUNTY SHERIFF'S EMPLOYEES
BENEFIT ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AND
THAT'S A GOOD SIGN OF ONE
NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
SPACE FOR JUST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
AUTHORITIES. WITH THE PARTY
CERTIFICATION THAT HAVE
CONCERNS THAT THE BALLOT PRINT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. RIGHT THANK YOU OPERATOR
YOU MAY CLOSE THE LINE THAT
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MS GONZALEZ. I RESPECT
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH BAY NOT
PRIMARILY IN THIS AND I
UNDERSTAND SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS AND DECERTIFICATION
WILL BE DEALT WITH AND PUBLIC
SAFETY BUT- AGAIN I. FOR FIRST
JUST TO BE CLEAR. I COMPLETELY
AGAIN VOTE FOR THIS BILL. BUT
I'M REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT SOME
OF THE FINER DETAILS SO I JUST
WANT TO DOUBLE CHECK ON A FEW
THINGS ON THIS. IT'S CLEAR FROM
SECTION FOURTEEN IT OUTLINES
RIGHT THE DIVISION INVESTIGATE
GROUNDS FROM THE
EMPLOYING AGENCY BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THEY CAN ALSO
INVESTIGATE CLAIMS FROM THE
PUBLIC CORRECT. YEAH OKAY IT'S
IF- IF THIS INCLUDES A STILL
EMPLOYED OFFICER IS THE
DIVISION REQUIRED TO NOTIFY THE
EMPLOYING AGENCY OR THE OFFICER
OF AN INVESTIGATION THAT'S
ONGOING. STUDENTS TO. EIGHT SO
THE PUBLIC REQUEST MASTICATION
THE BOARD INVESTIGATES IN THE
AGENCY HAS ALERTED THE OFFICER
HAS NO RIGHT TO BE ALERTED WELL
OR I'M THROUGH THE AGENCY
THOUGH THE OFFER WOULD BE MADE
AWARE OF THAT WE HOPE OKAY
YEAH. I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THAT'S CLARIFIED I MEAN
WE'RE WE'RE NOT VIOLATING THE
PLEASE SUCH AS BILL RIGHT TO
ANY KIND OF OKAY YOU SEE WHERE
I'M GOING WITH THIS AND- SO IT
APPEARS THOUGH THAT THERE IS A
THREE YEAR STATUTE OF
LIMITATION FOR THE BOARD. OF
COURSE AT THE PUMP ARE HAS A
ONE YEAR STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS.
IN THE COMMISSION DECERTIFIED
OFFICER IF AN EMPLOYEE AGENCY
DECIDED ONLY TO SUSPEND AN
OFFICER. FOR ASSUMING
SERIOUSNESS CONTACT YOU SEE
WHAT NOW. CAN FIRST OF ALL IF
THE EMPLOYEE IN THE AGENCY
SUSPENDED AN OFFICER CAN THE
COMMISSION STILL DECERTIFY THE
OFFICER. IF THE ACTIONS
WARRANTED THAT YES YOU HAVE
POST OR THE COMMISSION DEEMS
THOSE ACTIONS FALL UNDER THE
GUIDELINES OF WHAT
DECERTIFICATION AND JUSTICE
BECAUSE THAT AGENCY SUSPENDED
THAT ALSO YES THAT OFFICE TO BE
TERMINATED WE HAVE CLEAR
EXAMPLES WHERE OFFICERS HAVE
COMMITTED CRIMES AND JUST BEEN
PUT ON DESK DUTY EVEN THOUGH.
YOU ARE I WOULD HAVE BEEN
CONVICTED OF THOSE OPTIONS OKAY
WHAT I WOULD SUGGEST THEN IS
THAT THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
UNDER THE DECERTIFICATION
PORTION WHICH IS THREE YEARS
WOULD VIOLATE POKE BAR WHICH
HAS A ONE YEAR STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS AND PERHAPS PEOPLE
DISAGREE BUT I THINK- THAT
MIGHT BE. AN ISSUE. THAT MAYBE
PERHAPS COULD BE RESOLVED AND
PUBLIC SAFETY- AND I'M ASSUMING
THAT THAT. THE COMMISSION HAS
AUTHORITY TO DECERTIFY OFFICERS
FOR SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED
PRIOR TO JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SERIOUSNESS COULD
START WE ARE AFFORDING THEM
LIMIT RETROACTIVITY. OKAY IF
THEY ALREADY SUSTAINED A FINE
DEAN AND A SUSPENSION OR YOU
KNOW ALL AT. DISCIPLINARY PEEL
HEARING AND THE OFFICERS BEEN
GIVEN LIKE A LAST CHANCE
AGREEMENT. THEY CAN STILL
INITIATE DECERTIFICATION ON
THAT SAME CONDUCT. OR WHAT POPE
ARE BE IMPLICATED AT ALL I'M
SORRY. SO IF AN OFFICER WAS
ALREADY DISCIPLINED BY THE
EMPLOYING AGENCY THAT THE BOARD
NOW WANTS TO DECERTIFY THIS
OFFICER THE OFFICERS ALREADY.
EXTINGUISHED ITS APPEAL HAS
BEEN AT YOU KNOW HAD APPEAL
HEARING HAS ALREADY BEEN PLACED
ON A LAST CHANCE AGREEMENT. CAN
THE COMMISSION THEN COME IN
WHAT WOULD IT NOT IMPLICATE
HOPE ARE FOR THE COMMISSION
THEN TO COME IN AND DECERTIFY
THE OFFICER WHO ALREADY GOT THE
PRO THE- THE DISCIPLINARY
ACTION. I WANT TO LOOK MAIER-
MICHY I ANSWER THAT QUESTION
BECAUSE I THINK WE ADDRESS THAT
LAST YEAR- WITH- WHAT CONFLICTS
DID NOT EXIST UNDER POOL BAR-
WHEN WE PUT OUR LETTER TO THE
JOURNAL SO I WOULD IF SHE'S
STILL ONLINE I WOULD LIKE MISS
YOU- ADDRESS SAID SHE CAN'T. IS
YOU ARE YOU ON THE LINE. YES
CENTER BRADFORD THIS IS JULIE
YEAH YOU I DID NOT ADDRESS THE
DECERTIFICATION COMPONENT AT
THIS BILL LAST YEAR IF I WAS
NOT PREPARED TO ANSWER ANY OF
THE QUESTIONS I WAS UNDER THE
IMPRESSION THAT THESE QUESTIONS
WOULD BE ANSWERED IN PUBLIC
SAFETY. YEAH WE PLAN ON ANSWER
MY I JUST THOUGHT YOU MIGHT
KNOW IT NO BUT- WE ADDRESS THEM
LAST YEAR I NEED TO I'M SORRY
IF I. MISSPOKE WE ADDRESS THEM
IN OUR LETTER TO JOURNAL LAST
YEAR REGARDING P. BARBER YES
WE'RE HOPING TO ADDRESS THESE
QUESTIONS AND PUBLIC SAFETY ON
NEXT WEEK. AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
ASKING THEM HERE I'M NOT ON
PUBLIC SAFETY AND OBVIOUSLY
WILL SEE THIS AND
APPROPRIATIONS. I'M CONCERNED
THAT THERE ARE ACTUAL JUST
FUNCTIONAL ISSUES WITH THE BILL
THAT- UNFORTUNATELY WHEN
BROUGHT UP EVERYBODY POINTS AND
SAYS ARE YOU DON'T SUPPORT THIS
I SUPPORT DECERTIFICATION I
WANT A BILL THAT WORKS WITH PO
BAR- AND DOESN'T. UNDERCUT
EIGHT ON ONE WAY OR ANOTHER
DOESN'T CREATE MORE LEGAL-
PROBLEMS FOR US IN THE FUTURE
I'M HOPEFUL. I I'D BE HAPPY TO
GIVE YOU A LIST OF QUESTIONS
AND PUBLIC SAFETY THAT WE'D
LIKE TO SEE ADDRESSED BEFORE IT
COMES TO PREPARATIONS. IT'S
YOUR CHOICE WHETHER NOT TO DO
THAT I JUST I THINK AS- A
LEGISLATURE THAT IS REALLY
DEALING POLICY TO GET THE
SPECIFICS CORRECT IT IS
ESSENTIAL WHEN WE KNOW THERE'S
A CONFLICT. AND SO THAT'S WHY I
WANTEDTO BRING THEM FOR THE
SAME ISSUES THAT I BROUGHT UP
LAST YEAR- AND HOPEFUL THAT WE
CAN. GET THEM SETTLED IN PUBLIC
SAFETY BEFORE THIS BECAUSE
FRENCH APPROPRIATIONS. GOT
RIGHT I'M OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
IS THERE A SECOND. ATTOSECOND
THANK YOU MR GALLAGHER IN THE
MISTER HOLDEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN- YOU KNOW SENATOR I
THINK I FEEL LIKE WE HAVE A
MALE A LOT OF PROGRESS FROM
LAST YEAR AND A LOT OF THE
ISSUES THAT TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO BROUGHT UP- I
WOULD AGREE WITH IS. THAT I
THINK WE ALL WANT TO
DECERTIFICATION BILL IT'S- IS
JUST ABOUT ENSURING THAT- YEAH
I MEAN I LIKE IT WE GOT ALL
THESE OTHER STATES THAT HAVE IT
RIGHT ALL THESE OTHER STATES
THAT HAVE A DECERTIFICATION
PROCESS WHERE WE JUST LIKE
ALMOST COPYING. WHAT THESE
OTHER STATES HAVE DONE BECAUSE
THEY'VE DEALT WITH THE SAME
EXACT ISSUES. THEY WERE ALL
TALKING ABOUT. BUT IT SEEMS
LIKE WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE A
WHOLE NEW- TOTALLY NEW PROCESS
THAT'S DIFFERENT AND THAT AND
THAT I THINK THE CONCERNS ARE-
YOU KNOW KIND OF TWO FOLD ARE
YOU KNOW THE CONFLICTS OF
KHOBAR. I THINK THERE'S ALSO
CONFLICTS WITH ENSURING A FAIR
TRIBUNAL ON THE APPEAL PROCESS-
YEAH I MEAN ONE THING I THOUGHT
ABOUT JUST THINKING ABOUT WHAT
THAT SHOULD BE COMPOSED OF WHY
NOT HAVING LIKE RETIRED JUDGES
OR- YOU KNOW. ATTORNEYS THERE
THAT PRACTICE- IN IN IN THIS
AREA YOU KNOW JUST TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT YOU HAVE KIND OF
MORE NEUTRAL. ARBITERS TO MAKE
THIS DETERMINATION OF
DECERTIFICATION- RATHER THAN
THESE LIKE SEVEN APPOINTEES
WHICH I THINK IS THE CURRENT
MAKE UP OF THE OF THE BILL- YES
I HAVE I FEEL LIKE THERE'S
DEFINITELY A PLACE TO GET THERE
AND HAVE A DECERTIFICATION
PROCESS FINALLY. IN ALIFORNIA
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE WE'RE KIND OF.
DIG IN OUR HEELS IN A LITTLE
BIT. AND I FEEL LIKE- THERE'S
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY GET
SOMETHING THROUGH HERE THAT
WOULD BE THAT WOULD. ENSURE
THAT BOTH OF THESE THINGS ARE
DEALT WITH. PROPERLY THAT WE
DON'T HAVE BAD ACTORS OUT THERE
THEY'RE JUST GETTING. OSTERSUND
MOVED TO OTHER PLACES BUT ARE
ACTUALLY THERE OUT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOREVER RIGHT- ALSO
PROVIDING PROPER DUE PROCESS IN
A NEUTRAL- FAIR PROCESS FOR THE
OP THE ALLEGATIONS ARE BEING
MADE AGAINST- THE OFFICER- SO.
TO ME I DON'T THINK WE MOVED A
LOT I DON'T THINK COMMITTEE
CLOSER THAT'S WHY CAN'T
SUPPORTED TODAY- BUT CERTAINLY
WOULD LIKE TO SEE US GET TO
THAT PLACE. I THANK YOU MR
HOLDEN THEN THE MYSTERY OF.
THANK YOU ASSURANCE OF THE ACT
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR.
CONTINUING TO MOVE A VERY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION FOR THIS
YEAR NOW PACKAGED IN S. B. TWO
OF THIS IS A CONVERSATION AS
WELL AS RICK MENTIONED THAT WAS
PART OF LAST SESSION AND I KNOW
THAT YOU WORKED VERY HARD IN A
VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME TO
TRY TO GET SOME OF THESE VERY
COMPLICATED AND- WOVEN.
ELEMENTS ARE BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE AND TO HAVE SUCCESS
WITH THE LAST YEAR BUT PICKING
UP ON THAT AND MOVING FORWARD
WITH IT AS YOU HAVE THIS YEAR-
I WOULD SAY THAT YOU ARE.
MAKING GREAT PROGRESS- THIS WAS
CERTAINLY A BILL AS IT RELATES
TO THIS COMMITTEE AND THE FOCUS
OF THIS COMMITTEE ON THE BAY
ENACT- IS SORT OF SINGULAR I
THANK THE CHAIRMAN HAS
ARTICULATED IN THE ANALYSIS
SOME IMPORTANT- ELEMENTS THAT
MAKE THAT PART CLARIFIED AND
STRONGER- I DO BELIEVE THAT-
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
CHALLENGING BILLS BECAUSE YOU
HAVE SO MANY DIFFERENT PIECES
OF IT. HOUSED IN SO MANY
DIFFERENT COMMITTEES THAT
REQUIRE A LOT OF- DIGGING INTO
THE ELEMENTS THAT YOU'VE
ALREADY ARTICULATED IN YOUR
OPENING. AND I THINK THAT- THE
CHAIR OF APPROPRIATIONS HAS
GIVEN OUT SOME THOUGHTS OF WHAT
CAN BE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION. AND I'M JUST SORT
OF GOING OVER THIS IN THE SENSE
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND THE
MAGNITUDE OF SOMEHOW HOW
CARRYING THESE TYPE OF BILLS-
ART. ARE CHALLENGING BECAUSE
YOU'RE TRYING. TO MAKE THIS
ELEMENT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT-
TRANSPARENT. AND ACCOUNTABLE
AND YOU HAVE TOUCHED ON
COMMITTEE STRUCTURES AND THINGS
THAT ACTUALLY WILL BE PASSED
OUT MORE IN DETAIL AND PUBLIC
SAFETY. BUT I DO KNOW THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ENGAGE WITH
YOU ON THIS SO NOT ONLY IS I A
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITY IT'S ALSO
ONE WITH ADMINISTRATION. HAS
EYES ON IT AS WELL- AND I THINK
FOR ALL THE RIGHT REASONS
ACHIEVE ARTICULATED I ALSO WANT
TO JUST NOTE. THAT A BILL THAT
I'M CARRYING THE DEALS WITH-
DUTY TO INTERCEDE. THERE WAS A
DECERTIFICATION PEACE AND THAT-
WHICH WAS TAKEN OUT-
APPROPRIATELY SO BECAUSE THIS
BILL IS SORT OF BEEN WORKING
ITS WAY THROUGH THE PROCESS AND
IT MAKES SENSE RATHER THAN HAVE
ALL THESE DIFFERENT AREAS THAT
YOUR TRUCK WE'RE ALL TRYING TO
ADDRESS. BE HANDLED- WHEN
DECERTIFYING A POLICE OFFICER
WITH A LOSE THEIR JOB THAT IT'S
NOT JUST DEALT WITH THE LOCAL
LEVEL AS IT RELATES TO- HOW A
PERSON WAS THEN AN OFFICER WAS
FOUND TO HAVE VIOLATED THE
STATUTE THE RULES OF THE OF
INTERVENING- BUT THAT THAT
WOULD BE THEN HANDLED BY THIS
OVER PARKING UMBRELLA WHICH
YOU'RE CREATING. THE STRUCTURE
SO IT ADDS CLARITY AND
APPROPRIATE ACCOUNTABILITY SO I
pI DON'T I DON'T MEAN TO SAY
WHEN I SAY IT'S CONTINUES TO BE
WORK IN PROGRESS BUT BECAUSE
YOU HAVE ANOTHER COMMITTED TO
GO TO. THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
QUESTIONS THAT I THINK CAN
PROBABLY BE ANSWERED AND STILL
CONCERNS THEY CAN PROBABLY
STILL BE ADDRESSED I'M A CO.
AUTHOR WHATEVER CO AUTHOR. ON
THE BILL AND SO I CERTAINLY
SUPPORTED IN A SUPPORT- YOUR
CONSISTENT EFFORT. AS WAS
ARTICULATED BY A COUPLE OF THE
SPEAKERS. BECAUSE THESE ARE NOT
EASY BILLS- TO MOVE. TO
CLOSURE- DISCUSS DR SHIRLEY
WEBER- AND OTHERS WHO'VE TRIED
TO EMBARK ON DOESN'T HAPPEN IN
ONE YEAR. SOMETIMES IT TAKES
MULTIPLE YEARS AND YOU'RE IN
THAT PROCESS NOW. AND SO I
THINK YOU'RE POISED TO LAND THE
PLANE. I THINK THAT THE
ELEMENTS OF THIS BILL ARE
RIGHTEOUS AND APPROPRIATE TO
PURSUE. THERE ARE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED YOU'VE ALREADY
INDICATED YOUR WILLINGNESS A TO
TRY TO MEET. A LAW ENFORCEMENT
ARE AT A PLACE WHERE YOU CAN-
APPROPRIATELY ADDRESSED THOSE
CONCERNS. I TRUST YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO DO THAT. I TRUST THE
TEACHERS. GUIDANCE FOR YOU
TODAY- WITHOUT MAKING IT TIED
TO THIS ACTION BUT JUST TO-
INSTEAD OF IN FORM. OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT IT'S MOVING
TOWARDS PUBLIC SAFETY. OF SOME
OF THE AREAS THAT THIS
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
ADDRESSED AT LEAST AS IT
RELATES TO THE BAN ACT. SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP.
YOUR. OF STEADFASTNESS. AND
COMMITMENT TO THE CAUSE- MY
PLEASURE TO BE ABLE TO SECOND
THE MOTION. I DO APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT SOMEBODY HAS TO PUSH
THIS FORWARD AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THIS AS
WELL. I THINK THE COMMENTS MADE
IN THE ANALYSIS AND SINCE THE
ANALYSIS THE DISCUSSIONS YOU
HAD WITH THE CHAIR WITH
COMMITTEE ARE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE I THINK THAT
IT. IN THE END WE WANT
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO BE
WORKABLE THAT IS GOING TO
ACTUALLY MAKE IT THROUGH TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK. OF THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO. YOU'RE RIGHT
THOSE ARE COMMENTS WERE MADE
LAST YEAR AND I KNOW THAT THERE
WAS A COMMITMENT LAST YEAR TO
WORK ON THOSE. WE DIDN'T THE
BILL DIDN'T GET AS FAR AS IT
SHOULD HAVE A COULD HAVE. THE
ONE AREA- BUT I THINK IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. IS THE
MAKEUP OF THE BOARD. AND THEIR
COMMENTS WERE MADE HERE. HI MY
COLLEAGUES ALSO BY MR READ
REGARDING THE MAKEUP OF THE
BOARD. THE DECERTIFICATION I
THINK THAT EVERYBODY IS ON
BOARD ON THAT TRYING TO GET TO
THAT POINT IN FIGURING OUT WHAT
THE ACCOUNTABILITY WHAT THE
SAFEGUARDS ARE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET THERE. ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT I
APPRECIATE THAT- AS MY
COLLEAGUE HAS HAS INDICATED
YOUR WORK WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
THEY ARE A NECESSARY PARTNER
HERE. BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
MEMBERS FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
THAT WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY GET THE BAD APPLES OUT. I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK WITH THAT
AS WELL- READING THIS JUSTICE
SYSTEM THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYBODY. IT'S GOING TO TAKE A
LOT OF TENACITY AND I'M GLAD
THAT YOU'RE THERE THANK YOU THE.
SO WITH THAT- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR THIS IS A
OBVIOUSLY HUGELY CHALLENGING
BILL- AND YOU'VE GOT- ALL THESE.
PARTY'S SWAIN AND FROM YOU KNOW
UP AND DOWN THE STATE SO- I
KNOW THIS IS BEEN QUITE A LEFT
I REALIZE THAT TODAY YOU KNOW
WE'RE TALKING. ABOUT ISSUES
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE SOME OF I
THINK ARE ISSUES THAT ALL OF US
HAVE. GOOD BAD AND INDIFFERENT
COVER. THAT IS SOMETHING THAT I
WOULD PROBABLY BRING UP
PROBABLY ARE. BETTER I GUESS
APPARENTLY GOING TO BE HEARD IN
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
SAME GONNA TRY TO LIMIT. MY
COMMENTS TO FOR THE MOST PART
TO WHAT AT WHAT IS HERE BEFORE
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. AS YOU
OF. THE CERTIFICATION- I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
IMPORTANT- AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
THAT WE AS A LEGISLATURE NEED
TO ADDRESS. I DO WANT TO. HELP
HOWEVER I DO WANT TO. ADD MY
VOICE THAT. I THINK HOW DOUBLE.
THE MEMBERSHIP ON THE BOARD IS
IMPORTANT AND CRITICAL- AND HOW
WE GET TO THESE- ALTERNATE KIND
OF IT HOW POWER GOING TO
ADMINISTER THESE. THIS FROM A
JUDICIAL STANDPOINT IN THIS CAN
BE LITIGATED WE CAN ALL SEE THE
MASSIVE AMOUNT OF LITIGATION
THAT COULD COME OUT OF THIS.
AND THAT'S NOT GONNA SERVE
ANYBODY WELL- IF THIS ENDS UP
JUST BEING SWALLOWED UP IN A
MORASS OF COURT CASES. SO I
REALIZED. I BELIEVE CENTER
BRADFORD THAT THAT ISSUE IS
GOING TO BE ADDRESSED BEFORE
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE- IN
A LITTLE BIT MORE DEPTH BUT-
AND PROBABLY NICK I'M ASSUMING
ALSO IN. NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. AND I MISS
M. AND T. NONSENSE. BUT BUT I
DO JUST WANT TO ADD MY VOICE TO
THAT BUT I THINK I THINK THAT'S
A VERY IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THIS
LEGISLATION THAT DOESN'T GET
LOST OR SWALLOWED UP IN SOME OF
THESE OTHER DETAILS- SO I'D ASK
FOR YOU TO CONTINUE THINKING
THAT THROUGH CONTINUE WORKING
WITH. ALL THE PARTIES ON THAT-
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO BE
VERY IMPORTANT MAKE SURE THE
RIGHT THINGS ULTIMATELY GET
DONE. OKAY THANK YOU. SEEN I'M
SEEING THE NOT IN SOME NO I
DON'T. THANK YOU FOR YOUR HELP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I THINK
THE- AUTHOR OF FOR BRING THIS
FOR AND ALL THE HARD WORK IN
THE HARD WORK OF ALL THE-
ADVOCATES AND SUPPORTERS AS
WELL AS OPPOSITION TO THAT IS-
ENGAGE AS THEY INDICATE-
THEY'RE NOT OPPOSED. TO THE
CONCEPT OF THE CERTIFICATION
AND WE HAVE TO FIND A PLACE TO
LAND I AND I'D APPRECIATE
COMMENTS MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
COMMITTEE. HAS WON SAID THAT
WOULD ULTIMATELY EVEN WITH THE
HERCULEAN EFFORT OF THIS BILL-
HOPEFULLY MAKE IT TO THE
GOVERNOR AND THE CONVERSATION
WITH THE MINISTRATION GETTING
SIGNED- IS PART OF THE
MOVEMENT- AND THE GREATER
MOVEMENT OF US FACING REALLY
UNCOMFORTABLE TRUTHS- THAT
DON'T. SIMPLY DEAL WITH APPLE
ARE REALLY. A ROCK- WE HAVE A
SYSTEM THAT THAT HAS WROUGHT
THAT WE HAVE TO. UPROOT AND
THIS IS PART OF THAT PROCESS
AND IT'S GOING TO BE
UNCOMFORTABLE. FOR MANY THE
STAKEHOLDERS- AND IT'S HARD NOT
TO GET DEFENSIVE IF YOU'RE PART
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT- WHEN. YOU
HAVE THESE ISSUES ABOUT FOUR
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT ALL OF
US. IN THOSE OF US LEGISLATURE
HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK IN THE
MIRROR AND RECOGNIZE. NOT ONLY
THE ROLE. THAT THIS BODY HAS
PLAYED OVER GENERATIONS. IN
CREATING- THE CURRENT SYSTEM
THAT DOES NOT. REACH AND THAT
IS JUST- BUT HOW OLD THE
STAKEHOLDERS EMPLOYERS HAVE
PLAYED A ROLE AS WELL OVER THE
GENERATIONS. WE HAVE THIS
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY IN THIS
MOMENT- AS PART OF THIS GROUP
AS PART OF THE GREATER
MOVEMENT- TO ENSURE THAT- THERE
IS ACCOUNTABILITY AND JUSTICE.
THAT THERE IS DUE PROCESS FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT ALSO DUE
PROCESS- FOR THE VICTIMS AND
THE FAMILIES THAT SUFFER- AND-
THOSE WORDS SOUND EASY BUT
YOU'RE DOING THE DIFFICULT WORK
AND I APPRECIATE IT BECAUSE- IT
IS INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT. NO
PATH TO WALK DOWN BUT WE HAVE
TO WALK DOWN IT AND AS A
PRINCIPAL CALOTTERY PRECIADO.
YOUR WORK IN IN TRYING TO SEEK
JUSTICE END UP IN A- IN A MORE
EQUITABLE SYSTEM GOING FURTHER
BUT LIKE I SAID THIS IS GOING
TO BE I THINK A LONG PROCESS
FOR ALL OF US MOVING FORWARD
AND WE HAVE TO BE COMMITTED TO
LONG HAULS. THANK YOU.
TRANSACTION FAILING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER-
MISTER CHAIR I FEEL COMPELLED
TO SPEAK BECAUSE- I WAS
EXPLICITLY CALLED OUT BY ONE OF
THE CALLERS AND I THINK I KNOW
WHY BECAUSE I DID NOT SUPPORT
YOUR BILL LAST YEAR IN THIS
VERY COMMITTEE AND YET YOU KNOW
I MUST ADMIT THAT AT THE TIME I
WASN'T. VERY COMFORTABLE WITH.
YOU KNOW THE LANGUAGE ITSELF.
US INSTEAD YOU FAR YOU KNOW
DEMONSTRATED YOU. CONTINUE TO
WORK THE ISSUE AND I THINK THAT
IS THE ISSUE OF- THE
CERTIFICATION IS SOMETHING THAT
WE ALL. NEED TO WORK ON IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO BE
RESOLVED AROUND. SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR. FOR YOUR CAN YOU
LEADERSHIP. AND I'VE HAD TO.
YOU KNOW CHANCE TO SPEAK TO
NUMEROUS OF PARTIES AND PEOPLE
SINCE LAST YEAR AND REALLY HAD
A CHANCE TO REALLY. YOU KNOW DO
A LITTLE. DEEPER TAKING ON THE
ISSUE SO I WANT TO I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK AND-
AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY. AND I JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE TO YOU AND
YOUR TEAM. OF FOR YOUR HARD
WORK- OVER THE YEARS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. EXCEPT IT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR- I'M JUST
GOING TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUES
HERE IS SOME. REAL SUPPORT TO
DEFEAT CATION ESPECIALLY WILL
BE GOT THE BAD ACTORS OUT THERE
BUT LIKE A LOT OF THEM. MY
CONCERN IS THIS BOARD THIS
COMMITTEE- IT IT'S SO IMPORTANT
THAT WE DO IT THE RIGHT WAY
AND- IT DOESN'T MATTER WHERE
YOU'RE AT WHEN YOU HAVE.
MEMBERS THAT ARE APPOINTED YOU
CAN SOMETIMES GO ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER. AND SO I THINK THAT'S
REALLY REALLY- YOU KNOW
CRITICAL THAT WE THAT WE HAVE A
CLEAR PROCESS OF TRANSPARENCY
PROCESS. AND THAT THERE'S A
BALANCE THERE SO THAT WHEN
THESE THINGS GO DOWN WHEN THEY
DO HAVE JUDGMENTS. PEOPLE CAN
FEEL LIKE THERE WAS JUSTICE AND
IT WAS FAIR- FROM BEGINNING TO
THE END SO. AT THAT POINT
BECAUSE TO ME THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT- AND IT'S SUCH A-
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS BILL.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE PRETTY GOOD
THIS TIME I'M GOING TO SIT
THERE AND WATCH WHERE IT GOES
AND PUBLIC SAFETY. BUT I THINK
THAT I'M LISTENING TO MY
COLLEAGUES THIS IS PROBABLY THE
MOST IMPORTANT. AREAS RIGHT
THERE IS MAKING SURE WE HAVE A
FAIR AND BALANCED COMMITTEE
THAT WOULD BE MAKING THESE
DECISIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OTHER MEMBER COMMENTS QUESTIONS
RIGHT SEEING NONE CENTER
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS
AND WE HEARD THIS LAST YEAR AND
WE HEAR THIS AGAIN WE SUPPORT
THE CERTIFICATION JUST NOT THIS
NOT THIS THAN WHAT AND THEN
THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS BUT WE
ALSO KEEP HEARING THIS
OVERARCHING JUST NOT THIS JUST
NOT THIS JUST NOT THIS IN THAT
CASE WE'LL- NEVER GET THERE.
YEAH FOR THIS COMMITTEE WE
REALLY TRIED TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE BAY ENACT. I'M AFRAID
MOVING FORWARD IN. I UNDERSTAND
THE POLITICS BUT- THE- ADDING
CONFUSION TO AN UNDERMINING THE
BANE ACT IS SOMETHING THAT I
REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT I KNOW
YOU REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT SO
WE'RE JUST GOING TO TRY AND
CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN DO THE BEST THAT WE CAN AND
STILL MOVE SOMETHING FORWARD.
IT WOULD BE. VERY BAD FOR THIS
LEGISLATURE TO NOT MOVE
SOMETHING FORWARD THIS YEAR AND
MAKE THE BEST PROGRESS THAT WE-
POSSIBLY CAN AND I THINK WE'LL
FIND THE SKY IS NOT FALLING
THAT THAT THESE ARE APPROPRIATE
STEPS AN APPROPRIATE. VERSIONS
TO ENSURE THAT WE PROVIDE THE
SAFETY IN OUR COMMUNITIES THAT
IS NECESSARY AND- BREAK DOWN
THIS LONG STANDING. CULTURE OF
SORT OF SELF PROTECTION THAT
HAS EXISTED SO I KNOW YOUR
FRUSTRATION WE SPENT QUITE A
BIT OF TIME ON THE PHONE LAST
NIGHT WORKING THROUGH SOME OF
THIS SO I AM HOPING THAT. THE
REQUESTED THIS GETS OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE. TODAY AND I KNOW
YOU'RE WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH MR JONES SAWYER FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND I WISH YOU THE BEST
THERE AS WE MOVE THE POLICY
FORWARD. OKAY WITH THAT SENATOR
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU AND LET
ME SAY THANK YOU TO EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU WHO POSED THE
QUESTION I REALLY JUST WANT TO.
ADDRESS THE PROBAR ISSUE THAT
AND I JUST SURE WHAT ARE MY
STATEMENT WAS LARGE JOURNAL
STEERED AGAIN. IN MOST SENSES
POLLS WILL OFTEN RELY ON THE
INVESTIGATION AND THE FINDINGS
OF THE LOCAL ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
TO LEAD TO THE TERMINATION OF
OFFICERS. AND THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS BY LOCAL
AGENCIES ALL POLL BAR RIGHTS
WILL APPLY. AND NOTHING IN THIS
BILL ALLOWS LOCAL AGENCIES TO
CONDUCT AN INVESTIGATION THE BY
LIGHT POLE BARS. RIGHT I THINK
WE MADE IT CLEAR LAST YEAR
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE IT CLEAR
AGAINWE'RE NOT HERE TO
VIOLATE. OFFICERS RIGHTS I HAVE
ONE FOUR SEVEN IN MY FAMILY I
HAVE DEAR FRIENDS WHO HAVE JUST
RETIRED THIRTY FIVE YEARS WITH
LAPD WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE. WE TALK ABOUT BAD
APPLES WELL THERE'S SOME BAD
TREES THAT ARE PRODUCING A
WHOLE LOT OF BAD APPLES AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND POLITICS AND
EDUCATION. AND OUR RELIGIOUS
SYSTEM AND WE HAVE TO COME TO
THAT REALIZATION FOR SOME
REASON. POLICING IS A HOLY
GRAIL FOR. IF YOU'RE NOT PART
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT YOU CAN'T
JUDGE LAW ENFORCEMENT WE'VE HAD
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS OF
THE POLICE POLICING THE POLICE
AND IT'S GOTTEN US. ABSOLUTELY
NOWHERE. AND WE'RE DEVOID OF
TRUST AND CONFIDENCE THIS IS
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
HERE TRUST AND CONFIDENCE IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE WE ALL
WANT THE SAME THING. ABLE
OFFICER DRIVES ON THE STREET
THAT WE CAN RESPECT AND WE CAN
TRUST TO DO THE RIGHT THING AND
PROTECT AND SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THAT'S WHAT 90%
OF THOSE OFFICERS DO. THOSE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO PUT THEIR
UNIFORMS UP EVERY DAY THAT'S
WHAT THEY DO. BUT WE ALL KNOW
THE REALITIES THERE IS A 10%
OUT THERE. ARE BAD APPLES. WHO
STAINED THE REST OF THE
DEPARTMENT BUY THEIR PRODUCT
THAT THEY CONDUCT EVERY DAY
WE'VE SEEN. THE LAST THREE
YEARS THERE'S BEEN THIRTEEN
HUNDRED POLICE SHOOTINGS. ALL
THOSE THIRTEEN HUNDRED NOMINEE
OFFICERS WERE CHARGED. THIRTEEN
ALTHOUGH THIRTEEN IT WAS
CHARGED HOW MANY WERE CONVICTED
ONE. WE WOULD GO TO VEGAS WITH
THOSE ODDS ANY DAY. IT'S CLEAR
AS A WISE MAN ONCE STATED TO ME
IF YOU KEEP DOING WHAT YOU'RE
DOING YOU'RE GOING TO KEEP
GETTING WHAT YOU GET AND THAT'S
NOTHING SO. WHY NOT TRUST THE
PUBLIC THIS ADVISORY BOARD DOES
NOT HAVE FINAL SAY. BUT THEY DO
HAVE A RIGHT TO ADVICE POST
ADVICE THE COMMISSION TO SAY
LET'S LOOK AT THIS. WHY ARE WE
SO AFRAID OF JOHN THROUGH
PUBLIC. PORTRUSH DUST EVERY
DAY. TO MAKE LOST IMPACT
EVERYBODY'S WATER BUT WE WON'T
TRUST SEVEN CITIZENS SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT. I HAVE A NEIGHBOR.
WHO IS ALSO WANTED TOP DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS PROBABLY L. A. COUNTY
OF NOT IN THE STATE HE WAS ON
THE BENCH HE RESIGNED FROM THE
BENCH BECAUSE OF THE INCESTUOUS
RELATIONSHIP THAT IN EXISTING
BETWEEN. THE DA INVESTIGATING
AGENCIES WHICH IS POLICE THE
FACT THAT IT WAS ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO EVER GET AN
INDICTMENT LET ALONE A CHARGE
ON A POLICE OFFICER. THAT
SHOULD BE TROUBLING TO EACH AND
EVERYONE OF US BUT IT'S CLEAR
THE POLICE CANNOT CONTINUE TO
POLICE THEMSELVES SO THIS
ADVISORY BOARD IS JUST MADE UP
OF INDIVIDUALS. WHO DON'T HAVE
ANY BIAS AGAINST POLICE
OFFICERS THEY MIGHT OUT FEARS.
BUT THEY SHOULDN'T BE VIEWED AS
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BIASES WE TRUST
TWELVE CITIZENS EVERY DAY. IN A
JURY. TO MAKE DECISIONS ON LIFE
AND DEATH WHY SHOULD WE TRUST
SEVEN AND THIS IS WE'RE NOT
RECREATING WILL. MASSACHUSETTS
HAS THE SAME THING THEY HAVE A
COMMITTEE OF NINE PEOPLE THE
ONLY DIFFERENCE. THEY HAVE
THREE LAW ENFORCEMENT AND SIX
CITIZENS WERE SAYING SEVEN AND
TO. AND TO SAY THAT WE HAVEN'T
MOVED WE'VE GONE LIGHT YEARS
FROM WHERE WE WERE LAST YEAR TO
WHERE WE ARE WE'VE MADE
MONUMENTAL STRIDES. BUT I'M
SOMEWHAT AMUSED AT THE FACT
THAT EVERYBODY SAYS. WE WANT.
WE SUPPORT THE CERTIFICATION
I'VE SAT DOWN AND TALKED SOME
BLUE IN THE FACE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE WANT THE
CERTIFICATION WE WANT TO SERVE
KIDS BUT JUST NOT THIS BILL.
THAT'S ISN'T WHAT DO YOU
SUGGEST YOUR HOW DO WE IMPROVE
THIS BILL AND EVERYTHING THAT
THEY SUGGEST DOES NOT IMPROVE
THIS BILL. IT WEAKENS WHAT WE
ALL SAY WE WANT. SO AT SOME
POINT WE ALL NEED TO LOOK
OURSELVES IN THE MIRROR. AND
QUICK. PARROTING WHAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT CONTINUES TO SAY
THAT THEY WANT BUT THEY DON'T
WANT THIS ONE IF NOT NOW THEN
WHEN. IF NOT US THEN WHO IT'S
TIME TO MAKE A DECISION.
MARLOWE THE KINGS CROSS ST IT
COMES A TIME WHEN YOU HAVE TO
TAKE POSITION THAT'S NEITHER
SAFE. NOR POLITIC. OR POPULAR.
WE TAKE IT BECAUSE I CONSCIOUS%
TELLS IS JUST RIGHT THING TO
DO. THIS IS THE RIGHT THING TO
DO I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND AND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO PUBLIC
SAFETY CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
STONE HI STONE HI GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CHAO CHAO CHIU AYE
CHIU AYE DAVIES DAVIES NO
GONZALEZ RIGHT GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN HOLDEN HI KALRA KALRA
AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN HI
MAIENSCHEIN HI RES RESIGN THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PREACHER THANK YOU SENATOR. WE
ARE AT OUR TIME LIMIT I WANT TO
GO THROUGH THE BILLS THAT WE
HAVE SO WE CAN COMPLETE THE
WORK THAT WE STARTED TODAY WE
ARE STILL WORKING AT I WOULD
LIKE TO MOVE IT SB TWO EIGHT
EIGHT. WE DO HAVE A ON SB TWO
EIGHT EIGHT BUT YOU'RE GONNA
WAIT OKAY WE DO HAVE A SECOND
ON THAT. LET'S GO BACK THROUGH.
THE BILL LIST AND COMPLETE THE
BUSINESS THAT WE HAVE WE ARE
STILL WORKING ON A ROOM. FOR
BEING ABLE TO CONTINUE TODAY
POTENTIALLY WE COULD COME BACK%
TO THIS HEARING ROOM AFTER THE
NEXT COMMITTEE. BUT I'M NOT
SURE. HOW WE'RE GOING TO PULL
THAT OFF SO. THIS CIVIL LET'S
ROLL THROUGH AND GET EVERYBODY
ON WHO'S HERE THE CONSENT
AGENDA CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
PLEASE. CLICK ON CONSENT
GALLAGHER- GALLAGHER AYE CHU.
CHU AYE DAVIES DAVIES HI KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN I MENTIONED I. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER ONE
SB TWO FIFTY TWO WIENER I
BELIEVE THAT BILL IS OUT TO
CALL THE OF THEMEMBERS STONE
HI STONE HI CHU CHU HI KALRA
RIGHT KALRA AYE KILEY. RIGHT
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB FIVE THIRTY
ONE WHITE HOUSE SKI CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS STONE HI STONE
HI. CHU CHU BY DAVIES DAVIES NO
KALRA. OUR KALRA HI KILEY. OKAY
ITEM NUMBER FIVE S. B. TWO
SEVEN I'M SORRY S. B. TH SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN LEYVA. CHAO CHILD
BY DAVIES DAVIES NOW. AND KILEY.
RATE ITEM NUMBER SIX IS ON CALL
THIS IS SB SEVEN OH THREE HER
TITLE WILL LIFT THE CALL. CHOW
CHOW FIVE CHU. CHU FIVE TV'S.
DVI KALRA BONTA I SKIP SORRY
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I KALRA
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN I
MAIENSCHEIN I THANK YOU THE
BILL IS OUT OF NUMBER SEVEN SB
SIX OH SIX GONZALEZ COPY OF THE
MEMBERS CHAO. SHALL HI DAVIES
DAVIES NOW. REYES ALL RIGHT
REYES AYE. OKAY ADAM NUMBER
EIGHT SB THREE TWENTY EGGMAN
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. CHAU
CHOW CHU CHU FIVE DAVIES DAVIES
BY HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE KILEY.
THANK YOU I HAVE NEVER NINE SB
THREE EIGHTY EGGMAN THAT BILLS
ON CALL I'M GONNA LIFT THE CALL.
GALLAGHER. CHOW CHOW HI CHU CHU
FIVE DAVIES DAVIES NOW KALRA
FIVE CALLER I. MAIENSCHEIN HI
MAIENSCHEIN HAI RIGHT YOU THE
BILL IS OUT I NUMBER TEN SB
FIVE OH SEVEN EGGMAN IS ALSO ON
CALL LIFT THE CALL. CHOW CHOW I
CHU. CHU FIVE DAVIES. DAVIES I.
KALRA ALL RIGHT HI KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN TIME MISSION I THE
BILL IS OUT I AM NUMBER ELEVEN
SB THREE TWENTY ONE TORONTO.
COPY OF THE MEMBERS GALLAGHER.
Q. FIVE CHIU HI DAVIES DAVIES
HI KILEY MAIENSCHEIN HI
MAIENSCHEIN I. HELLO AM
THIRTEEN I THINK WE'VE HAD
EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM ITEM
EIGHTEEN IS SB TWO ADA JONES WE
DO A MOTION AND A SECOND THAT
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. SB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
THIS IS SB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
ITEM EIGHTEEN JONES- THAT NEEDS
A SECOND I WE DO HAVE A SECOND
BY MS DAVIES. FOR STONE BY
STONE ICE GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER
I CHAO. CHAO AYE CHIU. DAVIES
DAVIES I GONZALEZ NO GONZALEZ
NO HOLDEN. KALRA KALRA NOW
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN IN CHINA AND
REYES. OKAY THE BILL FAILS AND
I WILL NOTICE RECONSIDERATION
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR JONES ITEM
NUMBER NINETEEN IS ACR NINETY
FIVE. CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
PLEASE. GALLAGHER GALLAGHER HI
JUNE FIVE CHIU I'D DAVIES
DAVIES HI KILEY MAIENSCHEIN HI
MAIENSCHEIN HAI. RIGHT THAT IT
IS BEEN ADOPTED- THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW HAVE TO. I BELIEVE I
HAVE DON'T KNOW IF WE'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO MEET AGAIN. THIS
AFTERNOON AND FINISH THIS IS IF
NOT THE REMAINING BILLS. FIVE
BILLS WILL BE PUT OVER TO NEXT
THANK YOU. GREAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL WE JUST NEEDED TO
WAIT FOR THE TECHNOLOGY TO GET
CONNECTED I THINK WE'RE UP AND
RUNNING NOW THIS IS ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY WE'RE CONTINUING THE
HEARING FROM THIS MORNING AND
FOR THOSE WATCHING WANTING TO
CALL IN I THINK I'LL JUST
REITERATE THE PHONE NUMBER
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
DIAL IN IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE
FOUR TWO. OH TWO WE HAVE OUR
MODERATOR WE HAVE OUR SYSTEM UP
SO WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE WITH
OUR AGENDA AND THE BILLS THAT
WE HAVE BEEN. WORKING THROUGH
SO SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE SORRY FOR ALL
THE WAITING TODAY AS WE WORK
THROUGH EVERYTHING WILL SAY WE
HAVE. I ITEMS THREE AND FOUR SB
SIXTEEN AND THEN SB. THREE
FIFTY FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- DON'T MIND WAITING SLICE
GET TO GET IT DONE SO I'M
PRESENTING- SB SIXTEEN AND I'M
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
IN THE ANALYSIS REGARDING
CLARIFICATIONS ON ATTORNEY
CLIENT PRIVILEGE AND REQUIRING
DISCLOSURE OF FACTUAL
INFORMATION- THIS BILL IS A
REINTRODUCTION. OF SB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX WHICH WAS BEFORE YOU
LAST YEAR IN WHICH GOT FIFTY
THREE VOTES ON YOUR FLOOR CAN
IN FACT THE BILL THAT GOT FIFTY
THREE VOTES ON YOUR FLOOR HAD
EVEN MORE STRINGENT
REQUIREMENTS IN THIS ONE
THERE'S BEEN SOME AMENDMENTS-
THE BILL HAS BEEN MODIFIED. TO
ADDRESS SOME CONCERNS OF POLICE
CHIEFS AND OTHERS AND ALL
DESCRIBE THAT IN THE MIDDLE IN
A MINUTE. THE REASON. WHY THIS
BILL IS NOT YET LAW IS BECAUSE
IN THAT CHAOS OF THE LAST DAY
OF SESSION- DAIRY. IT GOT SENT
OVER THE SENATE BUT NOT IN TIME
FOR THE MIDNIGHT DEADLINE FOR
US TO TAKE IT UP SO I'VE
REINTRODUCED AND EVERY
INTRODUCED BECAUSE- THIS BUILDS
ON. A BILL THAT WE PASSED A FEW
YEARS AGO CALIFORNIA IS AN
OUTLIER STATE WE HAD FORTY
YEARS WE'RE NO. RECORDS
REGARDING POLICE MISCONDUCT
WERE AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC
ZERO PERIOD EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE
A GREAT PUBLIC RECORDS ACT IN
EVERY OTHER CATEGORY PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES IS SUBJECTED TO IT.
SO THE FIRST BILL LED A VERY
LIMITED SET OF PUBLIC RECORDS
ABOUT. PUBLIC ABOUT A POLICE
MISCONDUCT BE AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC. THIS ADDS TO THAT BILL
IT ADDS SOME ADDITIONAL
CATEGORIES OF ACTIONS THAT CAN
BE ALLOWED FOR PUBLIC
DISCLOSURE. AND IT ADDS A
LITTLE BIT OF- TEETH BECAUSE WE
HAD UNFORTUNATELY SOME
JURISDICTIONS DRAG THEIR FEET.
AND NOT RESPOND TO THEIR PUBLIC
RECORDS REQUEST SO
SPECIFICALLY. SB SIXTEEN
STRENGTHENS OUR CURRENT LAW. BY
EXPANDING ACCESS TO RECORDS ON
OFFICERS WHO ENGAGED IN.
UNREASONABLE AND EXCESSIVE
FORCE. WHO HAVE ENGAGED IN
RACIST HOMOPHOBIC ANTI SEMITIC
OR OTHER DISCRIMINATORY AND
BIASED ACTIONS. WHO ENGAGE IN
UNLAWFUL ARRESTS OR SEARCHES
FOR ENGAGING DISHONESTY SUCH AS
FRAMING PEOPLE. AND IT ALSO
HELPS ENSURE THAT AN OFFICER
WHO MAY BE ACCUSED OF SOMETHING
CAN'T JUST QUIT THEIR
DEPARTMENT AND MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT APARTMENT WITHOUT HAVING
ANY RECORD FALL OF THEM BECAUSE
WHAT WAS HAPPENING IS AN
OFFICER WOULD QUIT BEFORE THE
INVESTIGATION WAS COMPLETED IN
MOST OF THESE RECORDS HAVE TO
BE AN INVESTIGATION HAS TO BE
COMPLETED IN SUSTAIN FINDINGS.
BEFORE THEY WOULD BE MADE
PUBLIC SO IT ALSO REQUIRES
RECORDS TO BE ESTABLISHED IF
THE- OFFICER RESIGNS BIRD
INVESTIGATION AND IT HELPS
PREVENT THAT SITUATION WHERE A
JURISDICTION SAYS HEY. WE HAD
NO IDEA THAT THIS OFFICER HAD
THIS HISTORY WHEN THEY HIRED
THEM SO IT REQUIRES. AGENCIES
TO GET THE RECORDS ON OFFICERS
THEY'RE CONSIDERING TO HIGHER
SO THAT THEY KNOW THEY HAVE
THEIR FULL INFORMATION ABOUT
THEIR BACKGROUND- AND WITH THAT
I'D LIKE TO HAVE MY WITNESSES
WHO- WE HAVE NATASHA MINSKER
FROM SMART JUSTICE AND THE HEAD
OF THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION CHIEF ABDEL
PROTECTION. THANK YOU AND- WE I
DO HAVE THOSE TWO WITNESSES
LISTED NATASHA MINSKER AND
CHIEF PRIDGEN THE TASHA MINSKER.
GOOD AFTERNOON NATASHA MINSKER
ON BEHALF OF SMART JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA SB SIXTEEN IS A
MODEST NON CONTROVERSIAL
PROPOSAL THAT SEEKS TO ADDRESS
THE ROADBLOCKS THAT FAMILY
MEMBERS COMMUNITIES AND
REPORTERS HAVE ENCOUNTERED IN
TRYING TO ACCESS POLICE
MISCONDUCT RECORDS UNDER CENTER
SKINNER'S LANDMARK BILL SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE. FOR
EXAMPLE DEPARTMENTS NOW
ROUTINELY DESTROY RECORDS THAT
THEY ARE LEGALLY PERMITTED TO
DO THEY REFUSE TO DISCLOSE
RECORDS WHEN AN OFFICER RESIGNS
DURING INVESTIGATION THEY
CHARGE FAMILY MEMBERS THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS FOR QUOTE COPYING
FEES TO REPRODUCE RECORDS THAT
ARE STORED IN A DIGITAL FORMAT
THAT CAN BE EASILY REPRODUCED.
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF
ROADBLOCKS THAT FAMILY MEMBERS
COMMUNITY MEMBERS REMEMBERS AND
RECORDERS HAVE ENCOUNTERED IN
TRYING TO ACCESS MISCONDUCT
RECORDS AND THESE ARE THE ROAD
BLOCK SB SIXTY SIXTEEN REMOVED
ENSURING THAT THE PUBLIC'S
RIGHT TO KNOW IS NEEDING FALL
ADS ORIGINALLY INTENDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. THE BILL PROVIDES
MODEST ACCESS TO AN ADDITIONAL
SET OF RECORDS THAT ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
PUBLIC IN UNDERSTANDING WHETHER
THEIR LOCAL DEPARTMENT IS
TAKING SERIOUSLY ACCUSATIONS OF
MISCONDUCT OR EXCESSIVE FORCE
BY POLICE DEPARTMENTS. SB
SIXTEEN IS A MODEST PROPOSAL ON
BEHALF OF BOTH SMARTER TO
CALIFORNIA AND THE PROSECUTORS
ALIGNED TO CALIFORNIA I. URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THEN SEIZE
POLICE CHIEF OF THE PRIDGEN
CHIEF REGION ARE YOU WITH US.
SHARE GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBER. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARE NUMBERS MY NAME IS ABDUL
PRIDGEN AND I AM THE PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION. EPCA IS A
PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATION THAT
REPRESENTS ALL THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO POLICE CHIEFS IN
CALIFORNIA. ON BEHALF OF C. PCA
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL SIXTEEN. AT GUCCI'S IT IS
CRITICAL NOW MORE THAN EVER WE
ARE TRANSPARENT ESPECIALLY
REGARDING DISCIPLINE. OUR
COMMUNITIES MUST KNOW AND TRUST
THAT WE HOLD OFFICERS
ACCOUNTABLE VIOLATE LAW OR
POLICY. UNFORTUNATELY IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE HISTORICALLY
RESTRICTED THE RELEASE A POLICE
DISCIPLINARY FILES. TO THE
DETRIMENT OF PUBLIC TRUST. YOU
CANNOT EXPECT THE PUBLIC TO
HAVE FAITH IN OUR
ADMINISTRATION OF DISCIPLINE
WHO ARE NOT OPENLY SHARING THE
INFORMATION. THAT IS WHY TPC
AID SUPPORTED CENTER SKINNERS
ORIGINAL LEGISLATION TO ALLOW
THE RELEASE OF SPECIFIC
DISCIPLINARY FILES AND IT IS
WHY WE ARE SUPPORTING SENATE
BILL SIXTEEN TODAY. POLICE
CHIEF CONSISTENTLY ADMINISTER
DISCIPLINE WHEN OFFICERS USED
EXCESSIVE FORCE CONDUCT
UNLAWFUL SEARCHES OR
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST COMMUNITY
MEMBERS CATEGORIES INCLUDED IN
SENATE SIXTEEN. THE PASSAGE OF
THIS BILL WE WILL BE ABLE TO
SHOW THE PUBLIC OUTCOMES ABOUT
LENGTHY AND COMPREHENSIVE
INTERNAL INVESTIGATION. I'D
LIKE TO THANK SENATOR SKINNER
AND HER STAFF FOR WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH US TO ADDRESS
THE PRACTICAL IMPLEMENTATION
AND COST CONCERNS WE ORIGINALLY
HAD WITH SB SIXTEEN WHICH
ALLOWED US TO MOVE TOWARDS A
COURT POSITION. WORKING
TOGETHER WE'RE ABLE TO BRIDGE
GAPS AND FIND SOLUTIONS THAT
CREATE STRONGER COMMUNITIES AND
WE ARE GRATEFUL TO THE
SENATOR'S COMMITMENT TO TAKING
THIS APPROACH. THE REASON THAT
STATED WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I BOOKED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU JAY THERE IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIXTEEN. ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE
OF THE REMOTE TO MY TO READ THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE. SIGNUP
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB
SIXTEEN. WILL BE TAKING NAMES
AND AFFILIATIONS AND SUPPORT
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO TAKE ANY
FURTHER TESTIMONY. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE ABOUT TO COMMENT THINK YOU
WERE GOING TO LINE UP FOR
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SUS CARL LONDON AGAIN
ON BEHALF OF THE RECORDING
INDUSTRY AND A COALITION OF
MUSIC INDUSTRY INTEREST. IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIXTEEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NINE FOUR
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JIM
WEINBERG ON BEHALF THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION THAT
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. RIGHT
THANK YOU WE WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE ONE WITNESS
LISTED SHAUN RUNDLE. FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION ARE YOU WITH US. I
CURRENTLY DO NOT SEE SHAUN DIAL
DAN. OKAY MILITARE THIS IS
COREY SO THEY'LL- I WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE A LEAD WITNESS
AS WELL FROM THE STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION ALL RIGHT THIS IS
ALSO THEN GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS COURSE ALTHOUGH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION.
REGRETTABLY IN OPPOSITION- TO
SENATE BILL SIXTEEN UNLESS IT'S
AMENDED. UNTIL THE ENACTMENT OF
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE FROM
TWENTY EIGHTEEN STATUTE AND
CASE LAW PROVIDED ENHANCE AN
APPROPRIATE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
FOR PEACE OFFER PERSONAL
RECORDS AS WELL AS METHODS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH
RECORDS CAN BE ACCESSED. SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE MADE
SPECIFIED RECORDS AVAILABLE FOR
PUBLIC DISCLOSURE BUT MAINLY
LIMITED THE SCOPE OF WHAT COULD
BE RELEASED. TO RECORDS
RELATING TO USES OF FORCE THAT
RESULTED IN DEATH OR GREAT
BODILY INJURY. OR OTHER
SITUATIONS IN WHICH A COMPLAINT
OF WRONGDOING HAD BEEN
SUSTAINED. SENATE BILL SIXTEEN
EXPANDS THE RECORDS. ON USE OF
FORCE ALLEGATIONS THAT CAN BE
RELEASED TO INCLUDE COMPLAINTS
THAT ALLEGE UNREASONABLE OR
EXCESSIVE FORCE. WE APPRECIATE
VERY MUCH THE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS- REGARDING THE
ATTORNEY CLIENT. PRIVILEGE THAT
WERE DISCUSSED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS- WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN EARLIER.
TO THE BILL TO REMOVE
PROVISIONS RELATED TO CIVIL
FINES IN THE ABILITY TO SEE
COSTS ATTORNEY'S FEES. ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION OF THE BILL WERE
FURTHER AMENDED TO LIMIT THE
NEW USE OF FORCE PROVISION
DESCRIBED ABOVE. TO PERMIT
DISCLOSURE OF RECORDS RELATED
TO AN INCIDENT INVOLVING A
SUSTAIN FINDING OF EXCESSIVE
FORCE. CSSA WOULD REMOVE ITS
OPPOSITION- AND FURTHER IN
CONSIDERATION THE COMMITTEES
TIME I WOULD ALSO NOTE THE
OPPOSITION OF THE CALIFORNIA
LAW ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION OF
RECORDS SUPERVISORS. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS CSSA AS OPPOSED
TO THE BILL UNLESS AMENDED
THANK YOU. RIGHT THANK YOU N.
HAS SHAUN RUNDLE JOINED. I DO
NOT SEE HIM OUT THERE OKAY WE
WILL MOVE TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM
ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM.
SHE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SIXTEEN. SEEING NONE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR THOSE WHO'D LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION TO SB.
SIXTEEN THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB
SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AT TEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT THREE COMMENTS THINK
YOU OVER TWO LINES FOR EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS CRYSTAL
KEY DOLLARS ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
CREEK INNOVATION SOLUTIONS AND
MANAGEMENT OPPENHEIMER CHRISM
IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN OF FOUR
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS
AT LEAST PARTS OF THE ECONOMY
WITH THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE STILL REVIEWING THE
MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS RELATED
TO ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE
AND WILL KEEP YAKKING BALK AT
THE PRICE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN FOR NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS MATTHEW
EASILY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION WERE
OPPOSED LAS AMENDED FOR THE
SAME REASONS IS THE PERFECT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME RIGHT THANK YOU
OPERATOR YOU CAN CLOSE THE.
TELEPHONES AND I WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. DISCO.
THANK YOU SENATOR- I KNOW ONE
OF THINGS IT WAS BROUGHT ABOUT
POSITION IS ON USE OF FORCE
THAT IT COULD INCLUDE
COMPLAINTS OF EXCESSIVE FORCE
WHERE THE OFFICER WAS NOT FOUND
TO HAVE ENGAGED THERE WASN'T A
SUSTAIN FINDING- OR THERE WAS
INCONCLUSIVE YOU KNOW MIGHT BE
THE THING THAT COMES BACK- IN
THOSE TYPES OF SITUATIONS I
MEAN SHOULD I BE LIKE THESE
OTHER ONES THAT SHOULD BE AN
ACTUAL SUSTAIN FINDING THAT IN
FACT. THAT DID OCCUR NOT JUST
TO COMPLAIN. WE MADE THAT
SECTION OF THE LAW CONSISTENT
WITH THE SECTION ON THE A
DEADLY USE OF FORCE IN THE
ORIGINAL BILL. AND THOSE ARE
THE ONLY TWO SECTIONS WHERE
DOES NOT HAVE TO BE ASSISTING
FINDING. AND- ALL OTHER
SECTIONS HAVE TO BE SUSTAINED
FINDINGS. AND WHAT WAS KIND OF
THE REASON FOR THAT I GUESS
WELL PARTLY IT'S- HEY. IN THE
QUESTION OF FORCE THERE IS. WE
WOULD SAY SOME LEVEL OF
SUBJECTIVITY THERE IS-
OBVIOUSLY LITTLE TO NO SAID
CHECK TIVITY AROUND SEXUAL
ASSAULT- IN VARIOUS- SO THE-
SENSE WAS THAT. IF THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS A RIGHT TO KNOW IF
THERE IS AN OFFICER WITH THE
HISTORY OF. COMPLAINTS AROUND
USE OF FORCE. AND THAT WHILE
THERE IS OBVIOUSLY LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S FEAR THAT THERE
MAY BE SITUATIONS WHERE THERE
ARE FRIVOLOUS FRIVOLOUS SUCH
COMPLAINTS. I THINK ON BALANCE.
IN MOST AGENCIES ARE UP AND
DOWN THE STATE YOU DON'T HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF FRIVOLOUS
TYPES OF SUCH COMPLAINTS BUT
RATHER YOU HAVE. CITIZENS
RESIDENTS INDICATING WHEN THEY
FELT FORCE WHICH USED AND THAT
SEEMS TO BE VERY LEGITIMATE
INFORMATION FOR- FOR THE PUBLIC
TO KNOW BECAUSE THE POINT OF
THE BILL IS FOR TO HOPE TO HOLD
AGENCIES ACCOUNTABLE. AND IF WE
TAKE AND WE DDED THIS ISSUE OF
THE EXCESSIVE FORCE BECAUSE IF
WE TAKE THE CIRCUMSTANCE OF.
THEIR CHILDREN THE- OFFICER IN
THE GEORGE FLOYD CASE HE HAD A
HISTORY OF EXCESSIVE FORCE HE
DIDN'T HAVE A HISTORY OF THE
DEADLY FORCE BUT HE HAD A
HISTORY OF THE EXCESSIVE FORCE.
AND THAT WAS AVAILABLE UNDER
MINNESOTA'S LOSS BECAUSE THOSE
RECORDS ARE AVAILABLE HOWEVER
WE WOULD NEVER HAVE KNOWN THAT
IN UNDER CALIFORNIA'S LAW WE
WOULD NOT KNOW THAT ABOUT THAT
OFFICER SO THAT WAS THE FEELING
THAT THAT WAS A LEGITIMATE
PIECE OF INFORMATION FOR PEOPLE
IN AND OUT. AND IF WE COMPARE
THIS BILL IN OUR CURRENT
STATUTE TO THE PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT FOR EXAMPLE. IN THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT MOST AT ALMOST
EVERY INFORMATION THAT YOU
WOULD REQUEST DOES NOT HAVE TO
BE SUSTAINED OR VERIFIED YOU
HAVE U. S. THE PUBLIC ART HAVE
ACCESS TO THE RECORDS. THAT'S
JUST THE WAY THE LAW IS WRITTEN.
WELL LIKE FOR INSTANCE I MEAN
AND- CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG I
MEAN WE'VE HAD THESE NEW
PROVISIONS REGARDING-
LEGISLATIVE MEMBERS WHERE
THINGS DON'T GET RELEASED IF
THERE'S NOT A SUSTAINED FINDING.
RIGHT ASSEMBLY LIKE COMPARING
IT TO OUR OWN SITUATION- THERE
pIS A RELEASE A PUBLIC RELEASE
IF THERE WAS A SUSTAIN FINDING
AGAINST A MEMBER. FOR INSTANCE
BUT- AS I UNDERSTAND THERE IS
NOT IF THERE IS AN ASSIST IF
THERE IS NOT A STAND FOR THIS-
SB SIXTEEN AND THE STATUTE
THAT'S- IN EFFECT NOW SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE. FOR BOTH
BASED ON THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
WHICH GOVERNMENT NOT ON THE
LARA CORRECT ME ON ON YOUR.
OKAY YEAH THAT'S ALL THE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE THANK
YOU. FOR THE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE
A MOTION IS THEIR SECOND. AND
THE SECOND THANK YOU SENATOR
YOU MAY CLOSE- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH EARNED CHAIR THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES DID NOT OPPOSE THE BILL
LAST YEAR NOR DID THEY OPPOSE
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE SO I
FIND IT INTERESTING TO HAVE
THEM OPPOSE NOW AND I WONDER IF
RECORDS ACT AT THIS POINT- IT
WOULD APPEAR THAT SOME OF THEIR
OPPOSITION IS DUE TO THE WORK
THAT IS INVOLVED IN HAVING TO
PRODUCE THESE RECORDS. AND THAT
OF COURSE- YES IT IS A
ADDITIONAL- BURDEN ON ON- LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES HOWEVER I THINK IT IS
ILLEGITIMATE AND WORTHWHILE ONE
TO HELP BUILD COMMUNITY TRUST
AND TO ENABLE US TO HOLD OUR
AGENCIES ACCOUNTABLE AND WITH
THAT I ASKED FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU SO WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED. TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. STONE AYE STONE AYE
GALLAGHER NO GALLAGHER NOTE
SHALL. TWO FIVE TWO FIVE DAVIES.
GONZALEZ HOLDEN HOLDEN HI KALRA
KALRA KILEY MAIENSCHEIN RADIUS
REYES AYE. THE BILL NEEDS ONE
MORE SO FEDERAL PUT ON CALL.
GREAT OKAY ITEM NUMBER FOR SB.
THREE FIFTY FOUR. THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU- THEN I'LL BE VERY
QUICK I WILL JUST INDICATE THAT
IF THIS- SB THREE FIFTY FOUR.
CREATES A PROCESS FOR A PERSON
WITH A PAST CONVICTION TO APPLY
FOR AN EXEMPTION IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO BE FOSTER. A FAMILY
MEMBER AND THE EXEMPTION
PROCESS INVOLVES A THOROUGH
ASSESSMENT OF THAT PERSON'S
FITNESS TO CARE FOR THE CHILD
BECAUSE OF COURSE OUR PRIMARY
OBJECTIVE WOULD BE TO ENSURE
THAT WE DO NOT ENDANGER
CHILDREN. AND THAT IS WHY THE
WELFARE- OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
IS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
WITHOUT IT LIKE TO HAVE MY
WITNESSES BORN YOUR CORALS FROM
STARTING OVER IN KHAKI CENTER
LINK FROM THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU I DO HAVE THOSE TWO
WITNESSES ON YOUR QUARRELS AND
CATHERINE'S THE NEARLY
MCDONALD'S. FOR NEW CORALS ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. I CURRENTLY DO
NOT SEE RUNNING IT DIALED IN
HELLO KATHY CENTER. HER LINE IS
OPEN. GREAT THANK YOU HI MISTER
CHEN NUMBERS KATHY SANDERLING
MADONNA WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION TDB
HEARING INCREASE COULD BE A CO
SPONSOR OF SB THREE THIRTY FOUR
I'M GLAD TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TO THAT.
I FROM THE COUNTY CHILD WELFARE
AGENCY PERSPECTIVE THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT WILL HELP
COUNTY PLACE MORE CHILDREN WITH
RELATIVE CAREGIVERS WHEN THEY
COME INTO CARE RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT CHILDREN BONTA CHARACTER
MUCH BETTER WITH RELATIVES IN
GENERAL AND RELATIVES OF THE
FIRST PAGE COUNTY TURNS BUT BY
LAW AND THAT PRACTICE. AS PART
OF THE RESEARCH FAMILY APPROVAL
PROCESS WHICH APPLIES TO ALL
POTENTIAL CARE GIVERS ANY
PERSON LIVING IN A REGULARLY
PRESENT IN THE HOME MUST BE
BACK ON TRACK ANYONE WITH MORE
THAN A MINOR TRAFFIC MARIJUANA
AND PASINETTI CAN EXEMPTION OF
THE HOME CANNOT BE APPROVED.
EXEMPTIONS ARE DONE ON A CASE
BY CASE BASIS GRANTED AFTER AN
EXTENSIVE REVIEW OF THE CRIME
AS LONG AS THE PERSON IS TAKEN
SINCE THAT TIME TOO SO THEY
HAVE CHANGED AND ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE A SAFE AND LOVING
ENVIRONMENT FOR THE CHILD. NOT
EVERY EXEMPTION REQUEST IS
GRANTED AND APPROVAL OF THE
EXEMPTION AND SUBSEQUENT
APPROVAL OF THE RESEARCH FAMILY
DO NOT GUARANTEE THAT A
PARTICULAR. CHILD WILL BE
PLACED THEM AT HOME. EVERYTHING
HERE TO THE MEDIA HAS SUPPORT
AND CO SPONSORED. TO SIMPLIFY
AND X. THE AVAILABLE OF EXAM
FOR MY CRIMES. AND A CRIME THAT
OCCUR IN THE- HOWEVER MANY
CURRENT SURVEY NOT ACCEPTABLE.
OKAY AN IMPORTANT GUIDED BY A
READ APOLLO COURT IS. THAT IS
DETAILED YOUR IN OUR- THE
DECLARED THE CURRENT PROCESS
UNCLE. WHEN IT COMES TO
RELATIVES NON RELATED EXTENDED
FAMILY MEMBERS. BEING
CONSIDERED A POTENTIAL CARE
GIVERS CORRECTIVE PERFECT
LIMITED CHILD. IN THE COURT
RULED THAT SOMEONE CONVICTED A
CRIME TO. NOT A UP ALL MY BE
GIVEN A CHANCE REQUEST TENSION
RECEIVING EXEMPTION. IF THEIR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE CHILD AT
THE CAN THAT OF A. CAN YOU
CONSIDERING EXEMPTION THE SAME
PROVISION IF THAT'LL THAT SUCH
A RELATION BECAUSE THAT. THEIR
INTERFERE WITH THE TIME. THE
RELATIVE AND I IS NOW OF THE
REAL. THIS WILL BE AIDED BY THE
CHILD AND FAMILY TEAMING
PROCESS THAT OCCURRED A CHILD
IS BROUGHT INTO CARE. WHICH
INCLUDES FAMILY MEMBERS AS WELL
AS OTHER TO IMPORTANT IN A
CHILD'S LIFE. IMPORTANTLY THE
EXEMPTION PROCESS ITSELF WOULD
REMAIN AN EXTENSIVE CASE BY
CASE PROCESS AND WOULD NOT BE
AUTOMATIC. AND AS OF TODAY
APPROVAL OF THE RESEARCH FAMILY
WOULD NOT GUARANTEE A
PARTICULAR PLACEMENT. RIGHT NOW
COUNTY SAN TYLER IT COMES TO
YOU CONSIDER CERTAIN. OF GIVERS
TO RIDICULOUS CHILD EVEN IF
THEIR CRIMES OCCURRED LONG AGO
AND THEY HAVE CLEARLY CHANGED
HAVE THE NEXT SIGNIFICANT
EXISTING RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
CHILD. THE COURT DECISION MAKES
IT CLEAR THAT WE NEED TO CHANGE
OUR LAWS TO ALLOW FOR A CASE BY
CASE EXEMPTION. COULD BRIEFLY
CONSIDERED WHAT A DEEP
RELATIONSHIP ALREADY EXISTS
BETWEEN THE CHILD AND THE
RELATIVES WHO HAS THE POTENTIAL
CARE GIVER. TO WTA SUPPORTERS
CHANGED AND SB THREE THIRTY
FOUR WAS ACTUATED AND A
CONSISTENT STATEWIDE MANNER.
FOR ALL REASONS WE ARE JUST A
PART OF THE BILL IN A AND HAVE
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM WHO LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE FIFTY FIVE
I BELIEVE THAT FIND IT IS ON
THE LINE INTACT MISTER ARE OKAY
HIS VENUE FOR WITH THIS. I DO
NOT SEE RONNIE OF WIND OUT THEN
IF YOU ARE ON THE LINE YOU CAN
PRESS STAR ZERO SO WE CAN
GATHER YOUR NAME. ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE OPEN OUR LINE. HELLO
OUR BY NEARBY IS OPEN- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. HI MY NAME IS
SONIA QUARRELS CAN YOU HEAR ME
NOW YES WE CAN. OKAY I'M A
NATIVE CALIFORNIAN AND WHILE I
GREW UP IN LA I NOW LIVE IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. I'M A
PRACTICING ATTORNEY A NONPROFIT
CO FOUNDER AND DIRECTOR AND A
MOTHER AND A GRANDMOTHER. I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
CHAIRED STONE AND MEMBERS I'D
ALSO LIKE TO GIVE A SPECIAL
THANK YOU TO SENATOR SKINNER
THE RECOGNIZING THE NEED TO
MAINTAIN FAMILY BONDS. AND
RELATIONSHIPS IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF OUR CHILDREN. I'M
A PROUD AND HUMBLED COSPONSORED
SB THREE FIFTY FOR. THE REASONS
I SUPPORT THIS BILL. IT BECAUSE
I HAVE BEEN A CHILD IN FOSTER
CARE. A MOTHER WITH CHILDREN
PLACED INTO FOSTER CARE. AND A
GRANDMOTHER CAPS WITH BRINGING
MY GRANDSON HOME. FROM FOSTER
CARE. AS A THIRD GENERATION
CONVICTED FELONS SYSTEMS ARE
NOT NEW TO ME AND THE
GENERATIONAL IMPACTS WERE
REINFORCED WHEN I HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE ARE THEY PROP THAT.
THIRTY YEARS AWAY FROM MY
LASTING CAR SERRATION THE BEST
DID USE OF MY CONVICTIONS. THE
COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES OF
INCARCERATION SET THE STAGE FOR
AND OVER TWO HUNDRED THEY ARE
ESTATE PROCESS. I HAD BEEN IN
MY GRANDSON'S LIFE FROM DAY
ONE. HE WAS TAKEN FROM HIS
MOTHER AT COURT WHEN HE WAS SIX
MONTHS OLD HE WAS RIPPED AWAY
FROM EVERYONE HE KNEW. AND FROM
EVERYONE THAT KNEW AND LOVED
HIM NEED TO CALL CALL ON HIS
UNCLES. COUSINS I REMEMBER WHEN
I WAS THE KID OUT I USED TO
WONDER WHAT I HAD DONE WRONG
THE FIRST TIME THAT I WAS
PLACED IN FOSTER CARE. AS AN
ADULT I KNOW IT IS NEVER THE
CHILD'S FAULT. I BELIEVE THAT
SB THREE FIFTY FOUR WILL GIVE
CHILDREN THE BENEFIT OF AN
INDIVIDUALIZED ASSESSMENT
BEFORE MAKING PLACEMENT
DECISIONS. MAKING DECISIONS TO
PLACE CHILDREN OUTSIDE OF
FAMILY ESPECIALLY WHEN FAMILY
BONDS IN RELATIONSHIPS ARE IN
PLACE. SEVERAL FAMILIES IN A
WAY THAT HARMS OUR CHILDREN. I
HAVE NO POWER TO CHANGE THE
PAST. ALL I HAVE IS IT DAY. TO
DENY CHILDREN PLACEMENT OR DRAG
OUT THE ART THEY PROCESS
BECAUSE OF IT WERE BOOKABLE
PASS THAT HAVE NO NEXUS TO A
PERSON'S ABILITY TO LOVE AND
CARE FOR PROTECT. A RELATIVE OR
NON RELATIVE EXTENDED FAMILY
MEMBER IS A STRONG SENTENCE. I
DON'T SPEAK PROJECT MYSELF.
THIS IS A MAN IN THERE IS THERE
ARE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA LIKE ME. WHO
LIVE AND THRIVE IN SPITE OF OUR
PAST CONVICTIONS WE WANT TO BE
THERE FOR OUR FAMILIES AND
BREAK THE GENERATIONAL TIED TO
A CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. THAT
HAVE THE OVER RELIANCE ON
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS. WHEN
MAKING FAMILY DECISIONS. I
RESPECT ASK. THAT YOU BOTH YES
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE FIFTY
FOUR. BROWNLEE'S FIRST MEANS
ENSURING THE INTERESTS OF OUR
CHILDREN. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RIGHT ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WAS VACANT SUPPORTIVE SB.
THREE FIFTY FOUR. SEEING NONE
OF REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR SB. THREE FIFTY FOUR. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF BAT SPECIES THREE
FIVE FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE MINING CUTE
LINE FOR NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES NEW CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRISTOLOGY DOT COM BEHALF OF
THE CENTER FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND SB
THREE FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
RIGHT THANK YOU. I DO NOT HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION LISTED IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FIFTY
FOUR. SEEING NONE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO GET OPPOSITION TO SB. THREE
FIFTY FOUR. STATION TAX BE
THREE FIVE FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. WE THINK YOU
ARE PRETTY MAY CLOSE THE LINES
AND I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS TO THREATS. I WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE A PERSONAL POINT
OF PRIVILEGE AT THIS TIME AND
TO THANK THE WITNESS. MY DEAR
FRIEND GOING TO QUARRELS MY-
FELLOW ATTORNEY WHO HAS DONE SO
MUCH IN THE COMMUNITY AND NOT
ONLY FOR HER FAMILY BUT FOR SO
MANY. IN THE COMMUNITY SEEKING
A SECOND CHANCE- I AGREE WITH
HER COMMENTS AND- BELIEVE THAT
IT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO BE
SURE TO OPEN. THE POSSIBILITY
FOR THE LOVING FAMILY MEMBERS
TO TAKE CARE OF THE CHILDREN
BEFORE WE PUT THEM INTO FOSTER
CARE. AND ONE YEAH IS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE SOMEONE I WOULD TRUST
MY CHILDREN FOR MY SON WITH.
RIGHT I THINK THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED IF IT HAS NOT I WILL MOVE
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU IT HAS
BEEN MOVED. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THE SINGER OKAY THANK
YOU CENTER I WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE MY APPRECIATION WITH THIS
IS WE'VE CHANGED THE NOTION OF
SEPARATING HOW WE DEAL WITH
RELATIVE CARE GIVERS AND FOSTER
FAMILIES A CALL THE RESOURCE
FAMILIES NOW SO THAT WE CAN
GIVE SIMILAR SUPPORTS THE- HOLD.
BIASES TOWARDS WHAT A FAMILY IS
NEEDS TO BE CHANGING AS WELL
AND FOR US TO GET TO GO OUT
INTO AND GET FAMILIES
ESPECIALLY RELATIVES WHO ARE
WILLING AND ABLE TO BE THAT
APPROPRIATE FAMILY PLACEMENT
FOR THAT CHILD IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AND WE'VE BUILT INTO
MANY HURDLES ALONG THE WAY SO I
THINK THIS IS AN EXCELLENT BILL
AND VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
DIRECTION THAT WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO GO WITH THE ENTIRE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. MAKING IT
MORE EFFECTIVE FOR OUR KIDS. SO
WITH THAT. YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU- CHAIR- I THINK THE A
WITNESSES- GAVE GOOD
EXPLANATION BOTH OF THE- WHAT
WHAT THE BILL DOES IN THE NEED
FOR IT AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE THE MOST IN A SECOND
MOTION DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. STONE BYE STONE EYEING
GALLAGHER GALLAGHER I SHALL TO
DAVIES GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES
FIVE REYES AYE. THE BILLS OUT
OKAY THANK YOU. RIGHT WILL NOW
MOVE TO ITEM TWELVE SP FOUR
SIXTY ONE SENATOR CORTEZ E.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IT MEMBERS. THESE RESULTS
SENATE BILL FOR SIXTY ONE WHICH
WILL EMBRACE CONSUMER
PROTECTION I'M SORRY ENHANCE
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND FAIR
COMPETITION ENFORCEMENT BY
ALLOWING- THE AUTHORITY OF
LARGE COUNTY COUNCIL OFFICES
WITH THE PRE EXISTING AUTHORITY
OF THEIR CITY. ATTORNEY COUNTY
COUNTERPARTS CALIFORNIA'S
UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW. ALLOWS
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND CITY ATTORNEYS OF
CITIES WITH A POPULATION OF
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND THE AUTHORITY BRING
CIVIL ACTION AGAINST NEWBIES
BUSINESS PRACTICES HOWEVER
COUNTY COUNCILS DO NOT HAVE THE
SAME AUTHORITY. BY GIVING THE
STATE'S THREE LARGEST COUNTY
COUNCIL OFFICES LOS ANGELES SAN
DIEGO AND SANTA CLARA THE
AUTHORITY TO BRING YOU SEE ALL
ACTIONS SB FOUR SIXTY ONE WILL
CLOSE AN EXISTING FORCED ME GAP.
IN ENABLE THESE COUNTY COUNCILS
TO BETTER PROTECT CONSUMERS
IMPROVE AND PROMOTE FAIR
COMPETITION. THE BILL ALSO
ALIGNS WITH OTHER IMPORTANT
CONSUMER PROTECTION STATUTES IN
CALIFORNIA SUCH AS THE FALSE
ADVERTISING LAW WHICH BROADLY
AUTHORIZES COUNTY COUNCILS TO
COMBAT DECEPTIVE BUSINESS
PRACTICES SB FOUR SIXTY ONE IS
COSPONSORED BY SANTA CLARA AND
LOS ANGELES COUNTIES IN SUPPORT
OF BY THE LOS ANGELES DISTRICT
ATTORNEY. CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
AND CONSUMER FEDERATION SEIU
CALIFORNIA THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA AND EARTHJUSTICE
HERE TO TESTIFY TODAY IS JAMES
WILLIAMS. SANTA CLARA COUNTY
COUNCIL AND ROD CASTRO SILVA
LOS ANGELES COUNTY COUNCIL
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND I
HAVE THOSE TWO WITNESSES LISTED
JAMES WILLIAMS AND ROD CASTRO
SILVA JAMES WILLIAMS ARE YOU ON
THE LINE. GOOD AFTERNOON CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN STONE
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JAMES
WILLIAMS ON THE COUNTY COUNCIL
FOR THE COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA.
SANTA CLARA COUNTY URGES THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT SB FOUR
SIXTY ONE THE BILL OF THE NARAL
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
ALIGN THE AUTHORITY OF THE
THREE LARGEST COUNTY COUNCIL
OFFICES LOS ANGELES SAN DIEGO
AND SANTA CLARA. WITH THE
CORRECT AUTHORITIES THERE CITY
ATTORNEY COUNTERPARTS TO BRING
UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW CASES. I
NEED HELP ALREADY HAVE SOME
AUTHORITY UNDER ANOTHER KEY
CONSUMER PROTECTION STATUTE
FALSE ADVERTISING LAW. YET
WITHOUT UCL AUTHORITY ARE OFF
YOU CANNOT BRING UNFAIR
COMPETITION FALSE ADVERTISING
LAW CASES TOGETHER CREATING
SIGNIFICANT INEFFICIENCIES.
FURTHER THIS MISALIGNMENT
MCCARTY HAMSTRINGS OUR ABILITY
TO PROTECT CONSUMERS WHEN
STATEWIDE CONSUMER PROTECTION
NEEDS WORK THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO ADDRESS THEM. OUR
OFFICES ARE THE LARGEST AND
STATE HAVE STRONG REPUTATIONS
AND TRACK RECORDS AND HAVE THE
RESOURCES AND EXPERIENCE TO
LITIGATE OFTEN LONG TO COMPLEX
CONSUMER PROTECTION CASES. FOR
EXAMPLE THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
COUNSEL'S OFFICE HAS BEEN
LITIGATED CONSUMER PROTECTION
CASES FOR DECADES. YOU TO THAT
LITIGATION IN THE QUALITY OF
THE WORK CONDUCTED BY ATTORNEYS
OFFICE RECEIVED THE AMERICAN
BAR ASSOCIATION'S AWARD FOR
OUTSTANDING PERFORMANCE BY
PUBLIC. SECTOR LAW OFFICE
TWENTY NINETEEN. FURTHER OFFICE
PROVIDING LEGAL TO PROVIDE A
WIDE RANGE OF CRITICAL SERVICES
ACROSS OUR COUNTIES WE HAVE A
KEEN SENSE OF COMMUNITY NEEDS
THE LIGHT AT THE HEART CONSUMER
PROTECTION EFFORTS. AND OUR
OFFICES HAVE A GREAT HISTORY OF
JURISDICTIONAL COOPERATION AS
OUR LEAD PAYTON COPYRIGHT
LITIGATION CHAU. AS THE
COMMITTEE COUNSEL EXPORT
ANALYSIS EXPLAINS SB FOUR SIXTY
ONE DISTRICT COURT PROPOSAL
THAT WILL ADVANCE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS FOR COMPETITION
ACROSS THE STATE. BY ALIGNING
THE AUTHORITY OF LARGE
POPULATIONS HEALTH COUNCILS
WITH THE PURPOSE AND STRUCTURE
OF THE UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW.
I HOPE YOU WILL SUPPORT IT AT
THE END THREE QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE TO HEAR FROM MY LOS
ANGELES COUNTY COUNCIL
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU WHO RIDE CASTRO SILVA.
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN STONE AND
ARE RESPONSIBLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS RODRIGO
CASTRO SILVA AND ON THE COUNTY
COUNCIL FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
THE L. A. COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IS PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR AT THE FOUR SIXTY ONE
AND WE ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. SB FOUR SIXTY ONE WILL
ELIMINATE BARRIERS THAT
SEVERELY LIMIT MY OFFICE'S
ABILITY TO PURSUE UNFAIR
COMPETITION CASES TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND LAW ABIDING
BUSINESSES. WE HAVE THE
EXPERTISE TO PURSUE THESE
MATTERS ON A TRACK RECORD OF
SUCCESSFULLY LITIGATING COMPLEX
FALSE ADVERTISING CONSUMER AND
ENVIRONMENTAL CASES. THIS BILL
WILL EXPAND OUR ABILITY TO
PURSUE THAT IMPORTANT WORK. L.
A. COUNTY AS THE PRIMARY
PROVIDER SAFETY NET SERVICES
FOR OVER TEN MILLION PEOPLE ARE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AND BUSINESS AFFAIRS FIELD
INVESTIGATES CONSUMER
COMPLAINTS INVOLVING FORMER
POPULATIONS. INCLUDING THE
ELDERLY VETERANS IMMIGRANTS AND
THOSE EXPERIENCING POVERTY
INDEED IN TWENTY TWENTY THE CAN
RECEIVED OVER EIGHTY FIVE
HUNDRED CONSUMER COMPLAINT. NOT
HAVING FULL AUTHORITY UNDER THE
UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW HAS
LIMITED OUR ABILITY TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND LIMITED OUR
OPTIONS ON IMPORTANT ISSUES
LIKE ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC
HEALTH MATTERS. FOR EXAMPLE THE
EXITE FACILITY IN VERNON
OPERATED UNLAWFULLY PROTECTED
RELEASING LEAD INTO THE
COMMUNITY AND IMPACTING PUBLIC
HEALTH. OUR LEGAL OPTIONS WERE
LIMITED BECAUSE EXCITED NOT IN
THE UNINCORPORATED AREA OF THE
COUNTY AND WAS NOT VIOLATING A
COUNTY BOARD. IFSB FOUR SIXTY
ONE HAD BEEN THE LAW YEARS AGO
WE COULD HAVE TAKEN ACTION
AGAINST EXIDE. PROVIDING STATE
AND FEDERAL ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS
SB FOUR SIXTY ONE CAN HELP US
PROTECT IMPACT IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES AND PREVENT ANOTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL INJUSTICE LIKE
EXCITE. RECOGNIZING AN UNMET
NEED MY OFFICE ESTABLISHED IN
AFFIRMATIVE LITIGATION AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION DIVISION
WHICH IS STAFFED WITH FIFTEEN
EXPERIENCED ATTORNEYS. MANY
FROM OTHER PUBLIC PROSECUTOR
OFFICES. AS A FORMER FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR I UNDERSTAND THE
VALUE OF THAT EXPERIENCE AND
BEING ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY
LITIGATE THESE TYPES OF CASES.
WE ASK FOR YOUR YES VOTE SCOTT
PRUITT IS THE HEAD OF OUR
AFFIRMATIVE LITIGATION AND
CONSUMER DIVISION IS HERE WITH
ME TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. RIGHT WILL NOW MOVE
TO ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF SB FOUR
SIXTY ONE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
SEEING NONE AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE.
OPERATORS ARE PRETTY MUCH OF
THE LIGHTS WERE S. B. ANYONE
WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR SIXTY ONE AND AGAIN
WE'RE TAKING NAME AFFILIATION.
AND SUPPORT NO FURTHER
TESTIMONY. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. FOUR SIX
ONE THAT PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
TEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DO
HAVE ONE COMMENTING Q. IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR THAT
COMMENT. ONCE AGAIN I WILL JUST
BE ONE MORE MOMENT SURE THAT
COMMENTS. NINE FOUR NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
ELIZABETH
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
SENATOR CORTESE'S SB FOUR SIX
ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU WILL THEN MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE ONE WITNESS
LISTED EMILY HICKOK. ARE YOU
WITH US. I DO NOT SEE AMERI
DALVIN AT THIS TIME. OKAY MOVED
TO THE HEARING ROOM THAT ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF US BEFORE SIXTY
ONE. SEEING NONE THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE
ARE PRETTY WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB.
FOUR SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO ASK BE FORCED SIX ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I HAVE ONE COMMENT CHEN
Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THAT COMMENT YOU. LINE FOR
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN. HELLO HI MY NAME IS EMILY
HECOX- I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. FOUR SIXTY ONE I
WAS ON THE LINE BUT I DON'T
KNOW WHY YOU COULDN'T HEAR ME-
PREVIOUSLY ON MAC ON YES PLEASE
DO. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I'M A DEPUTY DSTRICT
ATTORNEY IN MONTEREY COUNTY AND
WORKED FOR THE PAST TEN YEARS
IN MY OFFICE IS CONSUMER AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION UNIT I
AM SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION AND I
ALONG WITH CDA RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU TO VOTE NO ON S. P. FOR
SIXTY ONE. CDA RESPECTABLE
PLAYED BY COUNTY COUNCIL AND WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY BELIEVE IN THE
GOAL OF ENHANCING CONSUMER
PROTECTION HOWEVER WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS BILL SOLVE THE
PROBLEM DOES NOT EXIST IN WILL
CREATE OTHER PROBLEMS THAT WILL
PROTEST. THE UNFAIR COMPETITION
LAW IS THE KEY ENFORCEMENT TOOL
USED TO COMBAT CONSUMER FRAUD
IN CALIFORNIA IT IS AN
INCREDIBLY BROAD STATUTE THAT
ALLOWS FOR CIVIL PENALTIES AND
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF AGAINST
COMMERCIAL ACTIVITY THAT
VIOLATES NOT ONLY STATE
STATUTES BUT EVERY OTHER RULE
REGULATION ORDER AN ORDINANCE
PROMULGATED BY EVERY LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT AND GOVERNMENTAL
AGENCIES. THE POWER GRANTED BY
THE UCL WITH EXTENDED EVEN
FURTHER JUST LAST YEAR WHEN THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT HELD
THAT THE UCL IS NOT LIMITED BY
THE GEOGRAPHIC BOUNDARIES OF
THE COUNTY MEANING THAT EACH
DISTRICT ATTORNEY CAN
EFFECTIVELY SEEK STATEWIDE
PENALTIES AND RELIEF FOR
CONDUCT OCCURRING OUTSIDE OF
THEIR JURISDICTION. SB PORT
SIXTY ONE WOULD ALLOW THREE
UNELECTED COUNTY COUNCIL TO
CIVILIANS FORCED NOT ONLY A
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
BUT THE PENAL CODE AS WELL AS
ANY OTHER RULE OR STATUTE THE
DECLARE SOME AFTER A COURSE OF
CONDUCT TO BE UNLAWFUL THIS
MEANS THAT UNELECTED COUNTY
COUNCIL WILL EFFECTIVELY HAVE A
CIVIL LAW ENFORCEMENT POWER
EQUAL TO THAT OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. THIS IS PARTICULARLY
CONCERNING BECAUSE THESE COUNTY
COUNCIL HAVE AT TIMES
CONTRACTED OUT AFFIRMATIVE
LITIGATION WORK. TO PRIVATE
CONTINGENCY FEE COUNCIL. THIS
CREATED AND HAN EVEN. BY GIVING
EXTREMELY BROAD LAW ENFORCEMENT
POWERS TWO ATTORNEYS THAT HAVE
A PECUNIARY STAKE IN THE
OUTCOME OF THE LITIGATION.
PROSECUTORIAL NEUTRALITY IS THE
CORNERSTONE OF THE UCL AND THE
PRACTICE OF USING CONTINGENCY
COUNCIL THREATENS TO UNDERMINE
THE PUBLIC'S FAITH IN UCL
ENFORCEMENT. IN SHORT THIS
MEANS THAT THESE UNELECTED
COUNTY COUNCIL COULD CONTRACT
WITH CONTINGENCY FEE COUNCIL
AND SET A LARGE UCL CASES ON
BEHALF OF THE ENTIRE STATE.
LASTLY THIS BILL SEEKS TO FILL
A GAP THAT DOES NOT EXIST DOES
COUNTY WOULD BE AFFECTED
ALREADY HAD CITIES WITH
POPULATIONS IN EXCESS OF SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND.
EACH OF WHICH HAS INDEPENDENT
UCL DAUGHERTY MORE IMPORTANTLY
EACH ALREADY HAS AN ELECTED
DISTRICT ATTORNEY WITH FULL UCL
AUTHORITY. I CAN SAY FROM
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE THAT THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION UNIT THAT
EACH OF THE URBAN COUNTIES IN
THE STATE ARE AMONG THE VERY
BEST IN TERMS OF QUALITY OF
WORK INVOLVED IN THE CASE IS.
ACTING AS A BACKSTOP TO ALL OF
US IS THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL WHICH ITSELF HAS A
ROBUST CONSUMER LAW SECTION
THAT PURSUED CASES AROUND THE
STATE. IN CONCLUSION WE BELIEVE
THIS WILL SOLVE THE PROBLEM
THAT DOES NOT EXIST WELL
CREATING OTHER CIVIL PROCESS.
WE ASK YOU TO VOTE NOW THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. RIGHT OPERATOR
ANYONE ELSE. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU.
RIGHT THANK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
LINES ARE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS PLEASE CONSULT. I'M A
LITTLE CONFUSED BY THE
OPPOSITION AND CORRECT ME IF
I'M I COULD HAVE THIS WRONG.
THE CITY OF SAN JOSE HAS AN
UNELECTED CITY ATTORNEY. IS
THAT CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT THE
SILICON CURRENTLY UTILIZE. THIS
PROVISION ALREADY YES OKAY HE'S
THE OF THESE THESE TYPES OF
ACTIONS- ON FOOT- THESE- FOR
COMPETITION ACTIONS CAN BE
BROUGHT BY THE CITY ATTORNEYS
IN THE DA'S THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL IT'S JUST COUNTY
COUNCIL SO CLEARLY THIS ALREADY
EXIST FOR A POSITION THAT'S ON
ELECTED PER SE BUT HAS THAT
THERE IS A LACK COULD INFLUENCE
TO SAY THE LEAST OVER IT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- THAT I'M GLAD
YOU PICKED UP ON THAT POINT I
THINK ALL OF US WHO SERVED
LOCAL GOVERNMENT NO OR
INTERACTED WITH LITTLE
GOVERNMENT KNOW. THAT COUNTY
COUNCILS- ENGAGE THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TYPICALLY IN A
CLOSED SESSION ENVIRONMENT
UNDER UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
BROWN ACT- ASKED FOR DIRECTION
TO- TO FILE AN ACTION LIKE THIS
SO THAT DIRECTIONS COMING NOT
ONLY FROM AN ELECTED OFFICIAL
BUT FROM A MAJORITY OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OR DOESN'T
PROCEED- AND- AND- BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY- IT YOU KNOW AT
THAT POINT THEY CAN MOVE
FORWARD IMMEDIATELY AND I THINK
REALLY THIS IS NOT. TAKING AWAY
ANYTHING FROM ANY OTHER OFFICE-
THIS IS A BOTH AND OR IN AN ALL
IN TYPE OF A SCENARIO WHERE IF
FOR THE A IN ONE OF THESE
THREE COUNTIES- IS AT CAPACITY-
AND THAT BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
SAYS LEAP INTO ACTION RIGHT NOW
PEOPLE ARE BEING HURT RIGHT NOW
WHAT THEY WANT IT IS THE COUNTY
COUNCIL VOTED TO GO INTO COURT
AND FILE FOR INJUNCTIVE RELIEF
FOR WHATEVER HE OR SHE NEEDS TO
DO IMMEDIATELY- AND NOT BE
SEEKING- OR GETTING IN LINE AT
THE DA'S OFFICE ON NOT TO SAY
THAT THE DA'S OFFICE. IS
CAUSING PROBLEMS OR DOING
ANYTHING- BUT GREAT WORK I
THINK IN ALL THESE KINDS OF
HISTORY SPEAK FOR COUNTY
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO REASON TO
PUT A COUNTY COUNSEL'S OFFICE
ON THE SIDELINES LIKE THE ONE
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY FOR
EXAMPLE WHICH IS- A CLAIM TO BE
ONE OF THE TOP. COUNTY COUNCIL
OFFICES IN THE COUNTRY IS
PURSUED WHAT PAINT HAS PURSUED
THE OPEN. ISSUE AND IS DONE IT.
A WITHOUT COLLEGE YOU KNOW- IN
ENGINE THAT'S WHAT THEY DO THEY
CREATE. BIG IMPACT LITIGATION
UNITS IN IN THESE COUNTY
COUNCIL OFFICES- AND- YOU KNOW
FRANKLY THE BLIND. AFTER EVEN
NOT NATIONAL LEADERSHIP OVER
THE PAST FOUR YEARS I THINK HER
WHERE THE- I UNDER THIS STATUTE
RIGHT. HE'LL IMMENSELY FOR THIS
BILL I HAVING SPENT A LOT OF
TIME OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
DEALING WITH THIS CODE IN YOU
KNOW IT WAS REPLACED IT WAS
PLACE WE UTILIZE THIS IN A
DIFFERENT STATUTE AND- SEEN THE
WAY THE INTERACTIONS OF VARIOUS
CITY ATTORNEYS IN SAN JOSE
VERSUS WHAT A SANTA CLARA
COUNTY MIGHT HAVE CHOSEN TO DO-
THE DA OF SAN FRANCISCO VERSUS
WHAT A SAN DIEGO DA- DID NOT
DO. CITY ATTORNEY IN SAN DIEGO
SO EIGHT IT I THINK LIKE YOU
THE MORE IN A SITUATION LIKE
THIS WHERE YOU HAVE THE
CAPACITY THE BETTER I ALSO WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR LEAVING SAN
DIEGO AND THAT I HEARD- SOME.
POSITION OF NEUTRALITY THAT
THEY WEREN'T GOING TO UTILIZE
THE STATUTE AND- I CAN
GUARANTEE I HAD A VERY LONG
CONVERSATION WITH THE- CHAIR OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS LAST
NIGHT NIGHT I THINK MAYBE
MAYBE. MAYBE IT WILL OUR COULD
BE UTILIZED- BY THE COUNTY I
DON'T THINK THERE WAS A- A
CLEAR INDICATION FROM FROM THE
MAJORITY OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THAT THIS WOULD NOT
BE UTILIZED IN SAN DIEGO SO- I
JUST WANNA THANK YOU I THINK
IT'S A GREAT DEAL AND- I. IS
THAT MOVED I WILL MOVE IT IF
NOT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND HOW
IT IS NOT A VALID DITTO TO WHAT
A SUMMER GONZALEZ SAID- CENTER
CORTESE AND THAT KIND OF A THIS
IS ADDITIVE IT'S AN ADDITIONAL
MEASURE TO ALLOW- INFORM FOR-
ACTION THAT CAN BE TAKEN TO
YOUR POINT- AND REALLY TO- SOME
OF HIS OFFICE PLANS WELL THAT.
YOU KNOW THE END OF THE DAY YOU
KNOW THERE THERE ARE A VARIETY
OF ELECTED POSITIONS AND THEY
TAKE DIFFERENT ROLES OR OR TAKE
A DIFFERENT VIEW OF WHAT THE
ROLE IS AT THE END IF YOU HAVE
A SITUATION WHERE A MAJORITY OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FEELS
THAT ACTION IS NECESSARY. I
THINK THAT THAT THAT'S A PRETTY
STRONG INDICATION. THAT THERE
SHOULD BE ACTION TAKEN AT THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S NOT FOREVER
REASON NOT WILLING TO TAKE CARE
OF THEIR OVER BURDENED WITH
WORK WHATEVER MAY BE- I THINK
THAT THE COUNTY COUNCIL UNDER
THE DIRECTION OF THOSE. ELECTED
TO POSITION OTHER OPPORTUNITIES
THANK YOU. THERE OU SUMMER. I%
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IDOL
THANK YOU. AB STONE RIGHT
STONEPINE GALLAGHER CHAU JUNE
DAVIES GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN HOLDEN I KALRA KALRA AYE
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN RADIUS. HELLO
HELLO HELLO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU GET MEMBERS.
TREASURY- WE WILL. CALL. FOR
CHARLES DAVIES. GONZALEZ. HI
GONZALEZ I. KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
YEAH- WHATEVER. HAS WHAT I
AGREE. OKAY SIR- I THINK MY
MICROSOFT BUT WE WERE JUST.
ADDING ON SO ITEM NUMBER THREE
SB SIXTEEN. CENTER SKINNER'S
BILL IS NOW OUT. SO WE GOT THE
ADDITIONAL VOTE ALL RIGHTS
SENATOR BAKER ITEM FOURTEEN SB
THREE FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. SB THREE FIFTY FIVE
REDUCE UNNECESSARY BARRIERS
KEEPING LOAN COMES CALIFORNIANS
FROM ACCESSING JUSTICE. THIS
BILL EXPANDS A LIST A PUBLIC
BENEFITS THAT AUTOMATICALLY
QUALIFY FOR FEE WAIVER AND USES
NEW INCOME THRESHOLDS THAT
REFLECT THE TRUE COST OF LIVING
IN CALIFORNIA. BUT MAKING SURE
THE PEOPLE WHO SHOULD QUALIFY
FOR FEE WAIVER CAN QUALIFY WHEN
THE ISSUE PLY. THE SUPPORT
CALIFORNIANS IN NEED. AND SAVE
VALUABLE JUDICIAL RESOURCES
CURRENTLY SPENT EDUCATING THESE
REQUESTS. ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
NOT BELIEVE IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT TO BOUNCE BACK FROM
THE CODEPEN DEMO. RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE I'VE TO
WITNESSES STANDING BY LEVINE
AND I USE A SENIOR ATTORNEY
THAT IS PROUD TO COMMUNITY AW
SERVICES. AND DOES RATE NGUYEN
WORTH DIRECTOR OF CONSUMER
JUSTICE CLINIC AT THE EAST BAY
COMMUNITY LAW CENTER. THANK YOU
I DO OF THOSE TWO WITNESSES.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND ALL RIGHT. THE NEW
TO NIGHT. ARE YOU WITH US ON
THE LINE. GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BENEFIT
NYACK AND I AM A SENIOR
ATTORNEY IN THE ECONOMIC
ADVANCEMENT PROGRAM MY
COMMUNITY LEGAL SERVICES AND
I'LL ALSO WE ARE PROUD TO
SPONSOR SB THREE FIFTY FIVE
WHICH WILL INCREASE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS BY UPDATING THE
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS FOR OUR-
SB THREE FIFTY FIVE BOOKS STAND
ELIGIBLE PUBLIC BENEFITS AND
INCREASE THE INCOME THRESHOLD.
FROM 110025% OF FEDERAL POVERTY
GUIDELINES 80% OF THE AREA
MEDIAN INCOME THE HIGHEST
COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE HIGHEST
STANDARDS UNDER THE STANDARD
80% OF THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME
IS CONSIDERED LOW INCOME STATUS.
I'D LIKE TO THANK COULD YOU
JUST COUNCIL CALIFORNIA
PROVIDING INSIGHT AND FEEDBACK.
AFTER THE CONSIDERATION FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL I'M
ARE YOU SEE THAT THE FOLKS AT
THE JCC SHARE IN OUR DEEP
CONCERN FOR ACCESS TO THE
COURTS. ESPECIALLY THE COPING
NINETEENTH AND DEMOCRATS
EXACERBATED AND DEEPEN THE
ECONOMIC DISPARITY. AND
FINANCIAL INSECURITY AMONG LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS. THE LOW
INCOME PEOPLE ARE AT RISK OF
EVICTION FORECLOSURE
UNEMPLOYMENT AND DEBT
COLLECTION. IN ORDER TO
ADVOCATE FOR THEMSELVES PEOPLE
MUST PAY COURT FINES BE THAT
CAN BE VERY COSTLY. HANG OUT OF
POCKET I AM SPEAKING. INCOME ON
THEIR SURVIVING MARC. WARREN
AND MANY OF OUR CLIENTS ARE.
STILL MODERNIZE UNITY LABOR
STRIKE UPDATING THE VARIOUS
WAYS THAT CONSUMERS. WOULD FACE
OUT. THANK THREE FIFTY OR ADD
ON AND LOOK BACK NO THANK
BLOCKS LOCAL. ONE FIFTY ACOSTA
FILING FEE AUTOMATIC. AND
THEREBY. JUSTICE. FURTHER AND
CREDIT BECAUSE NINETY AND THEN
NEARLY OF EVERY SIX MONTHS I'VE
FOUGHT THEIR JOB IN THE WHITE
UNDERSTAND INSURANCE BENEFITS
AND MEET. I UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE AND WITH LOOK AT. BY
I THINK THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
ARE. QUALIFY FOR THE LABOR TO
MORE ACT ARE PRETTY. OF THOSE
WHO NEED ACCESS THIS IS EXACTLY
JEFF. EXACTLY ARE YOUR I
THOUGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND THEN THERE'S A WHEN NORTH.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND OF THE
CAN MY NAME IS DESIREE ALL
RIGHT AND I AM TO OF THE TO IS
GOING AT LEAST THEY CAN YOU LOS.
AND RECENTLY THE FORMER
KEEPER'S ATTORNEY FOR THE
CONSUMER ADVOCACY PROJECTS AT
THE JACKSON EVERS THE CENTER OF
THE BAR ASSOCIATION OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN MY CURRENT AND
PREVIOUS ROLE I OVERSEE A
CLINICAL COMICALLY LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS IN THE BAY AREA MANY
OF YOU NEED HELP WITH A MATTER
IN COURT. ALL OF MY CLIENTS
QUALIFY FOR THE WAIVER IT IS
GOING TO ASK ME THAT TWO IN
FIVE OUT OF EVERY ONE OF THE
CLIENTS THAT QUALIFY UNDER THE.
FIVE G. DISCRETIONARY PORTION
OF THE FORM. NOT MY CLIENTS
CALL. UNDER HEALTH WILL INCOMES.
OF THE WAY REFORM BECAUSE THE-
IN. AS FAR TOO WELL. I THINK.
FIVE FIVE WILL PROVIDE A MUCH
NEED AT THE IF YOU HAVE A- BY.
THE IN. SKINNER TO BETTER
COMPLETELY DISCOUNTED IN
CALIFORNIA AND TESTING AND THE
FINAL POVERTY LINE. I THANK
YOU. FOR HOUSEHOLD INCOME THAT
INCLUSIONARY TO THE AREAS WHERE
THE COST OF LIVING ARE HIGHER.
AS WELL AS THE RATE OF DEBT
COLLECTION LAWSUITS. SB THREE
BYFIVE WILL DO A NUMBER OF
THINGS. INCLUDING REDUCE COURT
TIME FOR DISCRETIONARY HEARINGS
WITH THE WINNERS. HELP LOW
INCOME AMERICANS WHO HAVE TO
TAKE TIME OFF OF WORK OR
SOMETIME DURING FOR CHILD CARE.
AND OVERALL INCREASE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE. BUT THE THING CON.
COULD THE EXAM THE FORMER. WITH
A SINGLE. OF TWO. AND A- THAT
DOLLAR THE AND CAN'T. UNDER THE
CURRENT. FORM IN ORDER FOR HER
TO CALL FOR THE LABOR IN HER
HOUSEHOLD INCOME. ANNUAL SALARY
FOR HER FAMILY AT THREE. COULD
NOT EXCEED JUST OVER TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
STILL DESPITE THEIR FINANCIAL
INFORMATION SHOWING AND THAT
BALANCE OF TWENTY TWO DOLLARS
EACH MONTH. IT'S QUITE STILL
HAD TO TAKE TIME OFF OF WORK TO
GO TO A FEE WAIVER HEARING. FOR
HER DETAILED AND PERSONAL
FINANCIAL STATEMENT WAS
CRITICIZING OPEN COURT. VERY
INTIMIDATING HUMILIATE PROCESS.
AND LIKE ALL OTHER. WHO ARE WHO
FELL OUT THE FIVE SEATED.
PORTION SHOULD ULTIMATELY
GRANTED THAT THE WAIVER. THE
ONLY TIME OUR CLIENTS DO NOT
GET THEIR P. WAIVERS GRANTED IS
WHEN THEY CAN'T EXTRACT THE
HEARING BECAUSE THEY CANNOT GET
THE DAY OFF OF WORK. I'VE BEEN
NONPROFIT DIRECTOR LEGAL
SERVICE PROVIDER WE ARE DEEPLY
SYMPATHETIC CONSTRUCTION WEEK
RECORD OF THE STATE. HOWEVER
ACCORDING COURT THESE
INDESTRUCTIBLE WHO HAD OT
CHOSEN TO BE SEATED IS NOT THE
WAY TO FIND OUR COURT.
CHANGEABLE LOW. CHANGES THE
WORLD. TAX FOR THE HARD. AREA
MEDIAN. FOR THE HIGHEST
COMPLIMENT STATE WILL MEET THE
PRACTICAL NEEDS FOR.
IMPLEMENTATION BY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. I LOVE THE ONE THAT
THE BURDEN FROM AN ARDUOUS
PROCESS. BURKE THE WAIVER
HEARING FOR MANY LOW INCOME
PEOPLE. PEOPLE WHO WOULD
ULTIMATELY BE GRANTED TO BE
LATER. I THOUGHT I RESPECTFULLY
URGE EITHER. SB THREE BY FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. RIGHT NOW
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FIFTY FIVE. SEEING NONE AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO DECADE SUPPORT
FOR SB THREE FIFTY FIVE. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE FIVE FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
BORDERLINE SPOHR NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DANIELLE KENDO KAISER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN FIVE OH
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS
THOUGHT IT UP ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN FOR EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MISTER CHAIR MIKE CARROLL WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW POPPY
WE'RE ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU WE WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION
I HAVE NO OPPOSITION LISTED IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FIFTY
FIVE. C. NOT REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION TO SB.
THREE FIFTY FIVE. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE FIVE FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY SHOW ONE MINING Q.
LINE FIVE HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I FELT ROTTEN ON BEHALF
OF CENTER PER SPONSOR LANDING-
CALLING IN IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME RIGHT
THANK YOU OPERATOR YOU MAY
CLOSE THE LINES AND I WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MISTER KALRA THANK YOU SURE
THANK YOU SO ON THE BACK OF
FROM PREVIOUS FOR LONG OVERDUE-
AS SOMEONE THAT SAW THIS FIRST
HAND PUBLIC DEFENDER INTERESTED
NOT JUST THE BURDEN AS I THINK
THE WITNESSES. CAMINO REAL
REALLY WELL ARTICULATED IN
TERMS ON THE INDIVIDUAL IN THE
LOW INCOME FAMILIES BUT THE
AMOUNT OF COURT ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS THAT GO INTO. THE DRAW TO
AFFIRM AND REAFFIRM- THE INCOME
LEVELS AS ENORMOUS AS WELL AND
I THINK THAT NOT ONLY WITH THIS
RIGHT SIZE- THE LOW INCOME
ELIGIBILITY BUT IT WILL I THINK
ALSO REDUCE CORE CLASSES SO
THAT EVEN. THERE'S ALWAYS A
CONVERSATIONAL YOU KNOW. HAVE
AN IMPACT ON. KIND OF HOW MUCH
FINE OR FEES ARE INTO THIS. BUT
I THINK IT'S ALL WASHED REALLY
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT HOW MUCH
TIME ENERGY GOES INTO. KIND OF
A MEANS TESTING ASPECT OF IT.
AND SO THANK YOU SO MUCH BRING
THIS FORWARD. THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU. THE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. I
SEE NONE SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE.
ESPECIALLY AFTER I VOTE. THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA PLEASE.
STONE ALL RIGHT STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. CHAU CHIU DAVIES
GONZALEZ GONZALZ TIE HOLDEN.
KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN AND REYES. IS THAT
THE BILL IS ON CALL AND WE WILL
BE THREE MORE VOTES WE HAVE ONE
MORE BILL SB THREE FORTY THREE
SENATOR ALAN WE HEARD FROM.
CENTER VALLEY. THE VILLAGE.
OKAY SO WE GET IS CENTER I
WOULD GET HERE AND THEN IF
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WOULD ALSO COME BACK SO WE CAN.
FINALIZE BILLS WE HAVE TWO
BILLS ON CALL AND WE WILL HAVE
FIVE BILLS TO FINISH UP TODAY.
GENERATING RIGHT. ALL YEAH. THE
STUFF.
YEAH. VERY GOOD SENATOR
ALAN. ADAM NUMBER FIFTEEN SB
THREE FORTY THREE. THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
LOOK AT I LIKE THE STAFF I LIKE
WHAT I HAVE HERE- I KNOW YOU
GOT A VERY LONG DAY I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS
VERY IMPORTANT BILL. I WOULD BE
TODAY I HAVE- MICHAEL DAFT FOR
THE PUBLIC SERVICES AND HEIDI
SANBORN FROM NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP ACTION COUNCIL. TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. RIGHT THANK
YOU I DO HAVE THOSE TWO
WITNESSES HEIDI SANBORN AND
MICHAEL DAFT HEIDI SANBORN ARE
YOU WITH US. I AM CARE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU KAREN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS AGAIN ID
SANBORN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE NATIONAL SEARCH BACKING
COUNCIL A NONPROFIT THAT
ADVOCATES FOR CIRCULAR ECONOMY
WHERE CO SPONSOR SB THREE FOUR
THREE. I THOUGHT THE PRIVILEGE
OF SERVING AS CHAIR OF THE
STATEWIDE COMMISSION ON
REFLECTING MARKET MAKERS START
RECYCLING A GROUP OF SEVENTEEN
DIVERSE STAKEHOLDERS TO
REPRESENT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WASTE HAULERS NGOS RECYCLERS
AND MORE IT IS TASKED WITH
PROVIDING ADVICE ON HOW TO
REDUCE CONTAMINATION IN
CALIFORNIA'S RECYCLING STREAM.
THE COMMISSION HAS ALREADY
RELEASED YOUR REPORT AND THIRTY
UNANIMOUSLY SUPPORTED POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE THIRTEEN OF WHICH
HAVE ALREADY RESULTED IN ACTION
BY THE STATE SB THREE FOUR
THREE THE BASE POLICY
RECOMMENDATION NUMBER FIFTEEN
WHICH RECOMMENDS TRUTHFUL
LABELING TO REDUCE
CONTAMINATION AND IMPROVE
RECYCLING AND RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS CONSENSUS AMONG THE
SEVENTEEN- COMMISSIONERS. THE
CHECKING OUR ASSEMBLE IS THE
UNIVERSAL SYMBOL FOR
RESPECTABILITY A COMPANIES ARE
CURRENTLY ALLOWED TO PLACE
SYMBOL ON PRODUCTS THAT CANNOT
BE RECYCLED. SUCH AS BAGS IN
SOLO CUPS. THIS CREATES CAN
THAT WE DRESS TO. DURING THINGS
AWAY THAT ARE NON RECYCLED FULL
PACKAGES IN THE RECYCLING
STREAM. THEREBY CONTAMINATING
RECYCLABLES AND INCREASING
SORTING COSTS THAT ARE BORNE BY
RATEPAYERS. ACCORDING TO THE
CONSUMER BRANDS ASSOCIATION-
REPORT REDUCE REUSE AND
CONFUSE. ONLY 4% OF U. S.
RESPONDENTS SAID THE RECYCLING
IS NOT CONFUSING. WHAT DO THE
RIGHT THING BUT THEY FEEL LIED
TO WHEN THEY LEARNED THAT SOME
OF THESE PRODUCTS AND PACKAGING
THAT BEAR THE CHASING ASSEMBLE
ARE NOT RECYCLABLE AND THEY GET
MAD AT GOVERNMENT FOR ALLOWING
THESE COMPANIES TO USE THIS
DECEPTIVE LABELING. SB THREE
FOUR THREE WILL STOP TO
TRANSLATE LYING AND ALLOW
CONSUMERS TO MAKE INFORMED
PURCHASING DECISIONS BASED ON
THE RECYCLABILITY OF THE ITEMS
THEY PURCHASE AND CALIFORNIA
SHOULD NOT BE BEHOLDEN TO LAWS
IN OTHER STATES THAT ALLOW
CONFUSING AND MISLEADING
LABELING. CALIFORNIANS DEMAND
THE TRUTH AND WE MUST SLEEP AND
AS A NATIONAL OGANIZATION THE
NATIONAL SEARCH BACKING COUNCIL
IS COMMITTED TO HELPING AND IS
RIVER ROAD THE CHASING ARROWS
REQUIREMENTS AND OTHER STATES
AND CREATE A ROLE THAT
HARMONIZE. AND THAT IS WHAT WE
ALL DESIRE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
N. SENATORS SINCE YOU DID TOO
MUCH FOR PRESENTATION THERE ARE
AMENDMENTS. THAT ARE LISTED
YOUR THINKING THOSE OF A YES I
AM ABSOLUTELY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS AND I THINK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ITS WORK. THANK
YOU THANK YOU ALL RIGHT MICHAEL
DAFT WHO'S WITH US IN PERSON.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS MICHAEL DAFT WITH THE
FAMILY ON BEHALF OF REPUBLIC
SERVICES. A LEADING AWAY
SERVICES PROVIDER IN THE NATION.
THIS MEASURE IS A AS MUCH ABOUT
TRUTH IN ADVERTISING AS IT IS
ABOUT IMPROVING CALIFORNIA'S
RECYCLING SYSTEM CALIFORNIA'S
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE IS ONE
OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT RECYCLING SYSTEMS IN
THE WORLD. BUT IN SPITE OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS BEING
INVESTED INTO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO IMPROVE
RECYCLING CONTAMINATION REMAINS
ONE OF OUR MOST DIFFICULT AND
EXPENSIVE OBSTACLES.
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS HAVE
BEEN MADE IN MANUAL SORT LINES
OPTICAL SORTERS SCREENS
SHREDDER'S BLOWERS AND OTHER
ADVANCED TECHNOLOGIES. BUT
THESE TECHNOLOGIES AND
EQUIPMENT ARE FAR MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN CONSUMER
EDUCATION. AND EFFECTIVE SOURCE
SEPARATION. LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
AND THEIR LOCAL HAULERS SPEND
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY EDUCATE OUR CUSTOMERS
ON WHAT IS RECYCLABLE IN AN
EFFORT TO IMPROVE RECYCLING
RATES AND REDUCE CONTAMINATION
AND RECYCLING COSTS. BUT THOSE
DOLLARS ARE WASTED IF PACKAGING
MATERIALS INCLUDE MARKINGS THAT
FALSELY CLAIM THOSE PACKAGES OR
MATERIALS ARE RECYCLABLE. THESE
LABELS CONFUSE CONSUMERS AND
MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT TO
CORRECTLY IDENTIFY WHICH SHOULD
BE PLACED IN THE BLUE RECYCLING
BIN. AS AN EXAMPLE WELL PLASTIC
FILM IS A CHEAP PACKAGING
OPTION IT CONSTITUTES LESS THAN
5% OF THE WASTE STREAM. THE
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF WASTE
ACCOUNTS FOR A MAJORITY OF
PROBLEMS COMING UP OUR
MACHINERY CREATING LETTER
PROBLEMS AND INCREASING THE
COST OF RECYCLING OVERALL BY
ATTEMPTING TO REMOVE THEM FROM
OUR WASTE STREAM. CONSUMERS
SHOULD NOT BE LED TO BELIEVE
THAT THESE BAGS ARE TRULY
RECYCLABLE UNLESS MARKETS EXIST.
SB THREE FORTY THREE SETS IN
THE ACTIVE IN CLEAR STANDARD
FOR RECYCLABILITY. THAT WILL
INCREASE RECYCLING EFFICIENCIES
IMPROVE CONFIDENCE IN
RECYCLING. AND WILL REDUCE
RECYCLING COSTS FOR RATEPAYERS
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND
RECYCLERS WE ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE VOTE I'D ON SENATE BILL
THREE FORTY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. RIGHT WILL NOW MOVE
TO OTHERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FORTY THREE IS THERE ANYONE. IN
THE HEARING ROOM. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ALEXIS
CHAVEZ I'M WITH CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE AND STRONG
SUPPORT WE'RE ALSO PROUD TO.
SPONSOR I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO
VOICE THEIR SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF. THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE. OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND THE
CLEAN SEIZE COALITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE. RIGHT
SEEING NONE THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB THREE
FORTY THREE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. THREE FOUR THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AT TEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT
FIVE RANGING Q. WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO FIVE OH FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE FIVE ZERO FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT FIVE OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
FIVE ZERO EIGHT TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TRY
RIGHT FIVE OR NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GET AFTERNOON AFTER CARE
NUMBER OF THIS IS JENNIFER
FEARING CARP BANG IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE OCEAN CONSERVANCY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT FIVE
OH SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE NUMBERS BUT
YOU'RE MCKAY ON BEHALF OF THE
RETHINK WASTE AND SEVEN
GENERATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN FIVE OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JIM ONE BURKE ON BEHALF
OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE ONE MORE COMMENT THANK YOU
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT SURE
THAT MY NUMBER. THANKS FIVE
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING CARE MEMBER CHRIS THANK
YOU DOLLARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT YOUR CHECK
CAMPBELL AND STOP WAIT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW MOVES INTO A POSITION
AND I HAVE TWO WITNESSES LISTED
LAURA AGUILAR. AND SHANNON
CRAWFORD BOTH- ZAG YOU ARE IS
ON THE PHONE AND JAN CRAWFORD
0% I BELIEVE. SO WILL TAKE
SHARON CRAWFORD FIRST.
INTERMENTS KNOWN TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
SHANNON CRAWFORD AND I'M WITH
THE PLASTICS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT THE
ENTIRE SUPPLY CHAIN FOR
PLASTICS MANUFACTURING IN THE
UNITED STATES WHICH INCLUDES
OVER SIXTY ONE THOUSAND WORKERS
IN CALIFORNIA. SUSTAINABILITY
IS A PRIMARY FOCUS OF OUR
MEMBERS IN OUR SOCIO HAITIAN
OUR MEMBERS ARE INTENT ON USING
RECYCLED CONTENT AND CREATING
AND MARKET SO THAT LESS
MATERIAL GOES TO LANDFILLS. I'M
TESTIFYING TO EXPRESS OUR
CONCERNS WITH SB THREE FORTY
THREE BECAUSE IT WILL LIMIT
STRONG AND VIABLE RECYCLING
MARKETS IN THE STATE
SPECIFICALLY OF PT THERMOFORMED
POLYPROPYLENE. WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH SENATOR ALLEN'S
OFFICE FOR SEVERAL YEARS ON SB
FIFTY FOUR TO CREATE A BROADER
SOLUTION TO IMPROVE RECYCLING
MARKETS IN THE STATE WILL HOPE
TO CONTINUE THESE CONVERSATIONS
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE MORE
PLASTICS. SHOULD BE RECYCLED IN
THE STATE NOT LESS. SB THREE
FORTY THREE HAS STARTED A LONG
OVERDUE AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION ON THE RISEN RESIN
IDENTIFICATION CODE OR THE
RISK. THE CURRENT STANDARD
DICTATES THIS COACH SHOULD BE
PLACED INSIDE A TRIANGLE AND
DISPLAYED INCONSPICUOUSLY ON
BOTTLES AND RIGID PLASTIC
CONTAINERS. UNFORTUNATELY
TWENTY NINE STATES STILL
REQUIRE THE CODE BE PLACED
INSIDE THREE CHASING ARROWS.
CREATING SIGNIFICANT CONSUMER-
CONFUCIAN. CLASSICS IS
COMMITTED TO WORKING- TO
SUPPORT EFFORTS IN THESE TWENTY
NINE STATES TO FOLLOW
CALIFORNIA'S LEAD. AND UPDATE
THEIR CODES. WE SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
AMENDMENT WHICH ALLOWS OUR
INDUSTRY ADDITIONAL TIME TO
WORK WITH THESE OTHER STATES.
AND OUR MEMBERS ADDITIONAL IME
TO COMPLY BY UPDATING THEIR
MOLDS. WE'RE STILL VERY
CONCERNED REGARDING THE
LANGUAGE OF THIS LEGISLATION
THAT USES THE SAME CRITERIA-
THAT WE JUST SAW COME OUT OF
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
RECYCLING MARKETS IN CURBSIDE
RECYCLING. THAT LIST ONLY P. ET
IN HDPE BOTTLES AS RECYCLABLES.
PT THERMAL FORMS A CLAM SHELLS
WHICH PACKED SO MUCH OF
CALIFORNIA'S FRESH PRODUCE.
WOULD NOT BE CONSIDERED
RECYCLABLE AND WOULDN'T NEITHER
WOULD POLYPROPYLENE WHICH HAS
MATERIAL QUALITIES. MAKING IT
THE PREFERRED RESIN FOR A
VARIETY OF FOOD AND SAFETY
PRODUCTS. THIS CHAMBER ALSO
RECENTLY PASSED A BEFORE
SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH REQUIRES
RECYCLED CONTENT IN PLASTIC
THERMOFORMED. HOWEVER THE BILL
BEFORE YOU WOULD DEEM THOSE
ITEMS NON RECYCLABLE AND THEY
WOULD BE LANDFILLS. MAKING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT IMPOSSIBLE. REAL
IMPROVEMENTS CAN ONLY BE
ACHIEVED BY AN EMPHASIS ON
DEVELOPING AN MARKETS WHICH IS
WHY WE SUPPORT. CONTINUED WORK
ON SB FIFTY FOUR AS AMORE
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION TO
ADDRESS THE RECYCLING CENTER
CONCERTS IN THE STATE. IS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN SB THREE
FORTY THREE WILL REDUCE REAL
RECYCLING N THE STATE. HOWEVER
WE LOOK FORWARD THERE ARE
CONTINUED WORK WITH SENATOR
ALLEN AND HIS STAFF ON
SOLUTIONS TO MAKE THIS BILL
WORKABLE. AND HELP IMPROVE
RECYCLING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND THEN LORD I WE ARE WITH
WHO'S WITH US ON THE TELEPHONE
ARE YOU HERE. I AM CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
SHARE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LAURA
AGUILAR AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING. AMERICAN AND THE
FLEXIBLE PACKAGING ASSOCIATION
BOTH ASSOCIATIONS REPRESENT
PACKAGING MATERIALS ACQUIRED
PACKAGING PRODUCER THAN
CONSUMER GOOD COMPANIES. I AM
TESTIFYING TODAY IN AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION THAT
THE THREE FORTY THREE A
CURRENTLY DRAFTED THE BILL
WOULD RESTRICT THE USE OF. USE
OF THE TAKING CARE OF THE BALL
AND THE PRODUCT OF NOT BEING TO
BE RECYCLABLE BY COUNTY. WHICH
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS ARE WORKING
TO INCREASE THE RECYCLING IN
THE REUSE THAT THE PACKAGING
WHICH WE NOW WITH THE GOAL OF
THE AUTHOR OF GOAL OF THE
COMMITTEE ANIMAL FOR
CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE MULTIPLE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE BEEN HAVING
WHAT DOCTORS OFFICE AND MAKE
THOUGHTFUL JESUS IN THE
LANGUAGE SO WE CAN TALK
INSEMINATION IN THE CURBSIDE
BIN. AND HALF AND HELP MORE
MATERIALS GET RECYCLED IN
CALIFORNIA SHOULD WE DO HOPE
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS AROUND THE
RECYCLABILITY CRITERIA AND
DEFINITION OF WHAT WILL BE
RECYCLABLE IN CALIFORNIA I'D
LOVE THAT A EDERAL STANDARD ON
LABELING IS ENACTED IN THE
FUTURE BUT IT'S ALL TAKE THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION. OUR MEMBERS
WANT TO ENSURE TALK TO ENSURE
CONSISTENCY WITH EACH OF OUR A
LOT THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY. AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU. SO NOW
MOVE TO OTHER WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION IS ROOM.
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. C.
NOT REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO'D
LIKE TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO
SB THREE FORTY THREE WE'RE
TAKING NAME AFFILIATION AND
OPPOSITION. Q. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB THREE
FOUR THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FIVE
RANGING Q. OVER TWO LINES FOR
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON NICOLE KIANA
REPRESENTING THE HELPFUL
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
AND THE PET FOOD INSTITUTE WITH
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
COMMISSION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN TRIED FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHEN MEMBERS MANUALLY ON
BEHALF OF THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COUNCIL ALSO PUT MORE
CEMENTED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN STRIVE TWELFTH PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JIM SHUFFLING
WITH AMERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL- POSING AS AMENDED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN FIVE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN BERTHON CAP KEY
WITH MY Q. CAP CAN ASSIST YET
SOMEHOW THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO WITH AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN FOR SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOHN
CAMPUS INSTITUTION OF HOME
APPLIANCE MANUFACTURERS AND WE
ARE OPPOSED TO LAST AMENDED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THE TIME. THANK YOU OPERATOR
YOU MAY CLOSE THE LINES AND
I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. RIGHT SEEING. WE DO
HAVE MOTION ALREADY THANK YOU
CNN CENTER YOU MAY CLOSE YEAH I
APPRECIATE- THE COMMENTS I MEAN
I DO WANT TO SAY THAT WERE WE
ARE WORKING TO CONFORM THE
LANGUAGE OF THE TEAM FELT
REALLY INTO SEVERAL THURMOND-
TO THERMOFORM OCAS LAST WE WANT
TO DO IS TO DECREASE RECYCLING
BUT THE TRUTH THE MATTER AS THE
CURRENT SITUATION IS LEADING TO
PROBLEMS IN A RECYCLING SYSTEM
ASK ANY HOLLER WHEN ANYONE IS
TRYING TO HIDE. DISAGGREGATE
THESE ITEMS- SO I DISAPPROVE
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND- AND WILL VERY
MUCH CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND THOSE WHO HAVE
CONCERNS BUT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL THAT THAT IT
THAT BASICALLY SAYS IF YOU
CAN'T SAY THAT AN ITEM IS
RECYCLABLE BECAUSE OF OUR TRUTH
IN ADVERTISING LAWS YOU
SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO PUT THE
CHASING EURO SYMBOL THAT
EVERYBODY RECOGNIZES THE SYMBOL
FOR RECYCLING ON YOUR ON YOUR
ITEM. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE. HI STONE FIVE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER NOTES. TO
CHIU FIVE. DAVID DAVIES NOW
BEEN SALAS HI GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN IN SHANGHAI RAAS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THE BILL
NEEDS ONE MORE SO I'M GONNA PUT
IT ON CALL THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. RIGHT IF WE COULD
GET MEMBERS BACK SO WE CAN ROLL
THROUGH THESE FIVE TO LET'S GO
THROUGH THESE FIVE RIGHT NOW
FOR MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE. AND
WE'LL START WITH. SB SIXTEEN.
SENATOR SKINNER CAUCUS MEMBERS.
BURKE CHAU DAVIES DAVIES NO
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN MENTION ARE
THANK YOU AND THEN ITEM NUMBER
FOR SB THREE FIFTY FOUR ALSO
SKINNER. CHAU CHIU CHU AYE
DAVIES DAVIES HI KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN. MENTION ARE THANK
YOU ADAM NUMBER TWELVE SB FORTY
SIX CORTESE IS ON CALL A MENTAL
IF THE CALL. GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NOTE SHALL. CHU CHU
AYE DAVIES DAVIES NOW. KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN II
REYES. THE BILLS OUT. AND THEN
SB THREE FIFTY FIVE ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN BAKER CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS. GALLAGHER. CHAU CHU
CHU BY DAVIES DAVIES I HOLDEN.
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN CHINA HI RES.
OKAY THE BILLS OUT AND THEN
THREE THINK EVERYBODY HERE. HAD
GONE UP ON THAT. WHERE HAD
VOTED ON THE- YEAH OKAY SO I'M
GONNA HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR A
LITTLE BIT LONGER. FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO COME AS FOR ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN SB THREE FORTY
THREE THAT IS STILL ON CALL WE
DO NEED ONE MORE VOTE FOR IT.
DO YOU HAVE INFORMATION ON THE
BILL YEAH. THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
PEOPLE. FIVE WHOSE JOB IS SO WE
HAVE FIVE. FIVE THIS IS THE
MEASURE OF ALL THE- SEVERAL OF
THEM OUT. OF ALL THE PRODUCTS
ARE OF THE VIEW OF YOUR- AB HAS
BEEN GOING IN AND OUT THESE. NO
I ARE NOT EXPECTED TO RISE.
RIGHT. ABOUT.
FIVE ALL RIGHT
WELCOME MISTER TALCO WE HAVE
FIVE BILLS. TO CATCH UP ON
COULD WE GO THROUGH THOSE. SO
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB SIXTEEN
SKINNER. CHAU CHANNEL FIVE
OTHER NUMBER FOR SB THREE FIFTY
FOUR SKINNER. CHAU CHAVEZ THEN
I REMEMBER TWELVE SB FORTY SIX
CORTESE. CHAO CHOW HIGH. I
REMEMBER FOURTEEN SB THREE
FIFTY FIVE BACKER CHAO CHAO II.
THEN ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN SB
THREE FORTY THREE ALLEN IS ON
CALL ON THE LIFT THE CALL CHAU
CHAVEZ RIGHT THANK YOU THAT
BILL IS OUT. THANK YOU.
TWELVE
AND FOURTEEN FOR HIS ARREST.
OKAY SO IS REYES. I REMEMBER
TWELVE SB FORTY SIX CORTESE.
REYES AYE. IN ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN SB THREE FIFTY FIVE
BECKER. REYES HI. AND DO WE
HAVE THIS RACE ON ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN SB THREE FOUR THREE
OKAY AS A THREE FORTY THREE
RACE REYES AYE. OKAY YEAH WE
HAVE A RUN ITEM NUMBER THREE
AND FOUR. YES. OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY WE HAVE COMPLETED OUR WORK
FOR TODAY AND WITH THAT WE ARE
ADJOURNED THANK YOU ALL.